Ooh One.
Yes,
we're live,
ladies and gentlemen.
UFC two or four or five companion with my brother edge reprise here.
Hello.
First time ever in the fight companion.
Cameron Hanes is here.
Ladies and gentlemen.
What's up?
And of course Brandon motherfucking show up.
Hey,
big bro.
And we're here live for the uh,
Bisping versus Henderson rematch of fucking huge fight for the middleweight
championship of the world and Bisping's home town of Manchester,
England.
They are going to be going off whenever law in that cage.
Never lost where?
Over there?
Yeah,
over there.
He's never lost.
Well Dude,
there's some serious love for Bisping in Manchester.
When I went to Bisbing,
uh,
to,
to Manchester to watch him fight,
I remember thinking it was a match.
I've seen him fight a couple of times in England,
I believe.
But when you,
when you see him over there,
you realize,
oh,
they just don't like them.
And certain parts of America that in,
in England,
he's gigantic superstar.
He's the reason why I'm in May so big UHG over there.
Like you don't realize it because it's been a bunch of times,
for whatever reason,
the fans turned against him and some some events and here for talking shit when
he said the f Word Fag.
But in England it's different.
It's not the homosexual term.
It's like a cigarette.
Yes.
So when he uses it,
you know what I'm saying?
He didn't mean it in that tone.
Right.
But that's how he was saying it.
He wasn't saying it like it was a cigarette.
He was saying that but,
but,
but over there it's a little different.
You know what I'm saying?
Like they throw it around in a different connotation.
This is what you always understand when it comes to trash talking,
when two dudes or trash talking each other,
you cannot expect them to keep it PC.
Okay.
What they're trying to do is humiliate each other,
his verbal warfare.
And you can't say that that's his position on gay.
People know if he's,
I mean maybe it's rude for him to say it.
Maybe he's rude for him to insinuate there's anything wrong with being
homosexual.
Definitely he's fucking with that guy.
You got to understand this is not like a deposition in court.
This is not like his ultimate feelings on homicide.
Donald Trump shit is concentrated fat cause he wants to punch him in the face he
wants.
Yeah.
Hopefully it doesn't run for presidency.
Exactly.
We were talking about that Trump thing where over here
it's like that movie,
the campaign with Will Ferrell.
You can't make this shit up.
How crazy is it?
A joke to say,
hey,
you better watch what you say or murdered by Hillary.
That crazy.
It's a joke and everyone knows it's got to watch what you say.
Hillary will kill Ya and that chick is running for president and that's a joke.
Did you ever see that meme?
There's a meme of a deer laying on the side of the road is dead and it said,
what did that deer know about Hillary Clinton
thing?
Everybody's laughing.
I said
the only reason we would laugh is because it's true.
That's the only reason we would laugh.
Yeah.
Wouldn't it be funny if you did that about Oprah?
That's a point.
Funding all.
Totally true.
That really is.
There's,
there's that kid who according to Wiki leaks,
according to Wiki leaks,
the kid who is the DNC leak was the kid that got murdered outside of his place.
Damn Nigga got shot in the back at four o'clock in the morning outside of his
apartment and according to the Julian assague guy,
I don't know if he knows for sure,
but he believes that that guy's the,
the leak.
That's the guy who sent the leaked emails.
She's us about them supporting Hillary over Bernie Sanders,
like deliberately trying to get Bernie Sanders out of the picture.
Cool as shit on Hitler and straight.
I'm just saying that gangster.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I'm not saying it's bad.
They're like Tony Montana.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well I'll do like Tony Montana when you watch Scarface.
I did basically what Billy Bill Clinton is like.
Look at this with Jamie just put up there the missing hours of murder.
DNC staffer alone in a bar.
Guzzling beer,
depressed over trouble with his girlfriend.
The wiki leaks,
linked analysts refuse to ride home,
refused a ride home and stack it out in the middle of the night.
To his mysterious death.
Well that's a rough and just been,
yeah,
it have been just shitty decision making it too convenient.
But yeah,
it has a little to that one.
A girl who got,
uh,
I think she got suicide and she was going to suicides to find the Paula Jones
case with Bill Clinton and Paula Jones back in the day and they,
she was going to be the witness.
Boom.
She gets a what?
Suicided bro?
Suicide in means you pretend that somebody killed,
she killed herself.
Yes,
but they make it really,
really obvious that it wasn't a suicide.
It's like leaving a statement.
Do you guys remember the guy who was the whistle blower for Enron who shot
himself in the head twice?
Sure.
Do they do that on purpose?
Twice.
He shot himself in the head twice and they said it was a suicide.
We don't see anything wrong with us.
Everything seems normal.
That's a general,
that's a real story.
Politics and you get suicided.
If you look into it,
it's probably going to be pretty obvious.
It wasn't a,
maybe I could see wiener commence.
No,
because he's not in office.
Who?
Anthony Wiener.
Just can't not send a Jake brake dude's a freak.
I don't let it bother you that for that first aid.
I'm not mad at it.
Don't have your kid in the bed though.
Post and Dick is not good.
That's what I,
that guy for sure.
She get into standup comedy.
I carried a powerful speaker.
He's obviously a mass.
I bet he's hilarious.
Did you see that Robert Deniro speech about Donald Trump and he's been robbed
for 30 seconds.
He goes that scumbag on a fucking punch.
Ron,
uh,
Donald Trump and that face because they missed last day.
No,
not exactly like that for sure.
Just,
just punch in Robert De Niro talks,
Talk Mad Shit
on Donald Trump.
Wow.
I got some good candidates.
Let's bring it to the beginning.
Jimmy.
Jamie is a message to Donald Trump and put it in our here so we can hear this.
Oh,
can you do it?
Is it all right or no?
So blatantly stupid.
He's a punk.
He's a dog.
He's a pig a month.
Who doesn't know what he's talking about?
Doesn't do his homework.
He's an idiot.
Colin Powell said it best.
He said,
national disaster.
He's an embarrassment to this country.
It makes me so angry that this country has gotten to this point,
that this fool,
this Bozel as wound up where he has to edit the talks,
how he wants to punch people in the face.
Well,
I'd like to punch him in the face.
This is somebody that we want for president.
I don't think so.
What I care about is the direction of this country and when I'm very,
very worried about is that it might go in the wrong direction with someone like
Donald Trump.
If you care about your future,
vote for it teases
for Hillary.
He's an idiot.
Well,
before he didn't say,
he didn't say.
Now he's saying,
I mean we got a crazy choice here.
Donald motherfucking Trump and Hillary.
Holy Shit.
We know Hillary's crooked is fuck the libertarian candidate.
That's a real option.
And he's reached as high as I think 20% some states when people are scrambling,
this is the best time ever for a libertarian candidates.
That's an independent and the end it was.
What was that meaning?
Well,
independent is libertarian.
Green party candidate is a bunch of different people.
Jill Stein,
she's the,
uh,
the nominees.
He,
no one even hears about her.
She's a Green party candidate,
but she said some ridiculous shit that drives me crazy.
One of the things I think she means,
well and a lot of a lot of areas,
but one of the things she said,
she thinks that 16 year old should be allowed to vote.
Like,
are you out of your fucking mind bitch at 33?
I shouldn't be able to vote.
I don't know shit about it.
I'm going to vote though.
You know,
I mean,
for sure there should be a reason why we value your opinion and in,
in the,
the thing about voting as beautiful is that everybody gets a vote.
But the weird thing about voting is that there's a lot of us out there that
really shouldn't have a fucking opinion.
They just haven't researched it.
It's based on nonsense.
They just pick one side.
It looks like the better guy in the movie and that's what they go with.
That's why Trump is,
I think is pulled ahead a little bit.
You know what I'm saying?
Or doing well,
not pull them ahead,
but doing well because 18 to 36 social media,
you see all the headlines,
headlines,
headlines is the Kim Kardashian effect.
There's all the Kim Kardashian of presidents and there's also a time and that
time is probably coming up very soon.
We're poles are no longer accurate.
There's because no one's taking them.
I'm not taking them.
You're not taking them.
No one ever taking a poll.
Never still pull the people that they're getting in there talking to him.
I have a whole bit about it,
but there's,
it's like those are,
that's the real 1%.
We should be concerned with the 1% where answer polls for sure.
Just let me text in my vote.
Exactly.
How about that?
How about my couch?
Exactly.
We have like Instagram polls,
you know,
and you can't progress.
You can't do any more Instagram activity until you vote yes or no on this shit.
You know what I mean?
So everybody's got a social media.
They'd vote or a Facebook and it's right there pops up.
You can't do shit just to,
you make that fucking boom.
Yeah,
but she should want and you should want to have an opinion based on something I
would say.
How does guys sit in Merseyside,
Beck,
Dick and rustled?
Dawn Russell don't.
And it's four 502450145449 of the first round.
So right now it's four 45 four 44 so our,
our sync will be like a few seconds off.
So you should,
if you want to sync up to the podcast,
just just pause your shit for a couple seconds and figure it out.
Pitch.
I don't want you us to go oh shit.
And then you see it.
That does happen and it's a bummer and I'm sorry,
how crazy is it that we have an actor talking crap about a presidential can't
what?
And it and,
but he'll sway some boats too,
so it's like,
oh I loved him and go was going on.
So weird.
What's going on in this country is,
I don't even know what's going on.
I don't want to say no one does.
Dave Chappelle has a whole skid on the,
a while ago when when September 11th happened,
he said he turned on MTV.
It's like,
I don't give a fuck with Joe rule thinks about September 11th like he was all
over the TV.
Fuck is he talking about the CIA came out and just crushed Donald Trump just
like that too.
Not like a gangster like he just did,
but a former director of the CIA had to come out and say,
listen,
I got my issues with Hillary too.
He didn't get him to them.
He goes,
but Donald Trump,
if we allow this guy to be president,
it's going to fuck our country.
Basically.
I think you might even win more now cause my hell no,
no,
really scared to death of Donald Trump.
That's what I'm seeing.
But it almost helps because his name is out there more.
Right?
People are seeing it.
People are like,
Hey,
dinero is talking about a mom in some way.
Almost.
You're right in some way,
in my mind,
almost help.
But see,
here's the thing.
It's a long time before November.
I mean it doesn't seem like it is,
but it is in this weird climate.
Crazy shit can happen with these people.
How much more could come out?
What do you really think about Hillary?
I don't want any politician that's deeply entrenched in the political system at
this point in terms of like who is,
who's,
who's influencing them.
Like she's doing things like these speeches in front of these bankers where she
gets paid a quarter million dollars.
You don't do those if you're on the up and up.
That's just a payoff.
Like nobody wants to see her talk for an hour.
Come on man.
She's not funny cause she's saying something but I mean she's going to motivate
you.
Rob Has beach all the dreaming and how and people buy it.
This is like doesn't cook and shit.
Here's the thing.
It's like I understand what that means.
What she's like,
she's,
she's like the classic model of the politician who is not doing anything illegal
but it's distasteful when you look at it.
And in terms of like a whole system,
like the system of like these people getting these jobs or people getting,
uh,
getting things based on whether or not they donated or have donated to the
Clinton Foundation.
There's a lot of issues that people were having a giant problem with.
And not me,
like someone said,
all you're buying into conspiracy theories.
The Washington Post isn't a fucking conspiracy website print.
They print a lot of stories about this.
Like there's,
there's,
there's a lot of people that don't like the connection between some politicians
and some special interest groups that pay them a ton of money to speak at places
like crazy money.
People are just tired of politicians in general.
That's why they've gravitated towards Trump once I agree 100% yes,
that's no one takes those,
those big speech monies.
You don't take that,
that big speech money.
If you're really concerned about representing the people,
that's your own interests,
that's like there's a giant red flag.
Like it's sort of unethical,
but you're allowed to do it because it's not illegal technically,
but God damn it seems dark.
If you're taking hundreds of thousands of dollars from oil companies,
then you're making decisions whether or not those oil companies are going to
profit or not based on a policy.
For sure.
There's a connection.
I'll tell you who's really fucked.
Trump's can be fun to Gill in Eric,
scrooge McDuck,
Billy Bush,
the other guy doing the interviews.
The guy who was super fucked,
Billy Bush was the guy who was in the van.
Have you seen the video?
I have it.
Oh yes.
I haven't seen anything about this latest thing.
Excuse me.
Let's say a grab the pussy thing.
I don't even want to say,
oh,
look at this.
Hold on a second,
ma'am.
[inaudible] book got the back.
Billy Bush was the guy on the,
Oh shit.
He's got it.
Oh,
he's got it.
He's got a tap.
Oh boy.
We did the shittiest job ever cover and that fight.
He was there before and he had fuck got out and he's you guys back again.
Um,
I was balls deep in Billy Bush,
uh,
Bill Billy Bush and Billy Bush who was talking,
he was the host and he's,
he's,
he's from entertainment tonight,
or he was,
see this,
can we
go into a seizure?
Well,
no,
Billy bushes,
the guy interviewed him and they don't,
they didn't know their mics are hot and cop out.
Like,
he's like,
yeah,
you know,
he's like,
how about this chick all,
how about her?
And you know,
he's Kinda,
he's fucked.
And then when they get out,
there's a,
you know,
it's a Ho a host who's an attractive woman and he goes,
come on and give Donald a hug.
At least got to hug him.
And after that talk,
like,
oh,
he's a straight creep.
He's,
he's this guy,
Billy Bush.
When you recognize when you see him,
I bet.
Oh man,
it's just,
to me,
I just don't,
I just don't know how we got to this point where that's our option now.
I know.
And I think it's the outrage that people have.
I think this political system,
and I'm not obviously not any kind of an expert,
but I think it's like a battle ship.
I think it starts moving and it takes a long time to change course.
I think what we're now,
we're two,
we're seeing it change course and we're seeing the people's outrage.
Outrage at our peak lately.
Yes,
they are Hillary winning in the Paul.
Yeah,
but you know what?
There's still outrage.
There's plenty of people that outrage.
There's plenty of people that are just going to go democratic no matter what.
There's plenty of people that realize that she's the better choice between the
two monsters like the leg,
her better.
Even Arnold came out against Donald Trump,
but yeah.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Did he have a kid with the fuck
he was married about?
He was nice to them.
Oh,
those like as nice of them,
I gave them to sausage,
gave him that.
[inaudible] Trump.
He said,
dude,
in his voice,
I can no longer stand for someone.
I know.
All of us come back.
Then myself,
there's a line people,
he had just crossed it.
Okay.
You don't grab the pussy.
First of all,
a lot of them would let you.
You just have to ask.
Just grabbing pussy left dude,
like grabbing pussy.
You're pro Hillary.
Hillary is a good woman.
She's just misunderstood.
Sometimes people when they are good women,
they wind up suiciding themselves.
The personalities is,
it makes you humble.
Swamp is a problem for
emails is not good.
What does Arnold think about those emails?
I don't know.
The status mail issues seems very complex.
I've got to go.
Not just a governor.
That was our governor.
He,
I love him.
He's my hero.
You know
the Bernie Sanders,
Hillary election rigging and all that crazy shit that they just cover it up and
then you didn't see the shooting in Orlando.
Boom,
Bam,
Bam.
I don't think that's true.
See,
that's a convenient connection between 330 million people in one spot and then
something bad happens.
You blame it on these people that set things up.
It's not easy to set things up,
but it is easy to take advantage of those things.
Hold on,
hold on a second.
When it was a shooting happens.
First of all,
that's what everybody wants to see.
So the news,
they're going to cover it and it does make things look,
it does lighten things up,
but like here's a perfect example.
Do you remember Gary Condit?
Here's a perfect example of that.
Gary condit was a politician who was having sex with his girlfriend who was like
a secretary or some shit like that and she was really young and she turned up
murdered and he was under investigation.
Everybody's like,
Holy Shit,
this guy murdered his politician,
murder his girlfriend,
and then nine 11 happened.
So to think that Gary Condit set up so that he could get away with murder and
his girlfriend is the same kind of connection that people do when a nightclub
shooting happens with a guy who was on the FBI terrorist watchlist group,
there were a couple times,
a couple times,
he's a fucking nightmare,
crazy person,
and also gay going to gay bars and he had a fucking truck loaded guns.
He was a nut.
The idea that you could get that guy and recruit him and get him to do your
bidding on a specific day so that it makes something else like g get
overshadowed in the news.
I think it's an easy way to fall in,
in that way of thinking.
But I honestly think there's just so many events taking place that these people
are really good at manipulating the press.
They're really good at focusing the national attention on things that don't
matter.
Like gay marriage is a big one.
Like how often does gay marriage come up?
Whenever there's like a big political event,
less so now because it's so late.
But it was always like the beach ball.
They would bounce in the air whenever they wanted to get something in the news
that didn't matter.
It didn't matter to most people.
Well,
we just came out,
uh,
the Pentagon just got busted for spending $500 million to some British film
making crew or per production company to make a fake al Qaeda Taliban videos.
This is everywhere.
You can look this up.
Ron Paul's,
uh,
he talked hit sir.
Okay.
So,
okay,
let's,
let's find out if it's true.
Jamie pulled that shit on what that means.
Oh,
it's shitty.
But is it really true?
For sure.
Definitely.
Million percent make it real number.
It's sir,
they just got busted for days ago.
1000000% is so true.
If you read your mind,
let's just say
hypothetically,
what does that mean?
Kind of videos,
million dollars make it now they just got busted VHS video.
That shit you saw the news $500 billion worth of it was fake.
But is that really true?
Which ones are fleet?
What if it is,
what's the website?
I'm trying to find it that site first so we can pull what is this website's not
a conspiracy theory.
Socialists website.
Oh,
you guys are what?
We don't know if this is a real story because it's an incredible,
like what does it really mean?
It means that everything we know about the Middle East,
like all those terrorists,
uh,
videos,
which one's $500 million worth of [inaudible].
You're getting attracted to this before you know whether or not it's real.
I understand.
I already looked at what will then tell us a good website to go to that.
How about cloud is that everything comes up.
Yeah,
but this is the thing.
More Google.
It doesn't come out.
What's coming up.
Maybe there's another way to Google it.
What do,
what should we fake news?
Yeah.
See,
see if on the spam things pop up on your website called about fake news and
false.
500 million
should come up.
All the,
all the conspiracy theory websites are jumping on this or you can't even write
jumping on email.
I don't want that.
Jesus said Isis alert.
Subscribing now.
Oh my God.
Fucking paranoid.
Collect guns.
Yes.
That's me making it look like it was a Middle Eastern news.
Let's take a let's find out.
Oh,
this is real stuff.
They might,
how's it real though?
It,
hold on.
They might have done that.
They did know Eddie.
These these websites are horse shit.
Okay.
Like these aren't like the best website.
We have a website that said you saved me from a bear attack.
That's right.
That's true.
I heard that shows a website that I killed a mountain lion with my bare hands
outside the club.
I disarmed a,
an armed gunman Pentagon paid.
Okay,
here we go.
Now rush it today.
Now this,
this is where it gets interesting because Russia today is probably the one of
the most out of the this big pile of people that are reporting on this.
This is a very legitimate news source.
It's kind of weird cause it's Russia today,
but this is where Abby Martin was.
And uh,
they,
they get away with a lot more than anything that's uh,
on television in the United States like CNN or something along with,
of course it's true like I was telling you,
but what does it mean?
It means that everything we know,
but even if they know what they think,
some,
they faked a $500 million worth,
but any,
anything,
uh,
they keep anything that they're showing me now,
it's what I like Daniel Pearl and his family and all the shit about the Middle
East.
They faked $500 million worth of video.
Okay.
But we need them.
We need to really make sure that this is a big thing,
right?
So we really need to make sure we know what the actual facts are.
Just shot the pump when we just,
we need to know.
We need to know,
but he might be the truth,
but it might not be,
cause there's a lot of shit that people get wrong and these fucking stories,
man,
and these things get passed on from one person to another as gospel without
people like really looking into it.
But now it's really legit.
Said he's dropped it on that.
It might be,
oh we don't know.
Would you be surprised that it was a JV?
They're paid ready to release this if it was,
what does that mean?
It doesn't mean I don't,
it doesn't mean much to me.
Well all the million millions of lives of innocent civilians that have died in
the Middle East and still bombed the twin towers.
Those people,
oh you fucked up.
Oh you fucked up.
Cause he doing this.
He's been,
he's baiting.
You
guys talked before September 11th round Eddie and it's fucking,
oh shit.
Sorry.
Didn't mean to pry.
But I liked this tower.
Seven is that's the most obvious.
So if someone,
if someone can look at a skyscraper,
go down at free fall speed and send the video.
What conspiracy
theorists don't don't want to see about tower seven and what it shows is how
slowly it actually fell apart before it totally collapsed and there was a top,
there's a tower seven,
there's an exact to what he's doing is the top to the building and it starts to
cave.
It's during the Trump video starts to cave in minutes before it does.
It starts to cave in Manson for the thing collapse.
Listen,
it doesn't mean that it wasn't a controlled demolition.
Doesn't mean it doesn't still look like I'll controlled.
It.
Doesn't mean it doesn't still look like a controlled demolition,
but it's entirely possible because there's diesel fires in that building
collapsed because it was a piece of shit building.
Many experts have said it's impossible.
It's never had a pap right.
Have said that.
So you can't say it's possible and experts are saying it's impossible.
Many experts are saying it's impossible,
but many other experts are disagreeing with that.
I'm not an expert.
I don't know if they're paid off cause he don't.
You think that that would get out?
I don't know if they're paid off.
They might be paid off.
You might be right next to it might be that the stuff that we don't understand
about what's common mother fucking sense.
You got it.
There's enough circumstantial evidence.
There's fucking video of the building collapsing at free fall speed according to
the official story was free fall speed.
It's impossible.
I don't have an engineer and
you don't have to have an engineering degree.
You don't have to be a professional,
a race car driver to know someone's drag racing a car.
You could tell by seeing it and you're hearing enough unbiased.
A structural engineers,
chemists,
but one after another band.
But here,
let me stop you for a second.
Them with common sense,
but Eddie,
let me stop you for a second.
You're only listening to the ones that want to think that it happened that way.
There are a bunch of other ones that don't think that.
See,
this is the thing
that's incredible.
That's fucking incredible.
I'm not a scientist and I'm not a structural engineer.
So when there's a bunch of structural engineers arguing,
you just have to have a third grade education to see that fucking,
I can't remember what,
it's great when you go over bombing.
Great Shit that Stephan Struve's about to fight here.
He's tall.
He's tall as fuck.
Change the subject case.
True.
Look at him.
He's tall.
Oh,
he's white too.
How do you say this?
Daniel.
Aman.
Check.
He's not rip.
No,
he's never,
he seven foot for sure.
Pick up a basketball.
So you a giant dude.
And he's been,
he's been training a lot with Henry hoofed training with the black zillions now.
I liked his pad work,
man.
What did I say to move his last fight?
He got knocked out.
Is that what I know?
No,
it's last fight.
I think he won his last fight on his last day.
He beat no guarantee.
Beat big foot.
He got knocked out by Overeem,
but I think that was three fights ago.
Correct?
And he probably,
yeah,
he knocked him out and he stopped him.
Give him seven foot.
Um,
I mean I think it's him.
He says how tall is nobody can get up there to measure them.
So you have to,
I don't know why I didn't take his word for sure.
Some foot just round that out.
I think he likes it that way.
All right.
A lot of digits.
I guess.
I know if he just stood up straight,
he was got a little bit of a slump for a seven foot he seven foot for sure.
But uh,
he's a long dude and he kicked Steve Bay from way out.
It's 20 steep.
I made a post about it saying like how important it was for him to have lost
this guy.
Cause cause it was like,
it really burned the fire under him.
It was an important laws.
But he in the picture,
he's head kick and Steve Bay from across the room.
It's so crazy.
Go,
go gadget stuff.
They said,
I'm thinking to myself,
how the fuck is this guy kicking me in the head from way over there for it.
It's a ridiculous,
crazy pictures.
See if you can find a champion.
Remember Strube had the hops horrible,
hardest.
She man where they thousand after retire.
Well,
I think he still has a heart issue and one of the things he said is he did an
interview recently,
like within this last week that he said,
um,
I think that,
uh,
it's that I'm going to be able to prove that you can win without a full use of
your heart,
like with a damaged heart,
which is crazy bitch.
Yeah.
I would assume it affects cardio at some point.
My God,
if I have a whole heart and that bad boys working on and have a whatever,
a whole in yours for sure.
He goes,
beers knows heart.
Do you guys remember Mills Lane?
Yeah,
he was the original company.
It's probably a tribute to all his favorite raps,
yet willing,
when binge big John McCarthy started doing it for eminent MMA.
They sort of had an agreement like John would do it for MMA and he did it for
boxing.
Let's get it all.
It's a tough fight for Stru.
Yeah,
it's tough for them.
People think really good dude.
He's very,
very tough.
Yeah.
I don't think he's ever been finished.
Only lost by decision.
I've never seen him wrestle big shoe.
So,
so big.
He's just,
as he's moving away from this guy,
you realize what a distance gap between the two.
You don't see him use his reach a ton though.
Look how much bigger he looks.
Well,
I think that's something that working with hoofed will really fix.
I agree.
If anyone's going to be Henry who yeah,
and he's a fellow Dutchman to you.
No,
no,
no.
There's a whole triangle on Pat Barry.
That was amazing.
[inaudible] Presa yeah,
jumped.
I tell you,
I'll tell you where I can see strip wins by submission because think about where
are you gonna find a seven foot Jujitsu guy to train with Schroeder to get ready
for struve.
It's true,
but he could win by other things too.
You know?
I mean he can stay there
fucking picture.
That is so crazy.
He's kicking him from the other side of the cage.
That is nuts.
I mean that's like a foot difference between what Steve Bay can do to him and
where he can hit Steve Bay.
That's crazy.
That's so hard to deal with.
It's the hardest thing to deal with it.
Oh,
we just go into the left hand.
You got to get them going backwards.
Reaches the hardest thing to deal with.
An all striking.
Well,
yeah.
One thing that doesn't get tired as reach,
right?
Never gets 10 reached 10 inch advantage and reach crazy.
That's so big.
It's so big.
That's a giant gap.
Yeah.
You sure as fuck.
Don't want to on that side,
Daniel.
Yeah.
Gotta get in Bro.
You can't hang back with this guy because of the distance is so vast.
Yes.
Getting like do,
do what jds did do what Roy Jones does.
You get her.
Sorry.
Roy Nelson get in there and just fucking dirty box.
Oh,
we just tagged him with that left Hook and a right to left.
Really thumped him.
Yeah.
Oh Dude.
Throwing those casting punches.
Fade or style.
I like it.
Yeah.
Can't stay out there,
man.
Boom.
Oh.
Oh Shit.
They're getting busy.
Yeah,
I know.
He needs to keep that snoring and still keep the writer almost want to take him
down.
Yeah.
Oh,
nice.
You fucked up dude.
Wizard.
He's gonna step over.
No backup Struble jump guard now.
Oh it's to cry.
Triangles are nasty.
He will.
His legs are so long,
man.
He can wrap you up.
Yeah,
he's got a real good guard but super tricky Overeem got through that.
You know when Overeem took him down,
he knocked him out from inside his car.
He did granted pen.
Oh here we go.
Beautiful.
All that.
But his Darcel steps steps over.
See if he can get that mount.
Got The half guard
can be tough.
Yeah.
Almond check's not going to like this.
This is not fun.
Right?
Daddy's on his back very often and struve is so fucking long.
Only big.
Once you agree with this Eddie,
he's so like sometimes I liked playing bigger guys when they're this big and
long cause you have so much,
so much more room to get out and like shrimp.
Get the half guard,
recover guard or stand up.
Cause it was so fucking long.
Does that make sense?
It does make some sense.
Make the holes.
You me way Baker.
Yeah,
he's got a good arm triangle.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
He's putting the crunch down at time and it looks like he's from half guard it
now Daniel realize it.
Yeah,
you're not doing that under Jack.
That wasn't very sneaky there,
but right here.
If we could pull out his right knee and then forced the recorder mount and then
sit up,
throw some punches and then take this dude's back that,
that's the Maya path right there.
Free the knee.
Go.
Oh,
he's going to do it.
Look,
is it set up?
Throw punches.
Rear naked coming up hot.
Oh,
most trying to set it up because a lot of time.
You got a minute.
Yeah.
Go and body triangle that for me.
Those through your seven foot.
Yeah.
Why is he not doing that?
You know what man?
You guys don't lose it right.
There you go.
Look at that.
Here you go.
Sit over and did a good job.
We turned into it.
He did very smart.
Oh well shit.
Yeah.
50 seconds.
Come on,
get door.
Hmm.
Yeah.
I don't think it's ever been finishing this turn.
Let them mount again and as soon as he sets up for a punch,
give the back and then that'll kill.
Knows the 20 seconds.
Yeah.
He's trying to enroll him in here.
He's got the bug tracking on the top rope and he rolls towards the body
triangle.
He can roll into the choke.
Okay.
Not enough time.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Wow.
Powerful.
Kevin Hart Logos on the Mat.
He's fine now.
That's fine.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's true.
Struve won that round for sure.
Yeah,
for sure.
To control.
Look at this crazy control he's got.
He's like,
oh,
he's like almost in a twister setup,
like an underneath or above twister sick.
If he pulled off a twist or,
I know you probably could pull it off from a,
sure.
Let's get this boy is tired down for sure.
That's a great job.
I strove struve is what?
Two 62 65 has to cut to 65 Tazi.
Yeah.
Jesus.
We had the same answer.
Lex Mcmahon.
The key right there was truth.
Got to cut the top half.
You're going to have to pass the whole guard at all.
And then he forced three quarter mount,
still didn't pass,
sat up and before he throws punches,
he actually ended up giving him the mount and then he gave us backup.
Anyways,
he ended up on his back because the way my is doing it is dude stays in three
quarter mountain clamps onto your leg.
Any punches dude covers up,
gives him his back.
Am I never technically pass the guard so we didn't lose tonight.
I'm going to diet coke.
Whoa.
I'm crazy.
Crazy.
Don't judge me.
It's got caffeine.
I know you're trying to avoid caffeine.
Hell No.
Courage the canvas saying it's a drug.
Oh it isn't drug addicted to coffee.
So just say no to drugs.
Hey.
So he wanted to the uh,
instead of punching sand on top,
you know,
full amount.
He wanted to go for the submission.
You think that that's where he's better?
No,
that's true.
Giving them the option.
We'll give them the bat.
The guy you could give your back.
Okay.
Anybody?
Yeah,
it's fucking spot.
Easily,
cause everyone's going to let me go to the worst spot.
But sometimes in this sport you can't hit to the back of the head.
So now the worst spot is kind of the same spot because yeah,
the only thing that's showing is the back of my head and you can get it right.
Most wrestlers turn.
Yeah,
that would be done.
And one thing did you got to take into consideration whenever you see a fight
and there's a ground exchange and there's a submission attempt versus a ground
and pound,
it's not right or wrong.
It's like what he thought was there at the moment.
Beautiful thing about MMA is it all of these options are available.
Is it some people like cro,
cop's knock out of Gabriel Gonzaga from inside the guard.
It was devastating elbows from inside of the guard.
It's like the first time we got to see like a world class striker who's gotten
way better at wrestling,
right?
Yeah,
your boy way better at grappling.
Way Better for doom.
Helped them out a ton to the grill when he fought Gonzaga,
those elbows were so nasty level.
Really right on the UFC.
There was so next level it's like taking a guy like a mallet pet or something
like that.
Or like,
uh,
you know,
I guess you know bull cow.
Yeah.
And putting one of those guys,
like that level you would see from devastating,
devastating results inside the guard.
So that's,
that's the right way to do it for him.
God,
I'll look at that.
That's nice.
Oh Shit.
He's on top.
What's going?
That's called smell my,
but yep.
That's not a move.
He doesn't move.
He's not.
Dot.
I'm surprised.
Darson from fracking.
Oh,
that was beautiful.
Look how tiny got came against.
The cage is trap.
Oh look at this dude.
This dude is so game.
He's so game
be tapped them.
Super impressed.
That was super impressed with that submission and super impressive how game.
That dude is how we roll.
Let me,
he was stuck and getting strangled,
a neck cracked and he kept rolling and help him out at all.
Not at all.
I see.
That's what I've been saying to you,
man.
No Kale
fighting.
All right dude.
You want to sell it on on air,
ladies and gentleman,
this is the Dana White or by organization.
We have to do it on an Indian reservation.
Okay,
let's do it.
I'm a big fan of the native American people,
so let's make it happen.
If they could clear off one night,
nice football field size Matt area for us,
we just do that at like a football stadium.
You know what you do?
You have a black sheep blackground blackground like the center is black and then
you have a,
an enormous white area.
When you get to the white area,
it's understood that unless shit is getting crazy,
break it off.
You go back to the black area.
So you have a giant white area.
So even the white area where like say if you like you,
he sunk the Darce right there and he rolled but he rolled into the white area.
You're breaking them up.
No,
you got plenty of time.
You can keep rolling.
So,
but it's understood that if you're in the white area,
move back to the dark hair and if you try to like stay on the edge of the white
area,
people call you a pussy.
There it is.
Hell,
look at this.
Is this a fight in a football field?
Oh my God.
Of course they do.
You know what?
We can do it.
Holy Shit.
What the fuck?
MMA fighting a football field.
There's seven people there.
There's not that many people do it there,
but this is a great move and Russia,
Russians always have the best moves.
Fantastic.
Oh my God.
This is how the board should be played.
No,
they're going to stay in like a 10 foot area probably.
Oh my God.
This is exactly how fight should take place.
Now that I see it,
I'm so right.
This is so that he,
here's a better thing to it.
It would be better for them to fight in the grass then it would be for them to
fight.
Yes.
Better.
No,
it's itchy.
it's perfect because it's fucking raw.
It's natural dirt.
Some rocks and sand.
We've got to do it in sand.
I'm pretty sure this no rounds to
play football,
soccer on the grass,
no round.
They just go to [inaudible] [inaudible] go off at school.
Dirty feet and everybody's dirty feet and everything.
And Russia.
It might be battle to the death.
Yeah,
they might.
One of them might die.
Well,
you know what they could do?
One show would have a battle to the death and then everybody else would feel
like a pussy.
That was,
that would,
that would be the,
uh,
yeah,
the headliner would be a one up or,
it would be every fight we'd be battle.
The desk guys are,
you're talking about clay gladiator days?
Yeah.
I mean we're going back,
but they did do that.
Everybody else would feel like a pussy in Russia because they're so gangster,
man.
They got something good.
Like,
I wonder if Putin would fight.
He wouldn't fight,
but his body guard would he really have a killer body armor.
Crazy body tattoos takes it off.
It's all just trying to go from full guard.
Oh Shit.
Poop would fight,
but he'd just have it rigged.
So the guy who just does these guys are super talented.
These are good fighters.
And I liked the concept ban.
When did this take place where Jamie,
when did I rip this idea?
These guys are way too high level for,
this is in Boston 2020 it says
interesting everybody.
Yeah,
there's no way that could be like,
isn't it funny that you could look at some MMA fights and go,
oh that's definitely not before 2000 oh yeah.
Easy.
Yeah.
Isn't that interesting though?
Like that's how quick that this sport has evolved.
Like I can look at a guy,
I can look at some fights from,
you know,
you say it's like a world title fight.
If you get,
you look at it and go,
oh,
this has gotta be like 1997 [inaudible] 98 you know,
and then you look at even like,
I think I would,
doesn't get enough love Marlin Murrayas world series of fighting that Bantam
weight division,
bad motherfucker just fighting the world series of fighting.
But he's world championship level.
Like you look at him and go,
that's what I expect out of a world champion.
He said just a master striker or combination grappler.
He's a real solid MMA fighter.
Nasty,
nasty fighter.
He's fighting now I think starting in world series of fighting.
Did they make,
what's the money compared to the UFC?
You don't know.
But a lot of guys from the UFC like day branch just fought Vinny Magallanes I
don't know who won that fight.
Do you know who won that fight?
David Branch one I decision.
You wanted decision?
Dude branch is awesome but very good guy too.
Very good fighter.
And Him and Vinny were both in the UFC so they got a lot of guys jumped.
John Howard Posner,
rs and then they also got uh,
uh,
my boy Jake shields and Fitch.
Fitch.
That's a good fine.
That is the same night as the UFC fight in 'em.
I think it's the same night as the UFC fight in New York City.
But you fucked up world series.
That's,
that's a tough draw.
They get to the weekend.
Everyone fucked up.
Yo,
wait,
let's go.
Let's get busy with this.
What do you think about this Brendan Shop?
I am very excited about this fight.
I think people are fucking sleeping on Eddie Alvarez.
I think he's a dangerous,
dangerous 155 pounder that motherfucker can punch.
He punches hard,
he's fast as fuck.
And it does not a human alive that's more game than that kid.
I agree 100% that do to you if you've never seen him fight before.
You got to watch his fights in Bella toy with chandeliers and dream.
She just fights him dream.
And Michael Chandler is another dude who's out there who is world class that
could easily be fighting and winning in the UFC.
And you see it now with Eddie Alvarez.
Cause it took a while for Eddie to get comfortable in the UFC.
He,
Donald worked him over and his first fight because dismantled,
budge on.
But now he's training with your book Mark Henry.
And look,
Connor's a goddamn phenom.
And he's uh,
he's got as for Rasa,
hobby lexicon at the touch of death in his hands.
That's a scary fight,
man.
Anyone who thinks it's a easy fight or not a big fight for Conor is they just
don't know the sport out of their time on the underground king,
I think at 55 and everyone knows I'm the biggest con or nut writer in the world
at 55 I just don't see a ton of success there.
I think Eddie Alvarez,
if you look at the top five,
we've talked about this before,
you're like the top five.
It's his easiest matchup and that's a fucking nightmare for him cause he can
grapples ass off.
He's been so many big fights.
It doesn't get tired.
He doesn't mind winning by decision.
He doesn't get tired and he's a bigger grandpa.
Yeah,
those are two and he can't fucking crack and look at his resume and just resume
crisp man.
He's got crisp striking.
He's not an easy guy to hit.
You know you can hit him and he gets rocked and he survives.
If you watch his Chandler fights,
Eddie Alvarez got rocked and survived against Chandler and a couple other guys
over in Bella to think about how,
how's Connor win this fight?
You go through it has to knock him out.
He has five rounds and document.
You're not winning decision against that.
He could win a decision.
I don't think so.
I disagree.
Why do you worry about the fight with Gilbert Melendez?
Eddie wanted decision in the Gilbert Melendez.
Fine.
Oh No,
I'm saying Edwin's by decision.
Right.
You don't think that Connor could beat him in a similar fight?
No.
You don't get the same dances.
The endurance,
the takedowns to grappling with the striking as the rounds go on,
the knockout power goes down.
Do you think people sleep on Alvarez wrestling?
Cause I think they forget,
I forget how good of a wrestler.
His and his insurance.
It's a steering college.
Where did he wrestle?
He was a high level guy.
Yeah,
Division One.
All American.
I'm not sure.
But uh,
compared to Connor,
he's fucking Dan Gable.
Yo,
this fight,
this fight is nasty,
right?
We all know that.
Those guys,
I mean this is,
we're talking about Jimmy man.
It's about to go down.
No,
I'm saying this fight's nasty.
Just does not confused people at home.
But I,
I agree with you man.
I think people sleep on them.
It's easy.
You've rolled with like a real division one wrestler and you realize how fucking
strong the wrestling is all American.
Uh,
that's high school,
National Prep,
all American.
What is,
um,
what does his college wrestling record?
It doesn't have one yet.
No college wrestling.
It doesn't say as college wrestling.
And he got us rustling and fricking dream.
How about that?
He bypassed that career and went right into MMA.
So he wasn't high level high school Russell,
which is not as impressive as a college wrestler.
But when you see him wrestle,
you know,
he's got some skills.
Does he like to stand up though?
He loves standard trade and get back on and just wants to stand up.
Obviously he's too smart.
He's been in some with some of the best,
you know.
So Connor is not an easy take down though.
Even now to high school champ.
Chad Mendez begs to differ times or,
I mean as time goes on,
he's going to be harder and harder to get that.
Chad Mendez fight though in Connor's defense,
he had a pretty fucked up knee and that fight and he was shooting.
He was getting stem cell injections in his knee,
but that's also the only wrestle we've seen Conor fight.
It's true.
Taken down pretty effort loosely.
Yeah,
that's true.
Then that's the only,
that's the only thing we can go off of it and say,
I got a bad knee.
I get that.
It's a tough fight,
man.
But people think congressmen walked those guys.
They don't know the sport,
man.
I saw the violent,
oh fuck.
It's true.
But also I could see Connor just smirking ham.
Oh yeah.
That's how common is going to win.
He's going to,
if,
if Connor wins,
he's going to Mirko.
Connor has some vicious fucking power in his hands.
Has Ed been knocked out?
He's been stopped.
He Chandler stopped me rear naked,
choke him and beat him for the title.
I'm knocked out.
I don't think he's been knocked out.
I do not think so.
Some dog fights.
He's just his game as they come.
I think he's one of those guys that fights at his very best when he's scared.
Correct.
I think that's going to be one of the best things about this fight is that he
thinks Conor is a dangerous motherfucker.
Just like he thought hot failed Dos Anjos he stopped though sign jokes in the
first round.
And a lot of people,
including me,
we're making the argument that Dos Anjos,
if you look at the guys he's beaten,
stop cowboy in the first round,
beat the shit out of Nate Diaz,
had us beat Pettis up,
stopped.
Uh,
Ben Henderson crushed him.
I mean,
you look at all the guys that he's beaten,
there's a real argument that he's one of the best lightweight of all time.
And then Eddie went and stopped him in the first round,
so I thought he was gonna get murdered.
Like you went,
thought Eddie was just,
you can get it shows a huge,
he doesn't have the marquee name recognition type thing.
They don't know him yet.
Dangerous fight for economy because he has such a big name.
But yeah.
What if,
if Connor does,
when you imagine the 55 belt holder is crazy and the,
and the flat,
and then I think you'll forget about Tony.
Tony.
Well,
no,
we're not forgetting about them for sure,
but I think the thing about Eddie Alvarez is that he has the title and that's
why it's sellable.
If it was just Conor McGregor versus Eddie Alvarez,
they didn't have the title.
You can't sell it.
It's just that.
Well,
because it's so good to Miller garden stuck in the middle.
So valuable because we realize how valuable that title,
because Tony is right in there in my opinion,
as his Barboza as as a couple of Habib number go.
Madoff is of car course.
Everybody's first choice.
He's undefeated.
Nobody's been able to deal with that graph.
Suplex your face nasty fucking striker too.
And he going to give him,
give him a place fighting.
He's fighting Michael Johnson and the Max.
Right?
And that car,
that's a fucking great fight.
Johnson,
just coming off of the knockout of poor.
Yay.
That's a great fight.
Great fight.
Sound on the main card.
Yay.
It's the best work.
Let's be real.
We always argue what's the best UFC fight card.
That's the best UFC fight card.
The ball diamond
clothes.
It's like by far holds up.
Yeah.
If it holds up,
what's the lineup?
Can I say it?
The lean and the lineup is fucking insane.
You have three world title fights.
You have hours versus Conor Mcgregor.
You have Tyron Woodley's fighting Wonderboy.
People forget that to Steven happening because everybody's talking about other
fights.
They forget this fight.
How about you Andrea and Jay?
Check Versus Carolina K voce.
Bitch.
Come on man.
Nobody's even talking about that and then you have Chris,
why I met versus Yell All motherfucking Romero.
Come on.
Then our boy cowboy counseling this Kelvin Kelvin and look at this mission first
is Raquel Pennington got a fucking fire fights.
Never met.
Raquel Pennington is one of the best Bantam weight in the world.
Nobody talks about her because she's,
she's won some fights in a crazy way like the Ashley Evan Smith fight.
She's had some great,
but she looks,
she took Holly Holm to fucking split decision I had.
Those girls have lost a lot though.
He to eight and six.
They have brawls,
Bro.
These girls go after it and Pennington my,
in my opinion,
super,
super aggressive.
I like watching her fight me.
She got beat up in the last fight.
She did.
God.
Amanda Nunez.
[inaudible] Nunez.
No jail.
Oh my God.
Frankie Edgar versus Jeremy Stephens.
I almost forgot about that.
That's insane.
Neuroma Grumet often Johnson.
Holy Shit.
It's not even close.
There's not even a second place.
Hallway shots and get kids entity.
Oh my God.
To my favorites.
Why did they decide to go gangbusters on this?
Halfway on the towel is fighting.
Tim Boetsch a fun fight and that's all.
I'm fine.
We train to New York with Hanzo.
Jim Miller.
I'll go.
I was fighting one 55 this comes first Friday.
I call that the throat throwback Thursday.
Have you seen what Alvarez looks like?
It's crazy.
I have not.
He's running,
he's way thinner and he's lighter.
You know,
you remember when Elvis fought Matt Hughes when he didn't make weight?
Yeah,
and he was a coal reala.
The baby girl is so jacked.
It was hair said.
See Ya.
He had,
he had muscles that would start above his ears.
Pimple.
Excuse me sir.
You're actually turning into a pit bull when he stopped mad.
Who's flying a look like?
He looks like one.
Yeah,
he was so big.
He was so powerful.
One of the best box.
He was the most feared and Barboza of like 10 years ago.
Look at him right there.
Good for he's big or boat but Barboza man.
Well he was a big deal.
Do you remember he fought Martin [inaudible] was tooling Martin Kampmann until
he went for the take down.
Out of nowhere.
He was winning.
He had him hurt.
He had them staggered and someone told them to go for the takedown.
Yeah,
and you get your cotton.
So someone should be,
first time I seen him fight it was at a small show at a high school in Chicago.
Jason Chambers fought to,
I love it.
Oh that's right.
He's an American top team guy and man,
he
from that fight,
it was pretty,
it was quite clear that he was going to have a serious career.
Was he bodied on Holy Shit.
Tacos was always bodied up.
But not,
well actually when he spot phots Spencer Fisher,
Spencer Fisher,
people don't remember Spencer,
that King motherfucking Fisher Triangle Spencer who was a skillful,
skillful and he caught Tiago with a triangle.
But I think Tiago was only like 20 years old at the time.
I think he was super,
super young,
but I think that was Seattle's first fight in the UFC,
if I remember right.
It was finding that,
yeah,
at 19 or 29 he was young,
real young,
really young.
But so he's,
he's looks real light now real thin.
And he did the,
the Cam Haynes thing,
can't you,
how much you lose when you had to do that big foot 200 you lost like 20 pounds,
right?
Yeah.
You,
but you did it.
He did in the most gangster way because it had one 80 he was,
he was not fat.
So what he had to do was he had to make his body eat itself.
You have to burn off 3000 calories and take in one or taking him to,
I did four and three,
four and three.
So there you go.
You,
you burn that off that way.
So how'd you do it?
You body eats itself running just running nonstop 20 miles a day.
They supplies the VSP,
hit the twist tree.
This is a good crazy ass fight and Jimmy man was a nasty strike or someone's
getting knocked down.
So inside leg kick someone's getting knocked out and Manoa has been in camp with
Gustafson.
Who he fought actually Gustafson stopped him.
Yeah,
but man was really good.
He's just,
he hasn't been fighting for that long.
It's really interesting.
He didn't start martial arts I think til he was like 28 years old.
Yeah,
he was in I to say prison for a while in England.
How dare you just make that up.
You didn't even know.
It's like tower seven all over again.
I'm almost positive he did some time needs to get on the social media thing
cause he liked your picture today.
So I was like,
Hey,
is this him?
And I went to,
it's like 600 followers.
Maybe might not be him.
It might not be him.
I'm like 600 followers.
That is fake.
No,
he's got more.
He's a superstar in Sweden.
Yeah.
It doesn't make any sense.
No,
no.
He's,
when he fought in Stockholm,
when he fought a rumble rumble Johnson,
there's a giant crowd there.
I mean,
I want to say like 30,000 plus people that he has billboards.
Oh Gosh.
Yeah.
He's a stud,
so there's no way that was a real wow.
It was a good fight.
But Jimmy Manoa has like really nasty,
nasty power and stand up for mechanics.
Yeah.
Like I find it almost hard to believe he did it and start striking until he was
28 years old.
Good athlete.
Yeah.
OSP is a better athlete and he's so hard to,
he's like so unconventional.
That's why I had to give us,
yeah,
that hurt.
We have to also remember that Osp suffered a broken arm and the John Jones fight
and you don't know how long it took for that to heal up,
how it healed up.
Some guys will break an arm,
like a bad examples like the Nogueira fight when Frank Mir broke Nogueira his
arm Nogueira's arm was pretty fucked up for a long time.
After that.
I was also 80 years old in the fight world when he broke his fucking dog in the
fight.
He was 80 years a tortoise
flight years.
It was up here.
It was the upper is a mess.
Snap to shit off of God.
That was ugly man.
We just caught him with a knee.
Yeah,
he's um,
he,
Frank Mir is a fucking bad ass submission artist.
This OSP holding onto the head.
This ain't good from Manoa was like a neat,
oh look at that and I just drops right down.
You know,
he was a beautiful going to twist him.
Watch beautiful wrestling.
Mental is not exactly a grappler.
Yeah.
This is smart by Ospi,
man.
Don't be shocked if it gets into the truck.
Don't be shocked if it gets into what you'll see.
I'll tell you what Osp,
when he fought John Jones,
he might've lost that fight,
but he showed people that he's a real world class fighter and the fact that he
was able to fight with a broken arm through a portion,
I think of the fourth and the whole fifth round.
Yeah.
I think,
I think you've got to,
you know,
even though he lost the fight,
he got a shitload of confidence from him.
So that helps.
John also was kind of weird,
you know,
it was a little weird night.
He broke his arm.
John was super,
you know,
and I think that see people,
I think given John a hard time,
I think John didn't feel that comfortable,
but I think that osps really fucking good.
And I think the giant had to be careful.
I agree.
I think John had to be careful and I think John played it a little safe.
And I think Osp as a south dropped,
he dropped out for the kids who are looking for the kids in our men.
He's not going to just hold it on right now.
Hey,
he might get it.
It's totally,
totally my get it.
You never know what's going on.
What's going on the right arm,
what's going on with it was piece of right arm.
He's definitely under the chin,
right?
I just pushing down the rest.
Uh,
he's got some hand fight,
some space.
Oh Shit.
The back scrambles,
little tiny scrambles like that into the truck.
Hasn't got,
he's even got a brand on this Kennedy's he might have one.
Yeah.
At this fraternity to see Tennessee,
one minute see manner where there was like some little space there.
There was some space to scramble and man,
Ooh,
the rest of it.
Instead of scrambling at 49 seconds.
Exactly.
He arrested instead of square and it wasn't a perfect spot against the fence.
He's turning to his left,
which is perfect.
If he turned to his ride,
he'd be in deep trouble.
Bravo's where fucking elbows to the back of the head would be the king.
To your point,
Joe,
when you said he rested,
we should have scrambled.
That's where the world champions don't,
they literally get the fuck out and change the danger of the game.
Like you look at,
you know like a guy like mighty mouse is a perfect example.
I know I always use them,
but they ain't getting no room there
and she's,
Oh,
let's go into it.
I lost it.
That would have been dope if you rolled there,
but he was up against the cage.
That's a weird,
weird place to roll,
right?
Yeah.
I was not a good place to set it up.
Oh Man.
That's a nice elbow.
Yeah.
Wow.
So how many people are going to be at the uh,
New York show?
I don't know how many people was Madison Square Garden seat tickets are
expensive.
Insanely expensive already.
Yeah,
they,
they went for it.
I mean it's square garden.
First time ever.
UFC
think how many people would have to get paid for that show too.
There's a lot of whirl yas fighters on that show.
That is,
that is the God damn paper view bargain of a lifetime.
That card,
it's the paper.
If you bargain of a lifetime,
you have a kid.
And then the thing about the free flights on Fox,
those prelims are nuts.
Dude.
Nigga man Hoff versus Michael Johnson is on Fox.
So it's Frankie Edgar versus Jeremy Stevens.
That's great.
That's on fs one.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
Like to,
I'd like to see Stevens when that,
I like him.
I love Frankie too.
I love them.
I love Jeremy Too.
That's a,
that's one for me is a problem there.
Little Frank.
Great Guy.
I love Jeremy.
Jeremy's a fucking great guy.
He's an animal too.
I love watch that kid.
He's so game too.
He's another one.
It's sows.
Frankie.
Frankie's just relentless.
Yeah.
Best Pace on the game.
I'm interested in see what adjustments Frankie makes from the Aldo fight now
cause I'll go beat up a little bit.
Yeah,
I'll do a flip the script on them and you turn it into a boxing match.
Although flip the script on the UFC.
He said,
Nah,
I'm good.
I'm done.
Is he serious?
What is he saying?
He said he's going to play soccer.
I don't know what he wants to play some serious serious kicks here,
man.
Beautiful leg kicks.
LSPS attack at the end say oh the left hook.
Do you think all those being serious or do you think he's just expressing oh
nice.
Walked right into that.
I think he's being serious for now to realize is what kind of monster he's
dealing with.
Because even though you don't like it,
they're never gonna let you out of your contract.
It's,
it doesn't work that way.
He signed the contract.
Like unless you're literally legitimately going to go play another sport.
Yeah,
you're done fighting.
If you're not going to write out your UFC contract doesn't work like that.
Well,
I don't think he's asking to fight again.
I think he's saying that he's going to do something else.
I think that's essentially what he's saying.
What I read,
Oh,
we got spinning back for as a temp.
What I read is that who's going to play soccer?
That's him.
He apparently before he fought in the UFC,
look dude,
he's fucking good.
I mean,
I don't know like how he is mean.
I'm sure he's playing other good soccer charity game.
If we're Natto came in there,
he'd fucking kick is
or that guy.
Messi.
I see
five,
four,
dude.
He's amazing scores.
Four goals a game.
See some highlights of that dude.
I'm like,
he's incredible.
His role of his man of the ball.
These guys are going off.
Yeah.
It's good.
Kicking in this fight.
O s p without long.
Oh,
oh.
I see.
He's dropping.
You feel?
Yeah.
I'll just cover this real quick.
Yeah,
he's dropping that right arm,
man.
It tough as fun to fuck your cardio up.
Nice.
Inside the capital to open up that left ear too.
Oh,
right there.
Yeah.
He changed positions for a while.
He went south Paul,
which he does do sometimes,
so you know how we would stop,
dude.
He looks tired of Shit too.
You know how you always talking about how are we talking about you need super
camps this day and age to compete.
Yes.
Piece of guy that doesn't train a super camp.
Steve Bay's guy that doesn't train the super camp.
What's think about Super Camp Like I Att Aka Jack Black's aliens.
Yeah.
It's interesting,
right?
Right.
Well,
strong style that Jim in Cleveland.
Oh my God.
Straight K.
Oh God.
Did you see his leg caught on?
Oh my God.
And then the right,
they'll fucking Jimmy man was dangerous.
How hurt English left Hook.
He paired them with those left hooks the body,
and they caught him upstairs.
The huge wind based one in his crib.
Giant.
Giant went.
Especially considering how good Osp looks against Jon Jones went five rounds at
Jones Chimi stops when the second round.
God giant.
Who's the last guy to beat this guy?
Um,
rumbled,
knocked him out.
Maximum out bad on grumbled knocks everybody out at this one and oh,
Jesus slept till your hair at hand.
Right here.
He's looking at us.
Look how patient he is right here.
Boom.
Hey Raph,
let's go.
Yeah,
I mean that's a,
that's look at this.
Boom.
Full body shy hand high two ducks.
The left hand.
Look at that beautiful right hand over the top
to look at the setup.
The setup is nice ms patients.
Boom.
Perfect.
Oh God,
that it's real bad the way they got there.
Reminds me of a Mike Tyson.
Larry Holmes.
Remember that?
Knock out bad.
Mike Thompson knocked out Larry Holmes.
Larry Holmes leg got caught under him and sprang up and down.
No one's worse than Cro.
Cop,
Gonzaga.
Like we were like,
oh shit.
He broke his ankle.
Yeah,
I think he really did.
Fuck it's ankle of his ankles.
Swole up and it swelled up when we,
well,
I think when you talk to him,
he's like,
no,
my ankle feels like I'm good man.
Like you walked out.
I thought his shit snapped off.
He was the first guy where I realize we shouldn't be interviewing fighters after
they fight legit knocked out.
I was like,
you can't be doing the same.
Yeah,
like that.
He doesn't know what he's doing.
He doesn't even know where you are.
You don't know what happened and then they put a mic in your face.
You're like,
ah,
it's totally assuming I got punched or kicked in the face.
It'd be one thing if the fight or felt fine and was willing to talk about it and
new and wanting to do it themselves,
but even then,
then they shouldn't.
Even then,
it's probably not the best idea.
No,
cause I've done that,
but my manager's like,
dude,
you shouldn't do this interview.
And I did it really back.
Stay this.
Watch this.
Watch when Larry Holmes gets up,
Larry Holmes was in all sorts of trouble,
but watch the K out.
They give him the standing eight count.
Larry's walking around.
He's already in deep doodoo though.
I mean,
Larry's a legitimate,
you know,
36 or whatever he was at the time.
Watch this chaos.
It's so nasty.
He gets some over in the right hand corner.
Super wobbly legs.
Pull that left hook right hand.
Here comes right here,
dude.
Oh my goodness.
Oh my God.
You got hurt there.
I forgot how my long this lasted.
He Tyson Tyson off.
Yeah,
he was stressed right now.
he looks strange.
Little basketball back then he was switched dances.
No defense at all.
Well,
he just was aware that Larry was done.
Yeah,
I tried to catch him.
Oh,
this is it.
This is the right hand.
Didn't stop it.
Boom.
Right there.
See his leg?
His leg went under over and then bounced up like a cheerleader kicked.
I know what the most brutal knockout ever.
Ray Mercer.
Tommy Morris.
Oh,
you're right,
ray.
He got caught on the ropes.
So Ray Mercer kept upper cutting him.
He,
the ropes were holding his ass up that legs bad.
Do you see that Joe was bad and he had aids?
Correct?
I don't think he had aids back down.
Did he was bought,
you want to talk about one of the best white boy bodies of all time?
Tommy Morrison.
What happened later on in his career when he went crazy,
he got his tits done.
Well,
he got aids.
Yeah,
he had,
he had breast implants.
Is fights and chronic.
Just show the human hurry.
Go.
So in the beginning Tommy was doing well,
but then ray Mercer came on strong.
Here it is in the fifth round.
Look at this.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Oh my God.
Why?
Oh see him tied up
like three boom.
Oh Oh balance go route.
That's insane.
That is insane.
You know Ray Mercer Kimbo slice.
I got to take a pee.
Yeah,
buddy.
Guillotine dumb.
Yeah,
it Kimbo and Ray wrote down,
but ray ray didn't have any grappling experience at all.
And Kimbo was training at American top team.
Even though Kimbo is not a grappler,
he was more of a grappler than ray ray probably thought it was just going to be
like a stand up fight.
This,
it can be big.
We get this times square.
I know.
Come on saying,
look at this.
Conor is Conor,
he's like gangster,
like she's got Cammo on.
Oh,
this is pretty Tyron Woodley.
Eddie Alvarez drinking a cup of coffee.
I don't get it.
Other one is at the airport.
Yeah,
Wonderboy motherfucker.
Oh man,
you'll wanna.
I can't even hear this.
And it looks cool,
dude.
There's Carlina Cabal,
Tyron,
motherfucking Woodley,
ladies and gentlemen.
I think a bad ass right there.
It is a fucking bad ass.
He's got some power too.
That's putting it mildly.
Nobody knocks out Robbie Lawler.
Tyron can,
he can cover some distance to,
yeah,
he put the lights out and he's a Duke grooveless a protege.
Duke Roufus is one of the best striking coach on the planet earth before World
Moy Thai champion.
His brother Rick Rufus is another kickboxing legend like that family.
There's some deep,
deep,
deep knowledge.
And that's what tyrants training.
That's where he's doing all his striking.
So Wonderboy is probably without w mean it's,
it's a debate that he's the greatest striker in the UFC.
Ever wonder boy.
Yeah,
it's a debate because he was some insane number,
like 57 and oh and kickbox.
Yeah,
he only lost one time in the UFC.
That was to Matt Brown.
He just looks like a normal guy.
Does an intellect when they're showing them right there.
Yeah.
And in a very polite guy to really,
well,
well spoken,
but his kickboxing is off the chain.
I mean he's a world champion.
Kickboxer of the likes are.
There's very few guys who fought in MMA like you know,
even Mirko Mirko was a k one Stryker and who's a bad motherfucker.
But one of the reasons why he was so good in MMA was cause he was explosive.
He was really fast and he could hit really hard and quick,
but he wasn't like the most like s technically perfect kickboxer like Ernesto
hoost.
But Ernesto,
who's,
he would pick you apart nice and slow,
do it all with technique and just chop chop away at you and eventually knock you
out with some beautiful high kick or a perfectly placed punch or something like
that.
But Merkel wouldn't bark guys with like one kick and those type of guys are like
at a high level like Mirko was there more dangerous and MMA because haven't met
everything happens so fast.
You're saying wonder boys like that?
I think Wonderboy is super skillful.
He skillful in a way like when you see him fight Hendricks you realize like,
oh my God,
like this is so next level and he does stuff that everybody can't do.
Like right off the front leg,
his front leg,
you got to get past that front leg and that's not an easy thing to do.
He's front leg side.
Cal is a salad that round Kenyan his face,
he could do some shit that other guys can't do.
So like you,
you,
you have a real hard time bringing in someone and training that has a front leg.
Like that guy.
Yeah.
You only have like a few guys to choose from.
You have to take like Raymond Daniels,
you have to take someone who does Dragon Wilson.
Ah,
Don could've done it.
Thrive.
I mean if you could still,
it was like then he was just on one leg just like flipping it up.
You know when Donna dragging roles,
Wilson might still be able to spar.
He's one of them that keeps training in and dipping.
It was like sixties and seventies if you light spar with them,
as long as you tried to,
don't try to beat him up.
He's a skillful motherfucker.
Tez Ronda Rousey really fighting a man in Nunez.
Is that real or was that a hoax?
I think that's what she wants to do,
but I don't think it's been set up.
I heard she,
I thought she wants to fight Cyborg and cyborgs said she's going eat face
surgery.
She fights it.
Do you know what Cyborg said?
She said,
I'm like candy man to say my name and how come she thought,
but she scares me.
I going to be Cyborg.
Cyborg is called calling around today.
Yeah,
man wants to fight her so bad.
And then she said,
maybe if I was blue eyes,
blonde hair,
and you'd make a division for me,
give me the goddamn fight.
Oh my God.
Oh my God,
such a monster.
And you know what,
man?
Here's the deal.
There's a lot of other women out there that fight at one 45 this idea that
there's no women at one 45 that's just not true.
There's women at one 45 they just don't want to fight.
Nobody will.
Some might hurt some dude that like,
you know that money,
Lina Landsberg would just fodder.
She took the chance.
She fought her.
She's not,
she's not.
She didn't land one punch.
He had to know.
She didn't know.
She had no chance.
She took him for the world more Thai champion.
She didn't take it for the payday,
the girl's world book,
anything but not really.
She made something.
She got into the UFC and know now she's in the mix and she can have a career in
the UFC at one 35 she did not take a chance,
but if she won,
it's a giant chance and if you win,
you're a fucking superhero.
There's no one right now that would give her an issue in the UFC.
I mean,
here's my ask to ask Holly with her fighting style would fight her at one 30
here's another example,
Joanna Barsh.
If Dorina bars has been training MMA and she decided to come over to MMA,
you want to talk about a nasty kickboxer?
There's,
I mean she's got some insane record.
I think she's like 38 Oh shit.
No one wanted to fight her for years.
She beat the shit out of her.
Yeah,
I,
she's gangster.
She's at,
she's tall decision.
She went by decision but then remember knocked her down.
She talking about doing MMA.
If she did,
I'm saying that's the kind of seven need to challenge that takes her down so she
can't keep her off her.
She might,
she has a lot.
That's the other thing people forget about Cyborg.
Just she's a black belt on the ground,
legit black,
worried about that.
You know what I'm saying?
Now go to the ground with her.
Totally true if she can take her down,
but in MMA you also have to realize that bars is fighting with smaller gloves.
She can,
she can land shots that are likely going to have more impact with a smaller
gloves.
You can also break your hand easier and she could get taken down.
She's,
she's a bad app site.
The same way.
Did you see this fire TV?
The bars is no fucking joke.
Look at that knee.
I got to step in.
Neat Dude.
She's no joke whether there's a front kick to the face.
I chose Cyborg swarms or you know,
cyber.
She's all she can handle.
Yeah.
She didn't make it easy and also remember Cyborg and look at that.
I see.
I see this.
I go Jesus Christ.
Cyborg has a chin too.
Damn crazy.
Show game.
See if you Jamie,
see if he could see the front kick to the face that she landed.
She landed like a teabag kick to the face early in the fight and dropped her.
I don't know what you do with,
so I don't know who's going to find,
I don't know.
It's going to step up and fight her.
Here's the thing.
Nobody wanted to fight bars.
She's not even a kickboxer.
She's an MMA fighter and she chose to fight her in her sport.
That's how game she is,
but she still made it to decision.
How big would that fiby her and Rhonda Cyborg and race?
It'd be the biggest fight like crazy because they could make that happen.
I heard,
I read the Rhonda is training hard?
Is that true?
That's what I heard too.
I don't know.
I mean the only way to know is to talk to someone who is training with her and
then you have to trust them.
Yeah.
You have to go watch her train.
Right.
You know?
I don't know.
God.
I'd love to see her come back at the top of her game.
Yeah.
You know what was such a draw?
Amanda Nunez is fucking terrifying.
Yeah.
She's got ridiculous power in her hands.
She,
she punches with snapping Chris Punches,
but you could see like we should take was like,
oh shit out.
Yeah.
What?
She landed one and me.
She was like,
I'm not good.
Look at that knee.
Boom.
That beautiful step in knee.
Look at that man.
No Damn.
She's nasty bars is no joke,
dude.
It was the land landed the right hand.
It was a scrap boom.
So imagine that punch with light with small gloves.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Look at that.
Superman Punch.
Cyborg landed Cyborg.
So gangster dude,
she's so goddamn tough.
I just,
I just don't see anyone being there.
I think Dan,
what a crazy fight that was.
I think if she's landing those with four ounce gloves,
who knows?
Who knows?
But if bars lands with four ounce gloves,
this is the same thing.
She was hurting her there with shots too,
but it was a knees that was hurting her.
It was all,
mostly it was everything.
She hit her with a lot of heart jabs too.
All right,
let's see what he totally Jodi Goodwin say they reinflated them.
Ah,
well he didn't look that bad.
Right?
The best he's looked since the has got extra around that.
That's the golden stitch came in.
You're bullied and debates.
She called finance the golden snitch.
He,
there's no traps like the old veep.
No,
it's not.
But you know what?
The old Vituro fought at a bunch of different weight classes.
Um,
the old Vito from TRT days was one 85 are though,
until you got to a point or the most dangerous guy in the world when he was on
tot someone spinning,
fucking heel kicks your eye over dude with the,
with the traps and the long Mohawk.
Oh,
he was terrified.
He's no joke.
The scary thing is he has the skills to back all that up and he's lightening
fast.
38 now.
He's definitely,
he's definitely not in his prime.
He was the first Brazilian to come out with like legit box and finally a
Brazilian with boxing shit.
He came out and look at them.
They're looking at their,
wow,
that's crazy.
It's a crazy difference.
But here's the thing that I'm critical weight and that's the same weight,
right?
Yup.
Chris Weidman had a good point though.
He said that,
uh,
it might actually help him because he wouldn't gas as much come on because he
was doing so much steroids before these beat him.
But come on,
Chris,
I'm just saying,
I'm talking to Chris.
I'm not talking to you.
It's what he said,
bro.
That's what he said,
man,
this guy's good.
Gate guard Musashi.
He always looks like he doesn't give up.
Fuck No.
He looks like he's bothered.
You're there to watch him fight.
Like he's upset if like if someone's like,
Hey,
you know Gago me Sauskia Syracuse.
I'm like,
yeah,
that makes sense.
Like he doesn't give a fuck about me.
Fixing seems like a real nice guy.
But he's been fighting for ever.
He's legit.
Remember when he knocked out jquery with upkick?
Yes.
And then yeah.
And then didn't Jack Gray Fonda was triangle too.
Yeah.
He was the man and dream.
Just Justice Tko a felony.
You fell on this triangle,
did he?
He did it to somebody else.
Do you hope to be triangle?
I remember he didn't try.
I thought he'd knocked him out and drop gray.
Filmed or maybe just not think he just came and got off of them,
but I think he did that.
I'm trying to,
yeah,
I think he did that to somebody else where he makes here to triangle them.
Yeah.
Just for old time's sake.
When you like to see via tour,
when you are your campaigns,
you're one of those guys who wants to see a guy win.
We don't win with this very rare rooting here.
Like of course Eddie Bravo would be rooting for Tony Ferguson when Ferguson
fight it because it's his boy,
but for the most part we watch these fights like people I know.
I know for sure.
I've known him for a long time and I've known gay God.
I like both these guys.
So I watched his fight.
I just go like,
hmm.
But you're like,
oh,
I want to see this crap.
I like,
Hey,
I like it.
I'm a fan.
Oh me too man.
Yo Brendan,
can I get one of those?
Yeah.
Thank you sir.
Can I get one Coronado,
ladies and gentlemen,
this is a,
can you pass them?
Oh,
let's have a cup of Coronas.
Kam Wants to dip into this whiskey.
You seem like a whiskey.
We looking at that list,
I had been eyeing it up.
Do you want some of that Whiskey Cam?
We could all have a little gentleman's glass of whiskey.
We've got some some ice there.
Here we go.
We should celebrate your bowl.
Yes,
we should celebrate [inaudible] moving g kegger with a nice leg kick.
Okay,
I'm going to be on bias now.
Nah,
he can't.
There's no going back.
Here's the thing with gay guard.
Gate guards got to be real careful of the blitz.
Kashi early.
Yeah.
I suspect that blitz.
I feel like he's too smart for that.
I hope he is.
I think she'd get Murray.
I think so too.
But there's,
there's,
there might be an attitude that some fighters have that v tour without the TRT
is very vulnerable.
Not In those first two minutes.
That's right.
He was on.
Oh.
Oh,
he's coming soggy.
and and Gagan.
Mutombo finger.
He gave him the,
no,
no.
Mason.
We tumble reference,
sir.
I'm from Dems.
K guard.
Come on down and gay guard advances.
You know what that means to me.
That means to me that that little finger mine,
it had an effect.
I agree.
Usually guys do some emotional like fuck them up.
I said Lake left kick to the body and the body or short shorts by beat door PHR
swinging,
fico vittores swinging.
Well that's the,
to be able to kick,
you know,
that's the worst thing about some boy to both landed.
The worst thing about them,
regular Moy Thai shorts.
You ever see those tigers are always rolling them up?
Yeah.
Like sometimes those fuckers bind your legs.
John Dodson,
where's Capris his are so big to be seen.
His,
their show baggy.
I think the move is the tights.
I think everybody should be forced to wear the tights because you don't like why
not?
Why or why not do the single like the old school?
It's Kinda like the speedo style.
Brazilian speedo dams like hold up.
What do you mean?
Wow guys?
Well come on is just a part of it.
Part of the fun.
So I'm crazy with zoom goes,
but you want to see him on a fucking grasp book.
All that beautiful takedown defense by [inaudible] Gago I tried to close it for
the takedown of Vidyard.
Vittores like,
bitch,
I've been fighting for 20 years.
Yeah,
come on bitch.
Okay,
check this out.
I my master's degree and take this knee to the body on the way outside.
Oh and two.
That's one.
Two from me.
His speed hasn't left and that's not usually the last thing to go.
I mean the first thing to,
you know,
what else hasn't left him,
his work ethic,
fee tours and notoriously hard worker in the gym.
Everybody that worked with them.
I did a training st coaches saying tell me insane.
Talked to me.
He just a,
you know,
it's all,
he's the first guy that I really knew who did like a super camp,
which it's just about him.
Like he brought any specific training partners,
brown GSP named my car myself when he's fighting Anthony Johnson,
he brought in just this core group of guys,
no shows for him.
And then he'd have his Jujitsu coach,
they're wrestling coach,
striking coach all times,
which I was a good fight.
They just disbar with them are grappling Anthony Johnson when he choked out
Anthony Johnson at once 70 no,
it was one 81 85 and 90 Johnson didn't make weight.
Yes.
That was in Brazil.
Correct.
And,
and Johnson puts a storm on them and the first round that rumble storm and he
survived the storm and it was a big fight for Vituro because you overcame
adversity.
Yep.
Trouble after that storm.
Yeah.
And then he choked.
Rumba has done,
yeah,
because gas back to anyways because he was losing way too much weight.
The rumble of today is different.
Like if you watched the rumble of today when he fought Phil Davis,
he went three heart beat Phil Davis up.
Yeah.
It's different rumble.
It's two different rubber.
Sure.
Wayne when he's at two oh five.
But Dan,
if you want to like make that argument,
Daniel Cormier was able to weather the storm and he grounded them out and then
he choked him out.
But he,
that's a fight I was saying.
Yeah,
he sad,
he sucked him dry.
But you have to also realize them dry gives me so I'm not in that way.
I mean like his energy.
How dare you.
Jesus Christ.
Nor,
I'm sorry it was dry.
I'm,
I wasn't either.
I was thinking in terms of like,
uh,
like almost like a spider.
Yeah.
Do you see a Sucky d?
DC is such old grinder,
you know like he wears that shirt,
the king of the grind.
That shit breaks the ground.
Yeah.
Embraces no,
he is a king of the grind show.
Embrace the no,
embrace the grind.
Everybody know that Stacy's thing but doesn't he have a shirt that says king of
the grind?
I don't.
Is it,
why do I think he had he had,
he had though is embrace the grind.
Definitely that's,
that's a wrestling statement but that's,
he thought God
they'll want to again,
he had the king of the grind too.
I might be mistaken.
I mean you to be right.
Oh that can't be done.
There it is.
Thank you.
I thought it was mistaken but anyway,
Brendan,
I wasn't sure but he does both.
He wears embraced the grunge short cage fighter and then you would still need of
the body by Louise Hasi but what my point was would that DC was able to front
and back.
You got them both.
Oh,
both.
Right.
Okay.
My point was that DC was able to drain Johnson.
He,
he eventually got him to the point where you could tell rumble was braking and
he was going to crack.
He broke as well.
He did.
He just kind of,
he gave him his neck,
didn't he?
Toward it.
But the thing is he was training for Jon Jones was most likely going to strike
with them and instead he got Daniel Cormier.
I one of the best wrestlers to ever fucking do it in MMA.
I mean not the best and amendment world class.
Just don't see what's resume.
You've got to watch him when he fights.
Josh Barnett to appreciate how fucking good his Ross,
Josh didn't break his hand that fight though early on sort of Daniel Daniel
broke his hand too and he did.
Molly welcome scoops him up in the air and throws him to the ground.
And this is a heavyweight Barnett who was the youngest UFC heavyweight champion
ever.
And Daniel Cormier hoists him.
I only 60 white and just fucking throws him on the ground.
When you realize like watching the shifts and he does it off this power single.
Look at this.
Watch how he hoists him up here.
Come on son.
That's how Columbia and bloody remember what he did to Dan Henderson.
He did the exact same move to den Huston but literally like
WWF and little hints.
A little like a little kid.
Now that is some serious world class throwing ability and the Henderson fight,
he did that about 10 times.
That's how God does tough Dan Harris.
It is running around like a rag doll.
This is a clear difference in size and horsepower and wrestling ability.
I mean all of their crowd beat the shit out of them.
Beat the brakes off of him for three rounds and also the guys at that level,
he's choked him out.
Right?
Did he choke damn asleep?
Yeah,
and guys at that level that,
that wrestling level,
there's really no catching up when they're that good.
So good.
Like I'm the only two guys I've arrested were like,
oh,
there's just no,
there's nothing I can do is DC.
He literally,
I was it guy.
What the hell am I going to do here?
And a King Mo.
Oh yeah.
And their poise and how's it all right?
You know what King Mall is one of those guys where you,
when you saw him,
the early parts of his career,
he thought this guy has all the potential to be like an all time great.
Like a serious world championship caliber wrestler.
Set a really good career as a w yeah,
he has had a really good career,
but I feel like what's the latest was in the UFC like early on,
like more people would know
it with him.
A,
he's thought probably the nicest guy in the room be.
He might be the best fighter coach I've ever met my life to really didn't lose
the weight the way you break it down in a split decision.
And that was to fight for the world title the bell to Champ Liam.
Yeah,
with a crazy one.
Was he fought,
uh,
what's his name?
Emmanuel Emmanuel spinning the spinning
crazy stuff.
That takedown again.
It'd Ooh,
a little blood coming out of the forehead toward,
that's nothing.
No,
but King Mo was Merkin guys can America.
He'd go over to dream,
do that,
and then bounce back here.
He's had a weird career path.
Remember when he knocked out south patches?
Ellie too nasty.
Beautiful Jab by most Aussie.
See now [inaudible] that blitz is not as effective.
You're in the second round and this is what Musashi predicted that he was going
to stop.
Oh Shit.
Upper cuts.
It's close over sun.
Almost Sassy looks insane.
God
tore survived that.
That flurry that that went down like that was,
oh beautiful.
Throw on this fight is in grave devotee being stopped.
Waved jeopardy is what I just said.
This impressive verocity.
God Damn we saw us.
He hasn't slowed down one bit.
Cardio is and say,
Hey,
I'm an impressive feat or for weather that harm because those elbows and he's
still,
he's holding the back of his neck and throwing the install.
No,
he's fucking,
he's smashing the tour.
It's over.
Oh,
incredible.
Incredible.
UFC card.
It ain't daddy's got to put them in for,
oh,
what's he went?
Three quarter mill.
Oh,
full mouthful.
feet towards getting smushed to 30 left.
This a long time left.
Yeah.
That's an eternity for with those landing.
You got to stop the fight,
man.
That's it.
Wow.
Musashi.
Look fat.
She's this jab at what?
85 to I think.
Wow.
That was some brutal striking on his part and he a one man.
He predicted it.
He said he just stop in the second round.
He said,
I'm going to weather a storm in the first round.
I'm going to stop in the second round.
Doesn't feed or have to be close.
Yeah.
He's 39 I mean,
should be over close to sign with Bella.
Turn you back on tr
right.
That's what I was talking about.
That's what I assumed you were going for.
Yes.
Kickstarted
off while he rattled them with that high kick man.
That right hand to the vittores in trouble and look at this Musashi saucy coming
on like an Armenian demon.
Whoa.
God.
Kick boom.
Right hand.
Holy Shit.
Look at this combination.
I know for cuts.
Oh my God.
Vittores just hardening.
Whether they're tar Yolana combination.
Remember that whoever she was lightened up and Ne Yeah,
Jessica Pinay.
God Damn.
Real good.
Stoppage.
Real good stoppage.
Yeah.
I gave them all the chances in the world to recover because he was kind of,
you give them a little bit of leniency,
right?
God damn sauce.
Good.
Yeah.
That was like his best performance.
His best performance in the UFC for sure.
That's a big win.
When is he,
when,
when his,
when was his last win?
Uh,
Dan Harrison stopped down.
Henderson the first round.
That was a little bit ago.
It was while ago,
I think it was two years ago.
And they send the golden snitch said you want to do what he,
that was a last TRT fight.
I think that was his last TRT fight,
correct sir?
No,
I think it was post TRT stopped him in the first round again.
Hmm.
He stopped him one time when he was scary.
[inaudible] they fought a few times and the Henderson beat him.
Henderson beat him by decision and pride then scary.
Trt v Two r stopped Henderson in the first round and then non Trt v tore stopped
Henderson again the first round too.
I'm pretty sure my right
when that head kick.
What's the date on the rock holders?
For sure.
Trt.
Dan Henderson was for sure TRT.
Then the last of Chris Weidman and then Dan Henderson again.
So lawyers.
Yeah,
he was deflated.
Where was that fight though?
That which ones he fight night.
77 zeal was at Brazil.
He might not be in Brazil.
Where's it say,
where's does it say?
I'm like,
do I have skeptical Hipaa lies?
Sure.
I'll Paulo skeptical hip out does not think that Vito was,
yeah,
he wasn't even a year ago.
Yeah.
So I guess that was a year
in boxing.
Those records are shit.
Yeah.
Oh,
you don't have a career.
It's crazy,
right?
You can't lose or you could have like one or two losses.
Like Canelo has pencil this.
Yeah,
let me know.
I don't watch boxing that much,
but up in big bear,
uh,
one of the guys,
one of the trainers that are turned me on to,
there's this Russian guy,
he's a triple g.
He's on a lot of saw the highlight reel of his who get Gennady Golovkin good
number.
Yeah,
it's amazing,
right?
There's like three of the world's best fighters.
If you have the top 10 world best fighters,
three of them right now in terms of boxing or,
or Russians facility Lowman Chanko I mean that guy is insane.
It's probably my favorite to watch one of the best boxers like you'll ever like,
it's far as pure boxing technique like an all time.
Great red a top three guys.
Coleville I'm sorry.
No,
not the top for now.
Sergei Kovalev is fighting Andre Ward and both of those guys are like top in the
world.
This is good.
How to get Lufkin right here.
Eddie,
this is a highlight reel of Golovkin is the one I saw.
He's a monster.
He's so good.
He just fucks guys up.
He has to fight Canelo next year.
Yeah,
we'll kidney a fight.
Floyd Mayweather is that way was to,
is not going to want to have nothing to do with this motherfucker.
Big
Tubes at one 60 look at that left toe.
Are People talking about it?
No,
not at all.
No Floyd.
The one nothing to do with this.
The first of all,
Super Canelo Eddie,
here's the thing about whether,
so you would think that that he's so big.
He did that for the money.
He was young.
10 news going to lose,
but the,
the real fight is right now because Canelo has never been better and then the
cause they can fight.
Man.
It'd be so fun.
Canelo's a big one.
54 too.
But I'm into it.
But here's like the thing of poker,
not eagle off.
Can they had a paper,
have you fight with him recently and it did not do well not draw.
The problem is most people don't know who he is,
whereas Canelo Alvarez is a fucking superstar.
He's the biggest draw.
Unboxing canals.
He's been knocking everyone out.
Just torturing people.
Yeah,
he's fortunate.
He's never looked,
never lost.
He said some good fights that the guy that he fought,
the last one,
um,
that they uh,
they stopped the fight.
Oh,
he his corner.
Stop the fight early.
Oh No,
that,
that's triple G.
Yeah.
So you're talking about,
that's what I'm talking about.
I was talking about Canelo triple g is amazing.
When he fired a,
what is his Canelo fought Liam Smith and a triple g fought.
Um,
oh God damn it.
The English guy.
And he was,
it wasn't Inglese corner threw in the towel,
his corner through in the tower and he was,
he was getting beat up by glove guide by him.
CTE.
I can't remember.
I can't remember it either.
I don't think it's Ct.
You can't brush
Mayweather's daddy's not necessarily.
He might be hanging around waiting for,
well if Manny [inaudible] more time.
If Manny wants to fight one more time too.
I think it would be gigantic cause man,
he's still fighting.
He's fighting against soon.
You can cure this.
Here's Gennady.
Gennady Golovkin they stop.
He stops a Kell Brook Kell Brook.
This first time I thought triple g look.
Cumin.
Well,
Brooke has really good man and we didn't go shopping.
Yeah,
but he came up two weight class canonical often.
Tko Kell.
Oh,
this is just a Shitty,
a HBO thing.
I mean it's just so good.
But your boy cove 11 ward fighting.
Oh man,
that's a fucking fight.
It's a gray box.
Never been better.
I'm so crunk unboxing and then Tyson fury went crazy.
I love it when you say,
I'm so crunk on something I give so crunk then I never get to use that word
either.
It's a great word.
Crunk Tyson fury his gun.
He's just nuts.
He has a mental issue.
You just can't deal with it.
So now the timeout Klich go first.
Anthony,
Joshua,
Joshua.
He's like the golden boy in England.
So it was Tyson fury going to step away from that title.
Yeah,
he's retired.
He retired.
No black guy bodied up for a day.
But Tyson fury is a traveler.
Tyson fury as a traveler.
But they call it,
I think they call themselves travelers,
but he calls himself a white guy.
He's a white guy.
A beat is another white guy.
Beat another way.
Weight Division.
I led a couple of Joe White guys,
but most scary guys,
black guy,
two of them.
Anthony,
Joshua.
Oh and don't forget Shannon motherfucking breaks people still sleeping on
channel.
Nobody wants a fight.
That guy,
he's older,
so he's like 43 years old.
It's 43 years old,
but he's still not motherfucker.
Let me say what David.
Hello.
David Haye doesn't want to fight him.
David has been tried.
Josh,
he's a bad motherfucker,
but David Haye has been running away from a fight with,
with Shannon.
Shannon breaks channel the camp.
He was,
how old is he?
He's 43 Casey Anthony.
Joshua was having an issue with getting a fight because I'm sure he's a
dangerous guy.
Super Dangerous.
Amazing guy.
Personality.
Come on,
Shit.
That's,
that's him right there.
Shannon.
Shannon breaks dude.
Nice go champ.
He's a bad motherfucker and he is one of the best guys to follow on Instagram.
He does Instagram.
He'll do these videos,
wages,
he everything he says,
he says,
let's go champ.
He's always saying,
Let's go cheat.
Cause everybody a chance to chat.
There's no variety.
But he's like,
he'll,
he'll like be working out.
He's dancing chair.
He starts singing do cute.
He wanted to fight with Klitschko and so he went on a boat while Klitschko was
paddle boarding and just start fucking come on,
fight me,
fuck me.
And drove the boat around and made them fall in the water.
Then he's crazy.
Was good.
Oh yeah.
Just talking and talking and he's hilarious.
He's hilarious.
He wants to fight him that he's older.
It's,
it's a tough,
it's a dangerous fight.
Super Dad.
You see super skill.
He's got nasty power and he's got a vicious left hook to the body.
He throws a left hook to the body.
It's like a laser beam.
It's like it just hits you in the liver.
I thought he was retired and one like did bell like 20 years ago.
He's now than he's ever looked physically in his life.
He gets a shot,
but I don't see one of these young guys doing is him.
Was he working out here is what we're going to say?
Yeah,
Dude.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Hell yeah.
He can't.
It breaks is no joke.
Come on.
And he goes,
chat.
Come on.
Those are,
this is,
see,
this is just shots.
Yeah.
This isn't like him doing a great job marketing though.
Social media.
Yeah.
He's incredible.
Best in the game at boxing.
Better than yeah,
he's got power mat.
Oh yeah.
I mean what he's doing right here is just,
you know,
repetitive techniques over and over.
Don't want to fight on a blast.
That power punch.
But he's got real good head movement.
Real slick boxing.
He knows his shit.
He sets traps.
He's not like go like a one dimensional slugger by any stretch of the
imagination.
I'm a fan,
but he's got,
I don't see it happening though.
The zone boats went for a long period where he too was depressed.
He wasn't in a good place.
Yeah.
He talks about it.
He got real fat and got up to like 300 pounds.
He said 404 no.
Yeah,
we can do that.
I was just going to have it on the rocks like a gentleman.
But you want to do shots like some of our barrier.
I didn't know it was a frat house.
I was,
I was just going to hang on your rocks.
I can goddamn gentlemen too.
Yeah.
If you,
if you show show
show,
like see if you find like a highlight of video of him.
Powerful main event coming up or both been Shannon Briggs.
I love Shannon break too man with the main event and he's got the old man's yes.
I was like,
there's no way
one
junior like
how's Java is doing?
He's still in the mix.
He's just lazy.
That's the excuse the rub on him.
What about Hector Camacho?
Look at this.
Shannon.
Shannon,
this was just,
Yup,
that's Klitschko.
No,
the Shannon Briggs,
but look dude,
I dunno.
Some scrub,
some brilliance.
My trees about a hundred pounds lighter.
Emilio's erotic.
My apologies Emilio.
Just fucking around.
You know,
scrub to look at this.
Look at this fucking beautiful combination,
man.
This is a dangerous guy.
Nobody wants to fuck with him right now.
Shannon brakes has a real hard time getting fights for a real good reason
because he's fucking dangerous,
man.
The body,
you know who you should fight or t's.
How many heavyweights do you know that move like this?
Did he tell you a lot of time off and then I'll never stop fighting.
He took some time off.
Time off.
Yeah.
It took some time off.
He went to,
he had depression.
Wait.
Oh,
he went to Bob.
No,
he didn't take that off.
Just messing around.
He's old.
He took some time off a long stretch,
man.
Where the game,
look at this left toe like this combination.
Backed that up.
A few seconds.
Look bad shit.
Watch this shit.
He's standing right in front of the dude.
He's moving away from punches.
Good head movement.
This,
he gets in tight.
Rip Sign.
No,
he's a monster.
He's a fighter or teas.
Come on.
Just finding a white guy with all due respect.
Got Still Brazilian guy.
It's hard.
It's hard to judge.
He's whiter.
I,
I'm telling you,
I get the matchup for him.
He needs to fight that dude or tease out of Cuba.
No one's fight him.
He's older.
Right champion.
Right,
and that guy's a South Pole fucking nightmare.
Well,
he's a guy that had that fight with their Russian dude with a Russian dude's
head swolled up and he wound up having like internal bleeding on his brain.
Real serious brain injury off that fight,
which no one will fight.
Ortiz who?
He's very good.
He's a Cuban [inaudible] name is Joey Diaz.
What is King Kong?
We're tease is what I like to refer to him and he's a bad motherfucker.
Here's our T.
Looks like Joshua.
Jack,
he looks like he's out of Mike Tyson's punch out.
Well he's,
if you watch him fight man,
he's super skillful south.
Paul had over 300 400 amateur fights.
Come on,
look at that guy.
Okay,
this counts.
He's very good man.
Very good.
A powerful Ben.
He so he was a world champion as an amateur.
No one wants to fight him cause he's older.
He's from Cuba.
They can't really get a read on him without that Cuban team man.
That the level of technique that the Cuban boxing team and the Cuban judo team,
he,
I mean you remember how God damn good Hector Lombard's judo is.
People forget that.
Hector lumbar rag doll.
Jake shields.
Remember that fight?
That's when I was like,
oh,
I'm not going Vegan Egg.
Oh,
how dare you.
You watch that one's a meat eater.
He hereon eats tags.
I
think he's a vegetarian.
Either way.
I'm not done.
Jake shields is better than ever now and then has grabbed submitted Leo Machida
son,
he's getting people forget he beat Damien Maia veteran benefit.
Most in my experience,
not,
I dunno if I should say most,
but a lot of MMA fighters as soon as they hit the UFC just seems like they're
grappling just maintains you don't see visible improvements.
Huh?
Game in mind.
Yes.
That's an exception but people sure.
But you know whether it's right or wrong,
like people don't like watching it.
I don't like watching what Maya,
I mean the the casual fan,
don't they like the knockouts?
They like it all.
Yeah.
I mean I liked it cause he's so impressive there but just like the knockouts,
he just wants kickboxing.
We have to any of that shit,
plenty of that.
We always had that a boxing stay there.
I just know sometimes when you listen to the crowd saying you,
I'm saying no,
I love it.
No,
but people are on the ground too long.
He's here,
the crowd booing and stuff.
You know what I mean?
Like in Alabama?
No,
that's Orange County Shit.
I got booed like a mother.
It's like a hundred thousand Jitsu school down there.
People appreciate good grappling.
They did.
The fact that Damien Maia brings that character and when when you're having him
against anybody,
any striker,
whoever it is at one 70 are they going to be able to stop?
It's a chess match,
not I get it strangled like a wild animal gets it.
He was just saying he doesn't want to see that bullshit.
People want to strangle.
When I shut it,
who has taught me,
I was like,
fuck
yeah,
people like both things.
Now the beautiful thing about MMA is that all these things can happen.
Like when were talking about earlier with Gi guavas and Marvin Kamin,
Tiago.
Elvis was tuning up Martin Kamin and he someone fucked up in his coach.
Someone,
someone apparently according to a belief,
Tiago said,
someone called for a takedown after he had Martin hurt.
They were like take them down and take them down and he shot in and Martin has a
nasty,
it's just locked it up nice and tight.
That's what's the beautiful thing about MMA is that it could turn on a dime
because it represents real fighting.
But yeah,
for the average Yoko knucklehead,
they want to watch dude's throw knuckles,
Cam's right for the general audience they want to see big knock.
But the thing is it's just like flip or anything else.
The deeper you get into the sport more you appreciate like strategy and craft no
lives.
And I see him and I listened to you talk because you talked through the moves
and when he's on the ground and you can just see that,
that it just happening.
I mean it's,
it's awesome.
Well Damien Maia versus Neil,
Maggie was a great example.
Me Just like B in an awe.
I was like,
like he like watching his grappling,
you know,
as someone who was like seeing a lot of guys fight and a lot of like Jujitsu and
MMA.
Him and Rick store is another good example cause I know Rick story is a fucking
gorilla and he's a really good wrestler.
And the way my,
I put the clamp down on him and just slowly squeeze the life out of them like a
fucking Anaconda and got his back and neck cranked him.
It's like that's pretty drug.
That's where the commentating I think is so key to,
you know,
cause you have to be able to explain what's going on because I don't know,
you also have to like it.
That goes down the knockouts meeting and Martin is my opinion.
I think people like MMA show huge now.
UFC in particular,
so huge because the knockouts,
unlike in boxing or kickboxing,
the knockouts mean more because that guy could have fucking dragged you down and
choked you out,
but you're knocked them out.
So yeah,
extra special.
So time sometimes,
but he's other knock is a perfect example.
Why that's not the case.
Me,
she'd taken Holly Holm.
It was one of the craziest fucking fights ever.
That was a wild,
crazy fight.
And Meesha take down on points takes her down in the fifth round and chokes.
No,
that's as dramatic as any knockout and you don't feel guilty about it.
Of course he don't feel like you watch someone get brained.
Yeah.
I think the UFC kind of plays into what I'm talking about because they show the
knockouts.
Yeah.
They don't show a choke out the highlights.
Cause cause on Fox they don't show the top 10 submissions to knock out.
If they did,
it would be a hit.
No,
they could be a fuck.
Nah.
Not as big as I thought.
I love juice to mourn striking.
Not as big as the hit us knocked out just as big boys.
We are about to see the best submissions.
You wouldn't get to it,
but in general,
people in Snow White,
this is a real possibility in this fight.
Let's take this and to consider snow grappling going on.
You know?
No,
you don't know.
Michael Bisping might try and take Dan Henderson down thinking that Dan
Henderson maybe gets tired,
took him down and he's older.
Who knows what's going to happen here.
I think Bisbing boxes.
This is going to be crazy.
It's going on right now.
He just has to avoid that giant fucking h bomb.
Yeah,
just circle to do it with one eye and go get that touch
to the back of the head.
How do they let 'em fight with one arm in the elbow?
Well,
he can see enough.
He could see enough.
Apparently all that stuff does.
It's not like his vision is devastated to the point of no repair.
It's like he needs that in there to keep it as retina intact.
Only he knows and his doctors how well he could see from what,
but it ain't perfect.
How good does Dan look physically?
Yeah,
it looks great.
Powerful.
10 too.
He brought an art,
some leaven for this camp.
Oh,
duty.
Yeah.
Damn.
A lot of pictures of him sparring with arts 11 on Instagram 11 who's a former
world muy Thai champion Joe Forum,
like Super High Level Guy.
He was a glory champ.
Oh,
switch kick by perilla cause Bisping's coach said he,
he thinks business wins by left high kick dude.
He just switched,
kicked him up behind.
It looks smooth as fuck did he?
I didn't see that.
It doesn't mean he blocked it,
but it looks smooth as fuck.
Bisping's fight.
Nice.
I don't get why more people don't talk about is his striking coach.
It's,
it's cyborg striking coach and lesbians.
Two monsters will and Bj Penn,
he worked with PJ Penn chasen pearls.
A bad motherfucker out of the fight,
Huh?
Yes he is.
And he canceled the entire card because of the God dog to the
Bj got injured apparently.
Damn.
I don't know what the injury is.
Let me some Bj Penn love him.
But you know what man,
that was a crazy way to jump back into the pool.
Get barreled,
says I get him F's favorable.
We,
you know,
we don't know.
He looked terrible and his last fight I thought when he fought Frankie Edgar.
Yeah.
You've got to realize is also fighting a monster.
But we never seen him like this dad.
No,
we have the hype was the hall staff,
but that was also camp in Hawaii and since then he trained at Greg Jackson's
music in there for a long time.
Now that right to handle landed a right hand.
Pa Did do this one's only that thing lands plus this bitch is over.
You've got a 46 year old world champion.
Yeah.
If it lands,
if it lands,
it landed once on everybody.
Right.
I mean nobody can take that.
Cain Velasquez,
we got knocked out bolt right and he's left hook to man.
She know.
Busy.
Just thinking about that right now.
Yes he is,
but it doesn't matter.
So it was Hector Lombard.
The thing about Dan Henderson is he,
he's got that one touch thing going on where he can just connect out of nowhere.
Like with Lumbar,
he hits him in the back elbow and puts them asleep.
Who the fuck does that heard?
That's a bar room to take a picture with Dan Henderson.
Put your hand on his back.
It's like you're holding one of those Indian Indian statues that has cigars.
Yeah.
It's like all raw touches made out of wood.
Pure would.
He does like Ryan Parsons,
who was his manager and his trainer for a long time.
Ryan Parsons used to do massage on him.
Like he had deep,
deep tissue on it.
He said,
dude,
I'd be fucking exhausted.
He said,
I've never,
I've never massaged anybody or you know Ryan's chiropractor too,
cause I'd never manipulate anybody who's is dense,
Dan.
Is that,
is their blood coming?
So there's blood on top of his head.
There is.
That was from the first one purse left.
Where's the blood?
You know,
it looks like some of the top of his hairline.
Yeah.
There's an lag from a headbutt.
No.
Is that left jab?
I think.
Well the good news is you already can't see.
So it's probably not bothering them at all.
As long as doesn't go in the other eye,
then he's blind.
Yeah.
It doesn't give a fuck.
No,
he doesn't.
Who was more game than Michael Bisping?
He never met a guy.
And let me ask you this,
has any guy benefited more than the TRT movement then?
Bisping.
He's one of them.
He's world champ.
Well,
so was mighty mouse.
Why do you mouse?
But he never suffered from it.
I'm saying busily bath routine off fought him on that shit.
He filed an EPO and he still beat them.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but I,
but I'm saying he,
he's never had any issues with it beings.
Flat guys lost the only guys
who have been TRT guys.
Right.
You're right.
And took him 10 years to get his fucking title shot.
Then he gets it on what an eight day knows and beats Lula Rockhold cold stuff.
Fuck.
By kicking out root for that guy.
I know what he talking about.
He's his game as they come in and he's been in the business for forever.
Remember he won ultimate fighter,
right?
You see that right?
Again,
what?
What'd he win?
Season two season two or three,
right.
Whatever Tate was on.
Oh,
switch.
Kick to the body is nice.
He's switched.
Kick is beautiful.
Oh God.
You know was,
yeah,
but almost as a really important point.
Like we're sliding just out of the way.
I know that timing,
that timing.
Hey,
doesn't that timing kind of happens?
But you see the way the distance between,
I mean look,
it can totally land.
Don't get me wrong,
but the way it's missing [inaudible] fuck you.
Tell me
what the hell's going on.
He's 46 years old.
Why are these going?
Whoa.
Oh Man.
Bisbing is fucking stride.
Grapple.
Oh God.
He say it in there with being,
Oh shit.
She said,
come on.
Come on.
Oh,
Holy Shit.
This is a fucking war.
Why rest?
Here's another thing about God.
Nothing about Bisping.
People underestimate resting.
Heartbeat's 34 beats per minute.
This cut.
It's crazy dude.
Right?
Fricking merch dem.
It's a crazy fucking high sign.
How about Dennis?
Kick off Kim.
Avoid date.
Circle right from that fucking right hand.
The right first rason.
This is not good match.
It's not that bad.
It's not.
No.
Here's the thing.
It's below the eye.
Whatever's happening up top is in the forehead,
which bleeds a lot but not that bad.
Hey,
that's his good eye.
Isn't that going to swell?
Shut?
It could,
but here's the thing.
They're working on the cut.
The real problem.
The one thing you don't want to happen almost.
This is a good point
and that was not almost
exact same thing.
Dodged a bullet.
Crazy pressure bisman is under right now.
If I feel for the guy and I don't want him to lose,
here's the thing,
man,
that fucking Dan can definitely still knock them out 100% right?
He knock anybody out.
We said that before,
but it's being survived.
You know,
just the fact that he's able to survive this goddamn gigantic.
It's gonna mess up your cardio two a little bit though,
if you're busy.
Mine,
but Bisping again.
Oh,
I'm worried about is ridiculous.
Cardio.
Remember is Anderson Silva fight?
He was basically out in that tune,
came back.
He was out,
out,
flying flat face and Anderson.
You've walked away from it like it was like it was a walkaway and the referee
kept the fight going down.
Her Dean said no big deal to herb.
He was like,
look,
I'll tell you when it's done.
My job is ref re,
hey,
wake up.
Make get your bitch ass up.
Y'All shit.
Look at this.
Oh my goodness.
Come on Michael.
He just has to land that one.
Goddammit.
Come on,
bids being,
oh look at that inside leg kick.
He and that was beautiful technique.
Fake the right hand.
Now he went high with it.
Holy Shit.
No,
he really doesn't give a fuck about any of that.
He's just ready to fire this h bomb.
That all still sucks.
I liked the way Bisping's moving.
It doesn't mean that Dan can't land it,
but here's the thing.
Well you brought up camps,
super important that left eyes swelling hardcore right now.
I wouldn't mind a tip.
He does.
He,
he doesn't look hurt at all.
It just needs to get a little,
I just need to get a sweat on maybe gas during that flourish.
Maybe I'd have.
He was going for the knockout.
It doesn't have any energy.
It's not a volume.
Punches him in the knee.
Yeah,
I just punched him in and he's not a volume puncher.
He might just be waiting to land that fucking nuclear bomb.
Yeah,
but look,
he keeps getting hit with that switch kick to the arms.
That shit takes a lot of,
I don't even know.
Does
Michael Bisping looking for the power right hand over the top.
You know what the scary thing?
That's fine.
He's cause Bisbing that they play that highlight him getting knocked out,
right?
It's Dan Hill Shins fucking logo.
So going into the fight,
I'm assuming he wants that revenge.
Try and knock them out.
I think
it's kind of a slap that didn't land.
Yeah,
you guys are both blind.
I don't give a fuck.
13 vision.
10 1510 15 oh inside.
Oh
Dude,
if he pulls this off,
this is the craziest,
you know I find ever.
Goodness.
That's an old possum too.
He's seen this before was like a bus crap.
What's scary than a possum?
Nothing.
Badger.
He's more of a pageant.
The honeybadger.
How'd he bagger God?
Be careful down.
Oh Shit.
That left high kicks.
A big factor.
That's why they were talking about it,
Huh?
Yeah.
This thing is a beautiful left high kick
looking for the right hand.
Bisbee is looking to catch him with a right hand.
They've got to get that end swell on the fucking I in between the rounds.
Oh,
spent some time in Thailand for this camp to see that video.
I fuck you're just kicking.
I looked,
yeah,
every fight.
He's the champ too.
You have to respect the fact that him winning the champ did championship.
Must have had an extreme effect as confidence.
Yeah.
He's,
and he's a guy that's never lacked confidence.
He gets to bed.
He's like,
Oh shit.
I told you I was fucking right.
Told you all fruit pastels for everybody got big balls in the UK.
Yeah,
yeah.
Carter's considered UK in Ireland.
Yeah.
Ooh,
look at that knee of the body.
People now they don't even know what the fucking UK is.
Shut it off.
Oh,
he say low.
He's like,
fuck.
Oh God.
Be careful now.
Hateful combination.
You Levine.
Oh,
oh.
Oh.
He's covering his mouth
wrong.
It's so wrong.
I'm free so we can cover his mouth again.
That is some old man.
He's going to break that clench and he's going to rise
this.
Let me ask you this,
this,
this round too.
I was thinking,
who the fuck to rep Bisping's tuning them up.
Bisbing how about this?
You got to go.
Listen man.
He thought he thought he had it,
man.
He thought he had it.
He was turning it on.
If I was going to win by knockout,
he's so confident and Henderson just drops the fucking,
how about keep that left?
Don't look at that.
Is tying them up pretty good coming back.
It's going to be,
he's going to rise up and
it's in England,
so may help.
It'd be tough to get busy in that round.
Boy,
that's a weird round man because for sure Henderson had one spectacular moment.
Hey,
for sure before that first three to give that to Henderson first three and a
half minutes as Biz being,
you look at the round and said,
who won that round to
put them away.
Here's the thing.
Look at this.
Boom.
He tuned Henderson.
It was,
oh my God and Bisping's like what?
Notice the eave Levine.
We'll let you get yo ass
evil Levine.
Look at that.
He's asking question.
What happened?
God Damn it.
Come on please.
It's been fuck man.
While he's getting well,
see they're working on the cut,
but there's all that swelling.
I don't see them.
I don't know.
Maybe,
maybe they weren't where we weren't looking at it,
but I would like to see them have that metal piece,
put that shit on and at the end when you know there's 10 seconds left,
then you put that shit on that cut and fill it up.
But the most important things that he can see,
the crowd is not going to affect his vision because he drives out twice with
that harm.
How good is Bisbing Chin though?
I know it's hard,
but you gotta realize that Bisbing part of that flurry was him kicking Henderson
and the Dick.
Now that we know that for sure.
Oh,
I left high kick again
to keep coming because it's like a fucking bear trap.
So do you give the first two rounds to Henderson?
I would,
yeah,
I do.
I don't know the kick to the deck now that I know it was a kick to the Dick.
That's what I'm saying.
I might say.
I might say it's an even round or you might be able to give it to Bisping.
No,
I don't know.
How would they kicked him out?
Didn't sway you more towards him.
He almost finished it in the second round and the first round,
the truth around when he always left son.
It's true.
The almost finished him.
No,
you got a good point.
I mean,
I'm just making an argument,
but what do we,
what are we judging?
You know there's two rounds kicks to the knee first two rather than going like
Ha Henderson could almost a finished him.
Yup,
correct.
But it looked like Bisping was coming on strong in the second round,
but now we know as a kick to the deck,
it had a big factor in there.
Think about if you're a judge,
you're thinking,
God,
who did the most damage and the most shots.
If you look at the strike stats,
I guarantee you Bisping's landed way more shot.
You don't care.
Well,
they don't care about that.
Usually look at Dotson Linacre but the actual volume,
you know,
I'm embarrassed to say I have not seen that fight.
I'll dare you,
sir.
I'm embarrassed.
Well,
you've been killing elk,
so I'll give you out there.
I got to get a year's worth of meat in one shot.
That's,
that's fair.
It's more fighting for his family.
I don't have a grill.
How dare I wish you would make some of the,
and I know you American grown on the guys talking about grill big.
It looks very good.
Look at that Jab.
Here's the thing about Bisping,
man.
He's looking at fluid and smooth,
even in the face of dire danger and he's looking bloody,
but he's not changing his game plan.
Like he's doing fucking win by knockout man.
He wants it to bad cell phones.
So far he's been able to survive like,
I mean he's got to go after him.
He's got out,
he wants to where Dan out.
And right now we're,
we're headed into the third,
right?
So we got two 15 the third,
we got two more rounds after this.
This is crazy.
Oh,
Beautiful Jab.
Dan does look a little bit,
it looks a little time.
I've got the power he could throw out
too,
but it was a beautiful face,
beautiful thing to a leg kick and he showed it to him again.
Now he taxed with the inside.
I think Brisbane to win has to win these next three rounds.
Dan.
Dan Isn't can lose one of these rounds.
Yeah.
Bisbee he's gotta be careful with that thing that he's doing.
He's doing this switch to the high kick,
but he's doing it.
He's dropping that left hand and a big way.
I,
yeah,
it keeps doing it and pull him biff Henderson Times that that switched to the
high kick.
If he's got it in them,
it's a matter of whether he's got it in a tank,
but he throws that step in looping right hand.
If he can time that switch to the high kick.
Bisbing can't get out of the way.
Once that legs and play,
he's all the way his legs up in the air and he's throwing,
especially when you're going high,
there's very little head moving is very little that you have left.
He's also timing his jab when he comes in,
that's all day and coming over the top Henderson's from like three punches.
This round,
that punch.
That's
all it.
Well,
I don't think he's capable.
Our tank is the power tank.
Just refueling.
I'll think he's capable of making those all.
He made the fake to the a new tab.
I don't think he's capable of making those,
those rounds the way Bisping's fighting.
No,
he just,
he's just refueling that battery.
Yeah.
He's like a video game.
He's just,
yeah.
Video game.
Is this right?
And actually known as the h bomb.
Yeah.
I think that's more,
we're now named it.
It looks like Dan slipped.
He landed.
Yeah.
God,
that's dangerous.
Definitely busy thing.
No matter what happens in the US and UK history,
this forth for Horry.
Right.
Come on.
This did look at this number bigger and better than the UK.
The first round Henderson landed more because he has this thing dealing trouble
like no one thinks that Bisping win the first round,
right?
Impossible.
First round,
a hundred percent Henderson second round because they paid him off.
He looked great.
He looked great for a while,
but he got knocked down and almost finished at the end of the round.
At the end of the rug got taken over.
There's a difference.
Third round.
The third round.
Yes.
He's still got,
he's got to do is throw one.
You're right.
None of this means daily hired two in business because it makes it a better
fight.
It's like a title.
It's bomb is right fucking there.
Look right there.
You never know.
Now powerful stiff kick by Dan.
Look for the high kicks.
Bisbee but now I see what they want the left cause mom's coming down.
He smiled and he knows it.
Yeah.
As long as he's standing,
no matter how wobbly he is,
remember fate or his fucking him up and then uh,
yeah,
then he
hit him.
Recite fader was winning.
He went up to dog fight control.
He didn't have the wizard.
He kept punching.
So he had his back and then
turned around quick install because of that wizard.
Yup.
All because of a lack of wisdom.
Deep half guard.
Yeah.
The lack of wisdom inside control with the under hook blasted up the dog fight
from side control.
Boom.
They don't kept throwing punches when he should throw the wizard,
the wizard and back down.
But he kept throwing punches.
So he got his back and then he kind of face planted.
He was fine.
He was winning,
but he face planted.
Hey,
take a one second break.
But that position,
Damn Henderson was right there.
Well Henderson Henderson went,
I think he went for the deep half,
if I remember correctly.
And he got here and then he threw an uppercut and he dropped like fate or like
face planted from the upper cut.
I think he scrambled and I think in the scramble,
Henderson landed a nasty uppercut as far as,
that's how I remember it.
And I knew went face plant had them inside control.
One side control beat comes down to the fourth round.
We're going and forth,
but we've got to pay attention to this.
[inaudible]
we'll watch it with watching for sure.
But here we go.
Forth this fine.
People were hating on it.
Oh,
I loved it.
I loved this fire.
I'm so glad they made it.
Yeah,
this is the fourth round.
Only.
Holy fucking shit.
Rockhold has gotta be home right now.
Calling.
What in the fuck?
How did I underestimate this dude gangster?
My topping is tough.
He's gangsters.
Fox until two on Henderson.
Uh,
I don't know man.
We're in England.
Who knows who's judging?
Who's you know.
I would agree with you.
He wanted the last one.
He's today one in my book under buddy.
I'm with Eddie.
It could be,
it could be two to one or someone might have made the second round and even
round may have gave that last round to Dan Henderson to praise.
Our second was an inside job.
Here goes,
hey.
Just kidding.
I know I almost fucking
got plenty of time.
It's fight.
We got to play any time.
We don't have to go anywhere.
I wish you Jamin brought some.
We're going to keep going.
Eat or something.
We get snack on,
dude.
I got some
Digiorno's fucking pizza crushes Domino's.
Remember that shit?
Let's just watch the fight inside leg kick by Henderson.
Okay.
Oh,
he's talking to him?
Yeah,
I got a piece saw.
God.
No,
I can't.
I'm going to do that though.
Round.
Hey Dude.
We need to have someone invent something that we could pee right here and like a
little beautiful.
They got that.
Oh,
Bisbing hurt him.
Where's it at?
Peace means just teeing off man the volume,
the volume of [inaudible] that he is throwing their front leg side kick to the
knee.
Well not to the knee above the knee.
Charlie Brown kids.
So weird that you're not allowed to target the joint with a strike,
but you're allowed to heal.
Hook somebody.
What the fuck is that wasn't bad.
That is a weird rule,
Joe.
Like you can't front kick a dude right on the kneecap,
but you can heal.
Hook them who and rip his fucking Nia parts cause you can't front kick the knee
in some states.
Some states have rules against attacking the joy.
What I've just done,
their low most retarded,
rather another local arrest.
Dan,
these are sacred heads.
Okay.
Not the sacredness.
Dan's a pro.
He's gonna take some time for 59 he's a pro.
Yeah,
he got cracked the second time of the fight.
Ooh,
that was a nut sack son.
Yeah,
he's got,
but he's going to take it move.
That's what your fucking head have in big balls.
Now here's,
let me ask you this.
Do you think they should be able to work on Michael Bisping's eye while Dan
Henderson is a is sitting there recovering like,
yeah,
it's an APP so foul.
Would it be nice if he could see a little bit better?
No,
that would be bullshit.
Well,
it's just time off.
It's just an eye.
Is he going to go back?
I was going to take the time taking.
He's going to do the full five east 46 the UFC a massage.
The balls.
That doesn't help.
It just makes them hurt.
Trust me.
It helps.
No matter what.
This tells the plane goes away.
See that he's stuffing.
They kind of shake that ball down.
Imagine if that was the job of like one girl,
like this one girl was just like,
she hasn't met the jihad ball massage.
Now it's about the technique.
What is,
what does my watches,
things like who cares if she has fake tits?
Michael Bisping is complaining.
The Dan Henderson is milking it.
You started clapping and pointing to him.
He's still taking his guys.
He's a pro.
Dan Henderson is milking this.
I know.
They don't know if that one we go perfect timing this.
It's like you have a psyche connection to Dan Henderson.
If you're back,
you're back from the can.
I know of that when I see it as it gives live time.
He used it.
Well.
How long do you think you waited?
Two minutes or three minutes maybe even maybe.
Right?
You got three rounds rests.
That's a big rest.
4,600 of those cups where they make a mold of your fucking Dick and your balls
and I hear about those every day.
No circles.
I travel
and make got mold of you fucking package and they make a cup around your
packets.
Let's watch the fight.
Hey,
two 18 and keep track of what Dan does after that long break,
he's going to drop skin.
Ask serious right hand,
serious recovery.
That's a long,
that was the left.
We have that.
The lack of flexibility in that leg kick.
That's on Charlie Brown cakes.
World class level I think.
Great.
And he had kicked,
he had kicked back to the lumbar with that.
Sure as hell did.
Oh good job.
Oh Man.
You give him two minute Rasta,
he fucked up.
He had kicked lumbered with the right.
I wonder if Dan Henderson was knocking fools out like in junior high.
I'm sure.
Raise your rates.
Here's what everybody forgets.
Everybody forgets.
They used to call him decision.
Dan,
he forgets this.
Yes.
I did a whole piece about this for the UFC recently.
That it wasn't until 2003 it was when he knocked out my real Bustamante.
He knocked out Marula Bustamante and everybody knew that he had power.
Like remember he fucked up Vandelay he hurt his eye.
I think that was 2001 if I remember correctly in pride.
But around the Marillo Bustamonte fight,
he started realizing he could Merck motherfuckers.
So he started really like throwing all his power into shots as something changed
in Dan Henderson's fight style because now everybody knows him has one of the
most dangerous knockout punches ever.
But they used to call them decision Dan on the underground.
That was his nickname.
Riddick Bowe had this,
went through the same thing Riddick Bowe never knocked anybody had in the
beginning.
And then when he was criticized about that,
then he started fucking people.
That's a little different.
Cause Dan,
you know with his worldclass wrestling back on,
he's just decision guys using these grappling.
They freak out.
Oh Shit.
That's right.
Hand is from God.
Check this out.
Yeah.
Also different
because there's only one thing that correct.
You know,
I mean we're,
we're talking about,
wow,
look at this.
When Riddick Bowe was fighting,
he was just boxing.
Now Dan learned how to strike while he was MMA fighting.
Correct.
Learn how to just drop Haymac cause I came into it.
Just a straight wrestler.
Yeah.
Look at Biz being thrown.
Sidekicks,
you the neat
things.
I came in to get appointment that I swelled up real proper.
Well Bisping has a background in traditional martial arts and a lot of people
forget that.
Like he's a really good kicker.
It didn't happen at like 17 I'm not surprised as good karate to head.
Is it two around?
Is it to,
to who won that round?
I know.
Got To give that to best pattern.
No volume.
What did Henderson do?
He landed a few left jabs.
Right.
But the volume of strikes and overall you've got to give it to best bang.
So this might be the deciding right now.
This is crazy.
Empathy's Cardio's insane.
I would assume.
I think bisman puts on a flurry here,
but he's,
he'll open himself up to a huge right hand maybe.
But the,
so the second round is,
well here you go.
Do the Henderson did not fight hard at the end of the round after he came back
after taking that break,
some of that might've been part of his strategy.
He might've said,
look,
I'm going to take this big gray the fifth I'm going to.
Yeah.
And then,
um,
this is a really smart move because I'll have a deep gas tank in the fifth round
and it's his last round of his career and have since last name.
That's what he's been saying.
Yeah.
But I would say that too,
if I was trying to renegotiate my contract as the middleweight champion of the
world,
but Bisbing is at home.
I got a good idea.
I bet he's done.
He might be done,
but why he's your cyber fire to the restaurant.
Go,
come on baby.
Come on baby.
You ever see Dan Henderson fight?
This is a big five minutes.
Fuck yeah,
me go.
Here we go.
The legend.
Okay.
If he wins this fight,
he arguably has the greatest career of all time.
Let's think about that.
What's on the line?
This next strike force.
UFC.
Yeah.
Two two titles simultaneously and prides Strikeforce title knocked out Faye
Door,
knocked out Hector Lombard in his last fight and at 46 years old if he could
win.
It's arguably as the greatest career of all time.
Look at Bisping.
He's looking at an Olympic medal,
right?
No,
no,
no.
He was silver.
Silver,
silver in the Olympics.
Yeah,
that's a career.
Oh yeah.
Oh He's,
he's on the Mount Rushmore.
Yeah,
100% for sure.
If legends second.
The first guy I was there for his first fight in the UFC in 1996.
Damn,
that's old school.
Remember he fought frank.
She said 96 why does this no six?
No,
it couldn't have been 96 because my first uh,
time in the UFC was in 97.
So it must have been 97 or 98.
Dude,
I think you're writing about him saving for this last round.
Yeah.
Well that's what a veteran would do,
right?
You got that three minutes.
Let's just skate for the next and try to blow them out.
What year was,
yeah,
powerful memory.
98.
Sorry.
98 [inaudible] 97 open 98
year.
Ryan goes,
oh,
that's right.
Allen goes very controversial.
Descend on unanimous decision.
Hey,
have you ever seen Alan goes versus Frank Shamrock?
Sure haven't.
Oh Shit.
That was in pancreas.
Palm strikes only.
Watch that show.
I'll never met at pawn.
Here we go.
Three 36 this is big.
This is huge.
Come on baby.
Okay.
Ooh,
nice combination.
See when you're looking at sheer volume,
Bisping's got a big leaguer.
Yeah.
And see the,
there's an argument to be said for breaking fights up in rounds is not wise,
and that the wise way to judge a fight is to give them rounds,
but judge the fight as a whole,
that's what pride did.
And I think that's the more effective God that was like uh,
like he's got some kind of,
he's like the guru reefer with last shit.
It's just comes down to the power.
Ridiculous crouch.
What are those blades called?
Sickles.
Yes.
Yeah.
Blocked that left high kick.
Kick has him in.
I think that we have a flawed system and a guy being able to win around and then
went around and,
and then a couple rounds later he gets almost finished and the fight ends with
him being almost finished but yet he could still win.
Cause cause you're saying cause that guy won the fight.
The other guy won on the card.
He won the game.
How about knockout?
Only MMA like you own wholly knockout or submission or some imagined it's
finished has agreed to that
same.
You keep going,
you over time around.
So someone gets finished and you do it in a football field.
Yes.
Let's do you want to do it?
How is it all down to
dog?
Don't make this shit happen.
Reservation.
Hey,
we're going to call it.
Oh left Pittsburgh with a beautiful right left and right there.
Nice Jab.
Is there already an RFC?
Oh,
nice.
Inside leg kick by Dan.
Probably reality fighting championships.
Wasn't that something?
Fight companion championships.
Just to call it the Rogan fight league if I can paint championships is good.
Yeah.
Shit.
The wheat.
Oh.
Oh,
Henderson with the right.
Careful over there.
Dot.
Careful in that cage is being one 43 degrees.
The crowd's going nuts.
Take some down.
Are you kidding me?
He's got his back,
dude.
Oh Shit.
He's going to get a knee bar is going to roll for knee bar.
Damn.
What the fuck are you just down looking at the Greco Roman?
He's about to do some nasty ground and pound him.
Now.
Did [inaudible] not gone into effect yet,
honey?
We got on the ground,
dude.
Oh Shit.
One seven two,
one,
one big deep breaths and Bisping's got that crazy cardio
really quick.
They both look a little dude.
What does that decision,
Beautiful Jab in England.
She was like,
this is going to be mad at a busy being decision in England,
but I guarantee you the UFC brought their own judges.
You think?
Oh yeah,
I would imagine
a bird out of badging.
Oh,
look at this.
I would imagine you can't really rely on the local judges.
I can't rely on the American judge.
He does.
He's not going to take him down.
Oh,
that doesn't make them look good.
He's going to lose this round.
Oh,
not necessarily.
There's still 32 seconds of hammertime possibly.
That's true.
He's landed more strikes in the last three rounds.
That's what it says.
Yes,
for sure.
Then the last significant one to ten eight left.
Do you see that one gotta be a tenant?
I would say so for sure.
It's going to be a draw then.
Who the fuck knows?
Right?
Trial.
We still don't have exact.
Tends to draw from rare.
They get this.
How much time?
10 seconds.
No Fun events over to Cartwheel kick when we volume ends.
The fight on his back.
That ain't good.
No.
Terrible.
His big might.
This decision that he got it.
He might've.
Why don't I bet he going to be a drone.
You can one the last three rounds,
but the first round with a ten eight draw.
Who knows?
It wouldn't do a draw.
It's done.
We could turn it off now start talking about RFC.
Oh,
we were going to talk about something.
What?
Fight.
Oh,
fader door and Dan Henderson pull up the fader and Dan Henderson,
cause
this is what I think,
I think Fado was on top ground and pound in.
Henderson went to deep half.
He reversed him,
got into a position where he's on his back and he did.
When the upper cut and flat faced a fatal I,
that's exactly what happened.
Then he finished off with ground and potato or cracked them,
dropped it and he dropped him.
And then fader was inside control trying to finish him from side control.
Dan Henderson hit that under hook and he hit that under Jack under hook face,
planetary door.
Here's base plan of,
here it is.
Let's just watch it too.
What happens?
Let's see.
The business decision first.
Yeah,
for sure.
But they,
they're gonna,
it's gonna take a few seconds for the show.
That decision.
So here,
uh,
push ahead to the stoppage tracks.
It looks like he cracks,
Henderson has him on the ground before that.
Buddy,
so yeah,
he drops him.
He ends up in side control.
Dan Henderson from side control hat grabs the under hook.
It takes it to dogfight fight or doesn't throw whizzer and he exposes his back
and then he hits him with a shot.
You're very confident in their,
so I'm inclined to think that you know what you're talking about.
I'm never when I could be wrong.
Now I have a lower buddy and I'm like,
damn,
I didn't remembered it all wrong.
I could easily be wrong.
That's also fade or fade or there.
By the way,
that's the sort of,
that's Fado that had been stopped by big Silva still though.
It was also the big,
big Brett Rogers and didn't do well in that fight.
Worries that real quick.
Here does.
He drops him.
This is the fight,
right?
He hits him with a hard punch.
See,
here's the deal.
Oh,
drop some flat foot
control
path.
We go to the coach's book cards.
Burgess judges score in the car.
Oh Shit.
Here he comes.
47 48 47 and 49 46
oh shit.
Wow.
I'll tell you what those Rockhold
licking their chops.
Wow.
That was a fricking fight.
You know what happened for this powerful has been at the end of the fight,
however you scored,
please
listen to him.
They just said something to each other.
Shit.
Sorry about that.
I want to hear what they're saying to each other.
It's been quite good.
People talk about your skill.
Let's watch the feed or knock out one more time.
I wonder what business should I say it one more time.
Let's see what he says.
Slow motion.
Give it up for Dan Henderson.
Beautiful.
Good.
That goldfish.
We can't really play this though.
The problem is we can't.
I see what you're saying.
It's not ours,
so look,
you got to look.
Look right.
Hurts him.
He's boom.
Crowd control.
He grabs the under hood.
Yeah,
you're right.
Yeah.
It looked like it was a deep house.
His right leg was on the outside.
It may have been quarter.
You may have had the foot.
It's hard to tell one more time.
It wasn't the deep.
Yeah,
no,
you're right.
I thought for some reason I had imagined that his right leg was in play.
That it was in between the legs.
But you're right.
You're totally right.
Look,
he siren sound right there.
You second control.
Maybe border guard,
man.
Fight.
No.
Wizard uppercuts.
Yep.
No,
you're totally right.
He did it.
He did it from the,
is that Michael Bisping's dad there?
That is.
Wow.
I feel good for that guy.
Defensive it.
Big Win.
I feel good for that guy in his hometown.
Yeah.
Big Win.
I wished both would retire.
I know it's controversial.
I wish Bisbing you want them to retire?
Why?
He's not too old.
Like what is it his,
if he loses when he loses a lot
of great fights coming up.
A big paydays coming up.
Yeah.
Big Page.
You gotta to worry about it too much.
Is it just as much as anybody if not more?
Yeah.
Okay.
Tell me which fight he's favorite unless she goes,
oh,
brain Weidman,
rocky guy.
That's the guy enjoys victory
match that he's in.
He could,
when he got a point,
he could win every match point.
You never know,
right?
Hey Rockhold you never know.
I'm just saying he's doing the blocking every single one of those matchups
that's why he's the underdog in the Rockhold fight.
And that's how he won the title.
That'd be the exception.
But you're right.
Do you think he say,
what did he,
was he favored in this fight?
Yes.
Two to one.
It's big.
Okay.
Here's the scary fight.
Him Eol
Romero and Rockhold.
Rematches a monster riot halls monster.
Dude.
Uriah hall got stopped in his last fight by Derek Brunson,
but he's a God damn monster.
I don't think they're all monsters right now though.
Who's not worried about them?
Because Michael is down 10 nos.
Why?
Fuck Weidman's dangerous.
Fuck.
Don't sleep.
Don't sleep on Talus.
Latus he's one of those guys like,
he's just like Damien Maia.
They came in pure Jujitsu,
didn't have striking,
didn't have wrestling,
but a lot of,
uh,
Jujitsu guys would have just said,
fuck it.
I got,
there's enough money in Jujitsu,
you know,
myself included.
No need to do that.
It's true.
You know?
But he stuck it up.
Damien Maia stuck it out.
Rowan Carnero stuck it out.
If I breached the word,
don't,
we're doing stuck it out and then now they're legit.
Stryker's now with legit wrestling.
I heard for resolvers came to sember Senate.
That's what I heard.
That's the rumor mill.
Fallis late has got an arm triangle from hell.
He could put anybody.
Let me ask you this.
That's a sleeper right there.
Why would they have that fight?
Steeping needs time off.
How much time was he needed off?
Enough time for those guys to fight in the winter.
It's interesting.
That's interesting.
Do you agree with that?
Do you think that's good idea.
I do.
To have a cane or a ratio you can do because if you have Cain and for Bho,
both weight and fight different guys,
you know what I'm saying?
You could have that.
That could be a headliner to fuck.
You have to headline two Oh seven yeah.
What side of Jamie [inaudible] December 30th to sell new years eve,
so they'd probably be the Ronda Rousey fight.
If she comes back,
she'll probably be on the New Year's Eve card.
That's usually their biggest cost.
That's going to happen.
Who knows?
Uh,
you,
you don't know.
I mean,
I
have no idea about this.
You don't,
you don't really know.
This is cool.
They're shaking hands and he's giving them props because he retired right now.
I don't know.
I think he is.
I wish we judge the fight on how you look at
legend son.
That's cool.
Good for Bisbing man.
What did he say?
I don't know
which.
We tried to fight on how you look after the fight.
How busted up.
How rude.
That's great.
Fine.
That's a funny thing to say.
Back at Bisping's career,
when they do a documentary on that show on Hbo,
it ended right now.
Fuck,
look at the guys.
He's well.
Well yeah,
he's by far the biggest thing ever happened in UK MMA.
But you look at his career,
looking at the guys,
he's lost to most of our TRT guys and looking at the ics beat.
Okay,
but the UK is Ireland,
right?
Didn't we establish that?
It's not someone tweeted and said,
no,
no.
Sorry folks.
We're so sorry.
All you people over there.
Oh,
we didn't.
We don't really get offended by geography.
We don't know.
We don't know who your king is.
There's a lot of shit.
We don't know.
Kings are cool.
I wish we had a king better than it.
Yeah.
What the fuck we got now?
I don't think they have tried this in the God damn.
Eddie's upset.
I don't think Ireland,
Ireland doesn't have kings.
I don't think so.
I don't know.
Right.
I wish I knew you all sound like complete princes and collab queens.
They're going to show the Brad Pickett Uri Alcantara fight.
This is a one round spoiler alert is the official name in case you know you can
have Great Britain and Northern Ireland.
Okay.
Official name of the UK is now,
I can't even break Great Britain and Northern Ireland,
but I thought Ireland in Northern Ireland would like pretty much United now.
Hey Bro.
So England,
Scotland,
Wales and Ireland or the United Kingdom.
Hmm.
Okay.
Although most of Ireland is now independent.
Interesting.
Huh?
Irish people are just clowning us right now.
Yeah.
They're like,
hey,
down down,
shit about us.
He can't even do a fucking Irish accent.
Joey couldn't tell him.
Could do an Irish accent.
Kenny,
he could do Conor McGregor.
Kenny didn't,
didn't you just do Joey doing Conor McGregor be taught?
Probably did it Yuri for good.
I forgot to click in do Joey.
That's one of the funny shit.
Oh Shit.
Uri Alcantara all over.
Brad Pickett.
Brad pickets at some goddamned wars in his career.
Did there Brad Pickett.
Uh,
who did he knock out?
Well,
he heard me.
He hurt.
Well,
he's knocked out a bunch of old,
but he's knocked out a big,
big time dude.
That that would surprise you.
Was it Ben of eating in the order that would surprise you?
Who Was it?
Big Time Guy.
Can you bring that up Jay?
He didn't knock out Benevidez right.
Knock out Benevidez was mighty mouse.
Did he knock down mighty mouse?
I don't think so.
No.
A Brad Pickett knocked someone the fuck out.
See if you can find out.
Brad pickets.
WC.
Oh,
please.
Got An analyst.
Or is it an empowered to the temple?
Nasty hunches.
Cut that on,
uh,
on super slow Mo.
Nasty ground and pound.
I see what he's doing.
He's Gassy.
He's never,
he never went to his knees.
He passed standing.
Now he's on his knees.
Once he passes or that beautiful and get on his knees to leave pet.
Beautiful.
Now look at this standing triangle,
triangle,
rap kid
Armbar I,
oh
my God.
Look at this beautiful,
beautiful.
Pick it on the head.
Beautiful.
Amazing battle.
He's supposed to look just like that.
It's supposed to look just like that.
We need a highlight reel of that.
That's pretty stunning.
You're average at the school.
That happens all the time.
Keep going down.
Keep going down to look.
Look up left.
That's his record right there.
She keep going to hell for me.
It's,
it's one that to surprise you.
Who's already all the way down to 2007 gone.
Damn God.
Hold.
Let me see.
Am I bad chick?
That's Brad Pickett.
Yeah.
Hold on.
I'm thinking about someone else.
No,
I'm missing one
here.
Uh
Oh by the city's just Johnson pay.
Interesting.
2006 years ago.
How crazy.
You don't think about it.
Years ago he knew it.
I got knocked out but I know what your big win.
Big Win.
It's a crazy way.
It's a motherfucker.
Yeah.
Well he's a really good striker is Brazilian.
So break this shit up every effort.
So Dominick Cruz,
powerful Alpha brain,
bringing that out of my bed.
Kell Brook,
we could not remember kelp off.
Both of us try,
tries dust.
God not searching for water.
I was just looking for something just that happens so often to me man here in
like when does it get it?
Like obviously I'm 49 and obviously my brain is not going to work in 40 years.
Like when I'm 89 for sure it's going to suck.
So like when does it start?
Is it going to start next year?
Keep up with the Alpha brain.
Ma'Am,
I'm doing my best but it's not going to work 300 years.
Technology 96 and he was still speaking like he was 29 but technology might
advance,
you know and help your brain and never know what did,
you could put Jack Daniels versus technology.
You can put your brain.
They figured out,
they haven't figured out how to put a bus stop,
but they did figure out how to take your brain and put it in some shit and keep
you alive so that you're alive.
You just can't move.
You're just your brain where it should read this and
they could keep you alive.
Pop up on that tower seven website I said,
I said
take your brain out and keep your on your brain where you could actually make
shit happen with just your brain.
We figured,
no,
I don't want that.
They haven't figured out how to take your brain and put it on another body
because it was common.
They're doing some experiments.
Would you do it 80 class when I was a hundred I was got to do while you are
alive.
Piece of basically you got to commit suicide and then they have you and your
brain.
You're in the hospital and then they got pretty hard.
They have to be like brain from teenage mutant Ninja Turtles.
You have to be that guy.
I think just something they have like a map of the future laid out and you have
to commit to this map of the future.
They've got to go look right now.
We can't put you in another body,
but what we can to keep your body in this jail for at least three years before
we put you in another body and you can still talk to your home.
You say we have it,
the brain and the body.
He's got like a super robot
that was shredders main homie.
That's what I'm talking about,
but imagine if they said Look Gi,
what we've determined is that the brain has to sustain this solution for three
years.
So for three years you are,
you are going to be trapped in this brain,
but you'll stay alive.
You'll know that you're alive and you're fucked and you don't know what it's
going to be.
We can come out after three years.
We don't know how you're going to deal with the fact that you couldn't talk.
You couldn't tell anybody you were okay.
He had to survive inside of this jar for three years as a drain and electro with
an eye so that you could see out your brain,
so you can't talk,
you can't communicate,
but the people that know your homeys,
when your family comes in,
they can just put on a fucking TV.
They go,
he loves this shit.
Boom.
And they could see that that the electric eye blinking,
bluish kind of paralyzed for three years term.
You're doing a jail term for three years.
If I was a hundred my balls right down to the ground,
my bad day,
go do it.
Girls at fall in love with brains and chicken.
He says he can't communicate about his Mars.
No communicating,
can't communicate,
but he can eventually the smart motherfuckers can communicate little by little
you're fucked up.
The movie evolution is evolution and there's going to be a couple of brains that
can do clicks for yes or no.
My thought,
my thought is doing three years in a bowl of Jello.
When you come out,
we have to hope that you can psychologically survive the fact that three hour
talk.
Do you have in your eyes?
I'm watching old lady going to do for three years.
Take Black Dick [inaudible] he wants,
he just wants to see people jerking Mongolians,
Mongols.
They gonna come in and they're fucker intense and you're watching and you can
tell by the brain,
aura and the color eastern bloc,
the brain,
just
eastern bloc due to big giant square heads.
Super aggressive with face tattoos.
Wow.
It's the,
it's the frequency of the brain.
The Gremlin after midnight
ruining my movie,
my movie,
the brain is just,
the torture is,
there's just no way you can express yourself.
I'm not terrible.
They can't read your brain.
Your brain is in suspended animation.
Pulse,
three years,
blood rushing to it to hope for three years.
It's in some sort of a biogen editor,
uh,
bullshit.
Can I sign up for
you?
Bring strippers and it's like,
there's no coincidence.
It's conspiracy.
And the skeptics like,
you don't know.
It's just the brain.
Drunks.
Too many,
too many drinks after midnight.
Feed him after midnight.
So definitely making sense for sure.
No,
it's so fresh.
Yeah.
I mean it's for anyone has made sense ever.
Okay,
Brian,
why are you with Joe?
Do
you hate me?
You,
hey,
listen,
it's totally logical.
Okay,
here's the fucked up thing.
If you do die right,
and they can take your brain and transfer port it into another body and rig up
something for you.
What if we find out though that death is not really death,
that all these ancient religions were on to something is that death is a portal
to another experience that you haven't entered into yet and I was awesome.
I haven't done that,
but I've done DMT obviously,
which is the main thing in Iowasca,
which is what your body produces when you're done with someone else.
Someone else.
You did five methodoxy DMT.
You know what,
and it was a very spiritual experience and made me believes that there I believe
in a higher power.
I don't know what it is.
I don't know if it's that bearded dude.
I don't know if it's the olive dude.
I Dunno if it's the Jewish dude.
I don't know if it's the African dude or the Inca dude.
I didn't go there.
There's some kind of shit.
There's some something in my opinion,
this is just my opinion.
Something created that created,
there is a creator of some sort.
It could be a fucking nerd computer simulation.
People believed that everyone believes in computer simulations.
Oh,
that could be true.
Kneeled to grass.
Fucking Tyson says it.
So that could be true that we're a computer in a computer simulation.
But when you start talking about like a creator or a higher power,
whatever,
God,
but a computer centers are not following that
one.
I'm just saying that fucking Neil degrasse Tyson,
he doesn't like him because he represents absolute facts that can't be argued
with.
And that Shit's dangerous for a conspiracy theorist.
If Neil walked in right now,
I would love it.
Oh my God.
How you know what I would do if Neil degrasse Tyson walked in right now?
Uh,
what would you do to make a mind fuck you?
He would choke your mind.
Eti you choke your mind,
your mind and electric.
You're talking about the moon.
And then I would listen to him talk about the,
how we actually went to the moon.
And I would,
uh,
I enjoy that.
Hey,
so what was your point?
I don't remember now.
It was,
it was about if you die,
what chapter yet?
Another portal is that we don't know.
Look,
I've said this before,
but I'll say it again.
Nobody's scared to sleep,
but everybody's scared to die.
No,
everybody wants to go to sleep.
Everybody does.
We look forward to it and we look forward to shutting off.
Cause we know that we're going to come back.
But everybody's terrified of death and we don't understand sleep.
We don't know why we need it.
We don't know what the fuck happens.
We don't know what dreams are.
We don't understand what kind of psychedelic chemicals are being produced by our
own brains while we're out cold.
We don't know what the experience is.
We know we come back with crazy memories and some people are capable of
manipulating those memories or manipulating that experience and they have lucid
dreaming.
I have to just,
I,
I've had brief moments of lucid dreaming and I've never put any effort
whatsoever into trying to get good at it.
But I know that some people do.
And they concentrate on it all the time.
I've done it.
I'm sure.
I'm sure you have.
My point is,
yeah,
there's a lot,
but my point is we don't know what it is.
We don't know what death is.
We don't know.
We were so convinced that this state of being awake is the only state that
exists,
but we already know of another state that we have no evidence when we,
when we are alive.
When you're walking through life,
you watch the UFC,
you're driving your car.
You have no fucking idea what was going on for eight hours of your day.
You don't.
You wake up,
oh my alarm clock went up.
Time to get up.
You have,
you have evidence based on a few fucking slide shows of ridiculousness that took
place in your imagination.
Air quotes in the last eight fucking hours.
We're not talking about five minutes of your day.
We're talking about eight fucking hours of your day.
We have to shut your head off.
What?
You literally have no idea what's going on around you.
You have no idea.
You have faith that you're going to wake up cause you woken up every other day
for your whole life.
That alone is fucking bizarre that you would have any confidence whatsoever.
It's what happens when you die and that you could tell me that you know for sure
you don't know what the fuck happens when you go to sleep.
Bitch,
you don't have a damn clue as to what the fuck happens when your eyes are closed
and you're [inaudible]
to die.
Something has to what's going on in your brain.
We don't know.
It's this.
We're all basing on our rudimentary understanding of normal awake consciousness,
which for a guy like me that's on a brain scientist or you or anybody in this
room,
we don't fucking know.
We barely understand consciousness on the highest levels of science.
They barely understand what consciousness is.
There's,
there's arguments as to what causes it this August arguments as to what defines
it,
which is it does a plant consciousness.
Plants can detect it when animals are chewing next to them,
plants they,
they excrete certain chemicals to make themselves tastes like shit.
When they hear caterpillar sounds from a tape recorder.
Is that conscious?
No.
Okay.
What about a dog?
My dog knows when I'm pulling into the driveway,
he starts barking.
He gets excited to see me.
Is he conscious?
No.
Venus fly trap.
Exactly.
Or how about those ones in the Amazon and eat rats?
They got this crazy.
Feels like a trumpet.
A rat falls into it.
It dissolves the rat.
He's like,
bitch,
you never get now a little shop of horrors.
Yeah.
This fucking all kinds of crazy shit that you can say that part plant put
animals,
uneasiness lunch.
Right?
Remember on TV when I was a kid,
you could order that shit.
That was though.
He's still a little mercial.
Still get those and it's still fine.
I still buy it.
It on Valentine's Day.
Uh,
two dozen Dina's flight tracker should I believe?
I think I had one ex wife.
That shit right there.
Dope Dude.
The eat flies in your house.
Leave the window open.
Come on in,
bitch.
You don't pull it all fucking shit.
What is a big sign and fly trap number recorded?
Can you imagine?
One like little shop of horrors.
Remember that she had AP move?
Was that based on,
what was he rapping?
The Cuny people,
of course,
it could be something like if you went back to the dinosaur days,
I guarantee there's all sorts of plants that were eating shit that slipped up.
We're sure eating like ancient Rome or wherever the fuck there was around 65
million years.
Lost Line of source.
Do you think that's just the same guy that thinks that the earth is flat?
You put out a video about dinosaurs being fake problem with that.
Of course we have bones.
There's false shit load of them.
All of them,
like in the museums,
there's a lot of them are bad and they fell out of them,
but that's not true.
See,
here's the thing.
When you look in at a fossil,
well you're looking at is not necessarily really a bone.
What it is is we're minerals have taken place of where the bone used to be,
what a fossilized like.
Have you ever see a megalodon tooth,
like a shark tooth on discovery channel?
Mack Bud Brotzmann had one on his office.
Remember we had that conversation,
we had a conversation about it,
and bud was telling me that this is a mega don tooth,
and I said,
it's sort of,
it is kind of a mega don tooth,
but it really is a fossil of mega don to,
what that means is over millions and millions and millions of years,
the actual tooth itself is changed by the ground and it's becomes mineralized
and it becomes like a rock.
So it's the shape of a megalodon tooth,
but it's not exactly the same as it was in the Mega Don's mouth.
So years ago.
The actual shape,
the shape of it,
but it's not a tooth.
Do you remember,
do a DNA test on it?
It's a fossil.
It's weed.
And you were a kid that oil came from dinosaurs.
Do you remember that?
She had,
that's what they used to fossil fuels.
Hey Man,
there's a guy who worked on that.
JFK Administration.
He was the chief of special operations for the Joint Chiefs of Staff under the
JFK administration.
His name is l Fletcher Prouty proudy l Fletcher.
Prouty.
Look that dude up and when you,
what he says about oil,
Holy Shit with that dude says a bottle.
He said,
this is what he said.
I don't know if it's true.
I'm not a geologist,
I'm not an oil.
He says that a peak oil,
like the scare that we're going to run out of oil is perpetrated.
That's it is perpetrated by the oil industry.
Says oil is the second most abundant liquid in the world,
and oils everywhere.
We'll never run out of it.
But if,
if the people knew that then they wouldn't pay the prices.
They have to keep to keep the prices high.
They have to give it.
This is what this dude said.
He might be right.
But there's something,
there was a really interesting book that I read that I'm thinking about this
today because today I was thrown some,
I was given some books away actually to goodwill and we're putting them in boxes
of books that I've read that I'm not going to read again.
And one of them was black gold stranglehold and there's a really controversial
book that I read.
I don't remember who wrote it.
Jamie,
see if you could pull that up,
but it was by a guy who was saying that oil is actually a natural process and
it's a natural process of the earth and that the idea that it was created by
fossils or,
and then later the theory was that plants,
plants like rotting would create this oil.
He said it's a natural process of the earth itself and it's constantly renewing.
It does kind of make sense,
right?
That's an l but you're proud of that.
He also said this to,
he said the reason we think it's a fossil fuel is because there John d
Rockefeller in 1890 2 cent a PA,
a group of paid off scientists to this big scientific community,
a committee on our organic matter in Geneva in 1892 he sent these scientists
just so that they can put in that petroleum is organic and it contains hydrogen,
oxygen and carbon,
so he knew that if they pass that,
then if it's,
if they could,
if he can say the petroleum is organic matter,
then people will believe that it's going to run out.
But it was all a complete hoax.
That's what El Fletcher Prouty.
You can get that book.
Here's dollars cheaper,
shared
oil,
trillions of gallons of oils.
A burst it up all over the world,
but you won't see it in American media because they,
they want everyone to think that it's not abundance.
It's so cheap.
We have so much oil in Alaska and all over the United States that it's cheaper
just to get it from the Middle East.
It's so much cheaper,
just like a cheaper to make products and China then to make it here.
We can make it here,
but it's way cheaper to just fucking make it a child on a second.
Do you know that most of the oil that we get is actually from fracking now and
then Millie says not where we get most of our or
changing now that that's part of his issue changing.
It's a big issue with fracking,
but according to this dude,
if you'd look at,
see that's the problem.
It's if it's one guy,
five minutes,
he talks about it,
but there's no way we're watching that.
I'll fucking,
my head will explode.
Finding out now he might be right [inaudible] going on.
It's possible you don't want to hear that possible.
But if the case wouldn't you think,
here's the thing,
it's entirely possible that the myth of the earth creating oil through dead
things and it being a limited resource is possible.
And the reason why we know it's possible,
it's because whenever there's money to be made by manipulating the facts,
there's a bunch of people that are willing to do that.
And what we know about the most recent history is that the sugar industry paid
scientists untold amounts of money to lie and say that saturated fats were the
cause of heart disease and that take the blame off of sugar.
And this is a really,
this is a really recent study,
are recent rather a revelation.
I'm we're talking within the last couple of weeks documentary's called
sugarcoated.
Write that shit down.
Sugarcoat it on Netflix.
You'll see the scientists from Harvard,
Yale.
So when you find this out thanking the tobacco d the same thing when you hear
about tobacco science.
Tobacco science has paid off science,
Harvard,
Yale,
because they know people bullied.
Cause most people walk around and they'd go,
Oh man,
I'm into science bro.
I'm into science.
They know that.
They're like,
okay,
you're in the science.
We're going to pay.
They know they're going to pay off the scientist so we could fool these gullible
motherfuckers.
That's what's going on.
Everyone's getting goalable.
Hold on a second.
Let's see what's getting fooled left.
There's bright,
I can't see it as a camera in the way here.
Can you scroll up?
Please?
Says oil prices were about 60% lower than they were two years ago.
Yet BP reports us oil reserves are now at an all time high up to 55 billion
barrels,
nearly double what we had 20 years ago.
This search demonstrates how even our best experts are limited in their ability
to appreciate just how much oil we have and can produce.
So it's entirely possible that they were hoodwinked early on,
but it's also entirely possible that they pretended they knew how the fuck oil
was created in a way that it would benefit them.
I did say,
Whoa,
we have a limited supply.
So therefore we got to jet remembering this in the 1970s man,
when they fucked up our cars,
we had the dopest fucking muscle cars in the world,
like the American muscle cars,
the 1960s with a shit.
But then when Jimmy Carter got an office,
they sense weakness.
That was one of the fuckers Jack,
the oil rates up through the roof.
And because of that,
we got mustangs that looked like dog shit.
Completely Golf.
Of course power such proudly,
proudly.
He said that was all part of the game.
Make it seem like there's a shortage caused chaos in the United States.
It was all part of the program.
That's how they get the prices of all a barrels show goddamn high.
If people knew that oil was lever going to run out,
this is what l Fletcher Prouty said.
If this one dude though,
let's Fletcher Prouty debunk Google him.
Yeah,
just Google that bunch.
I mean,
you never know.
Okay.
But you don't say,
maybe you'd want to know whether he's right or whether he's crazy.
Right.
So it's good to find something [inaudible] Kennedy assassinated.
You know you,
you might be right.
You must be roles.
No,
you might be right or they might be legitimate scientists that are proposing a
guy.
Exactly know what he's talking about.
That's impossible.
That's entirely possible too.
You never in this one guy,
there's plenty of guys,
but you keep bringing up this one guy.
I'll go on,
hold on,
hold on.
Hold on.
Youtube.
The oil deception.
It's a five but let's hold off.
We go down to see,
just see if you find anything about his credentials or that snips posted is 12
years old and it's just a message board that you can't really count,
so we'll just find something.
See if you could find something to him.
It's two minutes
to just not be interested in listening to this guy.
I do,
but not right now.
I'm good boy telling me.
No.
You're doubting is it.
Say No,
I'm not doubting you.
I'm doubting the people that are telling the truth or a bunch of tall tales do
it and you figure it out for the Kennedy assassination expert said,
is this,
hold on,
Lee Harvey Oswald killed.
Jack can.
Hold on.
He's fucking with you man.
How am I shocked of Jamie?
Jamie,
please.
That was the website.
A college website,
trying to figure it out.
Dot Edu what is it?
I can't tell.
What do you mean you can't tell?
What is the URL?
Missouri University.
Oh,
okay.
Minnesota.
On that Short,
so it could be a student created website.
Is that what you're saying?
Entirely possible.
This is the thing,
man.
Talk.
Listen to him talk.
Don't read Shit.
Just listen to it.
Just
says he has one of the favorite people of conspiracy oriented publications.
Come on.
Come on sites.
Do you book?
Are you,
what do you get your news from?
Camera one is this everything you hope.
Tell her this.
Her name,
the station where you come up.
Oil Book is $2 where do you get your
New York Times?
CNN,
MSNBC.
Oh my God.
That's all the bullshit.
You get your invitation from you to
you get your news from CNN,
CNN,
I listed a bunch of channels do cause you do what?
Do whatever you do.
Don't go to the news show for news.
Where do you get your news?
Where do you get,
you know,
never say CNN.
I get my news.
This is what I tried to do.
It gets it from a name.
God,
please relax.
Please rely on to say,
hey,
please stop.
Does anybody drudge report read it sometimes,
but hey,
that's good news right there.
Good.
Sometimes here's the thing,
good.
This is what I like to do when I go to the news.
I like to go,
I read some time ago,
Huh?
And then I go,
all right,
who else has this?
And then I go online.
I Google it.
I go,
Huh?
I read a bunch of different written,
this is all from being wrong.
This is all from getting committed to an idea and then finding out it's not
true.
So then I go to a bunch of different ones and then want to go to a bunch of
different ones.
I tried to figure out what the fuck is really going on outside where you look
and you go,
nope,
there's no credible,
credible CNN both.
Hold on a second.
CNN has been wrong.
They've been wrong about Bengazi.
I'm not saying that they were wrong about information that Hillary Clinton had
for
sure they're wrong about information the government had.
They have a limited amount of access to the actual facts of very complicated
issues like all journalists,
all journalists dealing with top secret issues have a limited amount of facts.
So you have to figure out who's biased.
Do you know Fox News is biased towards the right?
Absolutely.
Is Msnbc bias towards the left?
Where's salon.com fit in far left?
Where's drudge.com far right?
Who's right?
Well,
here's the thing.
Don't fucking have an opinion until you look at all of it because there's a lot
of bullshit and shenanigans going on,
on both sides,
and sometimes it takes a while to figure out what the fuck is right and what's
wrong.
The problem is confirmation bias is a real thing.
I've had it.
You've had it.
We've all had it.
We've all wanted Dan Henderson to win.
We all,
you know,
[inaudible] sometimes when you see a fight like that,
and I've been guilty of the same thing myself.
You see a fight like that and you say,
no,
you want bro.
And then people get mad at me and they'll say mean things to me on Twitter
because he threw a fucking pious bro.
Fuck a Dominick.
Cruz lost that fight bro.
You know,
fucking Conor McGregor was running bro.
it's,
it's going to happen.
It's inevitable.
But our boy Eddie,
hmm,
he loves him.
Something spiritually and I pulled up is from John c Mcadams,
who also wrote a book on the JFK assassination called JFK Sass and logic,
how to think about claims of conspiracy.
He described himself as a debunker by temperament.
And then,
so I found the page where he breaks down this Fletcher Guy and he's not talking
about the specific oil thing,
but he does take us a topic or a version of a story.
Proudy has,
how'd he comes back in?
You'd say,
not a word of this cause I don't want to get back fucked up Gremlin,
but they call him proudly isms.
I mean this is what he's known for,
the sweet he's made his career on.
It sounds like these conspiracy theories.
I mean,
look,
he might be guy like Jim Marrs is another book I gave to goodwill today.
Jim Morris had this alien agenda Book and Jim Mars is also a guy who's a very
famous Kenneth Dat is an annoying sound that you hear that shit.
Everybody who's touched that America hears that shit.
America,
Cameron Hanes because he runs,
he's fucking ultra marathons.
S E every 15 minutes I've been following this guy.
We've been hanging out elk hunting for the past week.
So I've been trying to follow him up mountains.
This is what it's like.
It's like him running up the mountain,
me running 60% off the mountain and going,
I have to take a deep breath.
I take my hat off,
I have to fan myself enough to follow him up the fucking mountain again.
Can Get Eddie another corona so we can go deep and black helicopter.
And I didn't mention this before,
but when you take your hat off,
yes,
that's like a shining thing.
I understood,
but I knew that they weren't looking at me right then and there.
I had a fucking throw some hair on my head,
dude.
Dude,
wear makeup.
Like if you have a mirror
back,
you open it up.
You put a little makeup all over your face and shit.
You were cammo everywhere.
Hey,
let me ask you this.
You do all this running.
What shoes do you do it in?
These right here.
I ran 200 miles in these shoes.
Under Armour's.
Yeah,
well I'm going to get me something else and they say keep hammering.
Matt's got his own shoes.
No shoes.
What?
Yeah,
he does.
I can get them online.
Yo Dude,
if you want,
if you want to run for fucking three gases,
do you want to run for three days?
She get your own shoes.
He'd be good at sub only.
No time limit.
Dude,
this motherfucker doesn't get tired.
I'm telling you,
I'm not in the best shape.
I mean,
I'm not the most endurance oriented guy,
but I'm in pretty good shape right now and I follow him up.
He's fucking mountains.
It's brutal.
There's something about like hiking up mountains.
You were,
we were talking about it before the show.
It's fucking way harder to do than you think it is.
Everybody thinks that manly shit is like hitting tires with a sledge hammer or
fucking doing kettle bells and doing fucking French presses like an animal,
bro.
Did 28 Chin ups fall this cock sucker up a map and then you'd see as you're
going up the smell,
because like I talked about another big bear.
We climbed up,
barely meet and talk about it online and you didn't know we was before the
shells.
I tell everybody because you're,
you're doing camp with Tony Ferguson.
Tony Ferguson's finding Rafael dos Anjos,
New Mexico,
Mexico City.
November freight fight.
He's up in big bear.
He got a cabin.
He's fucking gangster.
When we talk about savage,
everyone says,
oh,
he's a savage.
He's a sabbath.
He told me Ferguson is a guy,
damn savage,
tomorrow let's build you a house.
He'll fucking hunt for you.
He's the way he's in the cage is the way he is in his life.
That guy is fear fucking lists.
His worth ethic ethic is on.
Dude,
he's doing Jujitsu and striking at four in the fucking morning.
Dude in big bear.
We're going fucking nuts up there.
So we cleaned him up,
bear mountain.
We climb up bare fucking still,
dude.
It was the highest.
That was our highest snowboarding point.
And there's all these loose rocks and you're thinking the whole time I told,
I told him,
I go,
I'm here to teach you Jujitsu.
I'm not here to run a fucking marathon,
man.
He goes,
come up to the match.
I go,
Nah,
I'm going to do some emails at the cabin.
We got a lot of hatchet man.
And I'm like,
I don't want to be a pussy.
I don't want him like I gotta.
I gotta look like,
like,
uh,
at least have a medium sized balls.
You know what I mean?
So I'm like,
okay,
fuck it.
I'm had vans on I a vans on and we climbed his fucking,
and it's,
we're not supposed to.
I don't think we're supposed to go to bear mountain.
We just parked and just climbed up that motherfucker.
You supposed to,
I don't know if people aren't allowed to Kike as snowboarding resort,
you know what I mean?
I'm not sure is no snowboarding.
I think you'd probably get away with it might be private land though.
Right?
So the biggest misconception for those climbers is when you're climbing up and
you're like,
oh my God,
I don't know if I'm going to make this shit.
These mounts are pussy compared to your shit.
But for me as a civilian,
this was the fucking track man.
It was like eight of us.
How long did it take?
It was like we're climbing Mount Everest.
It took us to,
uh,
to me it was Mount Everest and I'm thinking the whole time,
at least when we get up going down,
it's going to be easy.
That's the biggest misconception going down.
Works a whole different part of your legs.
Holy Shit.
Going down is not easy.
It's,
it's just as hard in a whole different way.
How long did it take?
We all Goddamn day we were up there.
That's a warm up and there.
There's bees everywhere.
All God.
When the sun,
when we,
we got to the bottom of the mountain right when the sun went down and man,
but just one day,
just,
you know what again,
to you,
that's some,
we did some,
we did a white belt workshop in Cancun and it was,
I know that slow and listen,
don't get me wrong,
I was in the boy scouts for two fucking years growing up.
So if it wasn't for that training,
there's
6,000
seriously,
two years of boy scouts.
But the way I did,
I put a list out,
some bullshit boy scouts out and goes to 60 hours a week.
You know what?
Hold on a second.
Hey is not a this big beer lake.
We want it.
That's a big bear lake.
Go there and top party.
You go to the top of big bear mountain.
Oh,
you know what have you say on Instagram?
I did a minute video of the whole for one minute.
There's all these scenes of 8,000 right there.
8,008 oh five yeah,
that's down,
down all the way to the bottom.
Right there.
There we go.
Tony is a fucking savvy thousand five that's a good time.
Don't live in that Tony.
Tony is
not a normal human being and dude,
that guy is a beast.
If he was up like an an Apache tribe,
he would be the leader of the God damn tribe trusts me,
Tony.
Tony,
is this the fucking man?
What do you way,
uh,
when I did the race has one 65,
what do you weigh now?
75.
He was one and he did a hundred miles and then he realized it was too much
weight.
So he starved as body and truck it down.
That's how I like,
you have to have ice shoes and a pick and you have to follow a bunch of Sherpas.
Yeah,
I had a different animal.
The rock gave him props.
The Rop.
Brock put up a post about him the other day and we were out in hunting camp and
he's like,
Holy Shit,
the fucking rock posted something for me.
And yes,
because he wore,
he wore blood,
sweat.
And respect.
The Rock has something like fit,
what is it?
50 something.
60 60 million million to 8 million
has more than Hickory.
Holy Shit.
Go first one.
What is that guy's tee shirt on the first one?
Spark race,
dude.
Th 2.8 million views.
Look at that 2.8 million.
His fucking videos.
So the Cameron Hanes one I think had something like 300 how many thousand likes
for 420,000 likes.
Oh,
powerful for 24 minutes.
What if Instagram goes down like my space,
all those followers,
all that business.
What happened could happen.
That's the same thing that people are saying about Twitter is that Twitter is
starting to drop off.
But Instagram started to pick up
an apple thing because they can cause they add to kind of chat.
Apparently haven't jumped on that.
Snapchat got off for like 16 benefit of that over regular Instagram.
Explain it.
It's just a story.
So you can post this story.
Yeah.
It's like,
you know,
it's real quick so it doesn't last forever.
So he could post 20 insta pictures.
I'm doing an Insta story of you guys talking about [inaudible] so it's just like
quick,
I haven't felt the need to do that for some reason.
I don't know why.
Cause if you're gonna post something like whatever,
something's kind of silly or not that not a great picture,
which wasn't a story.
You
post pictures and I just put one up.
I just put a part of the inside story up that like that couldn't be a video post
postop.
There needs to be an APP,
a dick pic APP.
Hold on,
hold on.
Hold that thought.
What?
There needs to be someone that can do some of you guys out in Silicon Valley,
make a dick pic APP.
You could take a dick pic and then put like something like make it make your
Dick look bigger.
Too verbose.
It's too embarrassing when it's small.
Is that what it said?
Oh what is this?
Damn,
they got sunglasses now.
Holy.
And what's the benefit of smash and try that again because for some reason it
just didn't work.
Something you Asian guys out there and find.
Okay,
well that's racist.
You guys need to make a dick pic APP.
They can.
They're mainly white.
All
right.
Hold that thought.
What
it's saying,
Asian bad.
No.
Well,
there's a lot of Asians.
Asians are the smartest people in the world.
They're the ones programming everything.
That's why I say you agents out there in San Jose.
Okay.
You know what?
How was that?
Black guys have big dicks.
I was Mexican.
I wish that was a Mexican stereotype that,
oh,
we've got me so happy.
So explosive.
Mexicans are fast.
I wish Mexicans,
if it was a Mexican third type that we had gigantic Dick's dude,
I would not be hating on that shit.
That's a good,
that's a good snack.
The rear fast and John.
No,
you can't say we have big dicks.
That's racist.
Why is this not working?
Come on,
man.
You can't.
You have a crazy strict diet.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it did.
I just say,
wait it out.
You know what?
I'm trying to lose weight.
I'm trying to burn a thousand calories less a day at the same time.
God dammit fucking hit me in the marathon.
God,
you're replaying a snap story for the fifth time
because it's racist.
It's canceling itself.
I said,
hey,
hold on one,
one second.
Why can't a white guy come up with it?
Like I can't put Facebook and snapchat guys,
just executive produce shit.
Mark Zuckerberg,
man,
when I say Asia,
I had plenty of Asian
people thought I was Asian.
People thought I was Filipino growing up.
When I say Asian,
I'm saying that they're the smartest motherfuckers out there.
You can't deny that,
but you're also saying something else.
Think about it.
Samsung,
apple,
Steve Jobs
and Tim Cook,
Apple Gunner Jogger.
The Asians smarter than Asians.
Come on.
Who's making this about new song?
You're talking about apple phones and the fucking updates because it comes out
at fucking up left and right.
That's a new one.
Just that doesn't work.
Sometimes
Asians are the smartest people out there and you fucking know it.
Wait a minute.
I don't know what I don't know.
Responding to shootings are this.
When I was growing up and what
a plus average in math and everything,
patients were always the smartest in my community.
We didn't give a shit.
We were like,
okay,
Asians are the smartest.
What's theirs?
Why is that bad?
How is that racist?
Wish they said that about Mexicans,
that we were the smartest.
I apologize.
Some of them.
Ice Cube,
cube son.
Why did you send this to me?
Oh,
you got this man.
She got it with your bare hands.
And
do you feel like in order to cause real or is that bullshit?
What about polar bear?
You want to ask me a question?
Ask me.
Hold on.
Okay.
Oh,
global warming.
I think,
hey listen,
here's the,
here's what I would like you to do.
I'd like you to talk about things with no emotion or theatrical trek.
Mock things.
Don't go.
Don't go crazy.
I know I do.
I'm 100% Katen rip that off from you.
You're right.
You're 100% right.
But what I would like you to do,
I would like you to attack these things with just lodge
the third questions,
and we did.
You know we talk about some
shit that we don't talk on their global warming.
I'm talking about,
it's the exact same shit with every genre,
with everything.
It's the same shit.
It's the exact same thing in every aspect of the elite.
Whoever's running shit,
that's just a little glimpse into reality and we're not going to get into
glacier.
That's the same shit.
You don't want to be honey Dick,
Brenden.
Don't be.
That's,
that's a first honey date reference.
New t shirt.
I don't know if you haven't used in a while.
Tech is Eddie Bravo pointing at you go off and you're willing to go in on that
teacher.
What was the tissue you point and it says,
don't be honey dick.
And he starts telling the tee shirt
and go,
you wait.
That's just Instagram.
Instagram.
Fucking trolls.
No,
but don't be honey dick.
Do you pointing at him saying,
don't like that.
Look at the camera.
I already went through some deep shit.
How deep is the shit we went through?
Listen,
go camera.
Same me links,
pictures,
shit.
Everywhere you go.
It's the same people pointed that everything though,
Eddie,
everything,
everything treasured people pointed that camera lizard people point that camera
and say,
don't be honey.
Dicked don't be hunting
which one she pointed at Jamie.
That one,
the second one.
Second one pointed that way.
There you go.
T shirt.
I love it.
We got it.
That's our,
that's our second tee shirt of the day.
The first one is,
what was it?
I don't remember.
We had a t shirt.
Oh,
dead body.
Fuck party.
That's it.
Wait two and 10 Hillary Clinton.
I'll tell you exactly why because can put up some post about a hunting posts and
some dude wrote,
idiot,
I hope you die soon.
Then we all have a party.
Fucking your dead body.
So,
oh yeah.
Yeah,
so I put that up online.
There it is.
So I put that up online and I put Hashtag dead body,
fuck.
Here's what's crazy.
There was already two previous posts with Hashtag dead body on Trump.
No,
just some dude in 2014 he was like in a band.
You know what the mafia,
the fanny pack mafia,
someone said that and I thought that was a brilliant man,
but apparently that's huge.
And of pack Mafia.
You haven't heard that fanny pack enthusiastic,
obviously movement.
This recent one.
Someone recently put a dead but Hashtag dead body fuck party.
He said just having fun.
Macrophilia yeah,
I saw he saw your show a couple of feet today and then he wrote compassion
Hashtag dead party.
If someone fucking a dead body,
you would know that.
Oh God,
yeah
hands.
It's kind of a dead dude.
Get to watch anything crazy.
When you were in 1985 walking that this fucking,
this a VHS tape
and there was three volumes have to go through that curtain at the video store
to get it.
I mean,
brilliant.
Go to call Brandon.
Don't call him Brad.
You know what I call everybody?
That's Brendan.
I called Brian.
Everybody.
It's not just you because of Brandon Lee.
I,
you know what exactly the respect to the dragon's kid friendly and done shit in
forever is dead.
He's,
I know what these folks did to keep referring to two words for you.
The CHRO
just shut the fuck up.
You Know Joey Diaz will tell you he got killed by the fucking triad.
Tell you what happened.
Cock sucker.
Listen to me.
When Bruce Lee left a tryin to go and do the game of death,
they put the fucking fix it
talk.
They fuck those Chinese,
they fall in that shit to the end and he's have integrity.
How convincing me,
how are you not on that conspiracy theory where Brandon Lee was?
Cause they shut it was onset.
No I'm not.
He is.
These are so good show.
You don't open a store.
How do you know?
Oh you believe that conspiracy theory?
I sure as fuck.
Oh No,
I'm saying I don't think he died on,
I don't think,
I think it was an accident.
Oh you think it was an accident and you think you know what?
Uh,
I haven't tower seven.
What are you doing?
I'm sure Brandon Lee was just like tower seven.
He was the Chinese half Chinese tower.
Seven week frame it as what you're saying,
what he's saying.
Weak frame.
Do you know the one thing,
the one thing that over the last year I used to think that when people would say
like seed links and videos and stuff about celebrities being,
you get loose celebrities being part of the establishment.
And the agenda 21 like celebrities,
you know,
part of it.
Uh,
but over the last year,
man,
shit,
it seems.
Um,
what do you think about Robert De Niro making that video about Trump?
I don't give him,
I think he was irresponsible because it,
he should've said vote for the Libertarian Guy.
And he was like trying to sway people to Hillary.
I think Hillary's clear.
He should've made why?
He's talking shit on Trump.
Talk Shit on the Hillary to the fuck you doing.
You're going to push everybody to Hillary.
That's,
that's dangerous.
I'm talking about Robert De Niro.
He's talking mad shit.
No one's ever fucking done that before.
Get all right.
He thinks he's a bad motherfucker.
He thinks he's the dude from raging bull.
Put you in the face.
How do you know Donald Trump is taking privates with John Danaher?
How do you know?
Oh,
I'm going to put you in the face.
The guy's 89 years old.
You should make it clear.
Make it clear ourselves.
A cock fight.
Jon Voight and Robert Deniro going at each other.
Fuck Yam.
So Shane Cleo,
actor,
Bobby Deniros rant against Donald Trump.
What foul words he used against a presidential nominee.
Of course he says Trump's words to not hurt anyone.
I disagree.
I don't think up to nails hurt.
Anyway.
Donald Trump is a con artist and all that Shit,
but Hillary is a proven criminal,
so don't you make it clear?
You make it clear like,
yeah,
Fuck Donald Trump.
I'm all good with that.
I understand that.
Fuck yeah,
make sure you say fuck Hillary too.
Here's my question.
This is a legitimate question.
Is it possible that until the internet came around and we were able to see like
all the different influences on political processes,
special interest groups,
lobbyists,
all that kind of stuff,
all these different things that we didn't know whether or not we're real,
we all get to see it sort of consolidated.
Right?
Is it possible that these people that are here,
these longterm people,
you don't have to name them because anybody that's deeply entrenched in the
system for 2030 years,
they were used to operating back in like the fucking Reagan days,
man.
I mean,
they were around.
They were,
they were getting into the mix back when they were kids.
Jimmy Carter was president.
Ford was president.
You know,
when they were in college,
they went to the Vietnam War.
Like,
here's that.
You're dealing with all of them.
So when she went from Donald,
look,
you could look all down the list of all the different people that have been
involved in American politics over the last few years.
And most of them got their start a long time ago.
They get deeply entrenched in the system,
and it's,
it's entirely possible that this system is so fucking weird.
And there's so many loopholes as to what's legal and what's not legal.
It's not about doing what's right or doing what's good for the American people
is amount is,
it's,
you're competing with all these other people that are doing the same thing.
Probably the biggest problem going on,
in my opinion.
And I'm a fucking idiot.
All right,
how many idiot?
But the biggest problem in my fucking opinion,
show easily to honey Dick,
the masses,
the masses have all the power.
We see it in the weed movement.
Weed's being legalized in the feds don't want that shit,
but the people are waking up to at least weed,
but they won't wake up to all the rest of the shit.
That's the fucking problem.
The people that are gullible and they just buy all this shit.
That's the problem.
Right?
Then wake the fuck up.
Jesus.
God Damn problem over president.
That's the fucking problem.
Hey,
my question is,
you started that off with,
you had a question.
What was the question?
Hey.
Oh my question Jamie Brown.
Everybody's talking about the reason why we have Donald Trump,
can we assume that video is done is because
everyone believes all the shit they see on TV.
This is a result of all the skeptic score.
There's no fucking proof that they're corrupt.
There's no fucking proof.
You know what I mean?
It's those mother fuckers in a trance paid or in a trance or Zappos mother
fuckers.
That's why were we got Hillary and Trump.
That's why you mother fuckers cause the you.
That's it.
I'm done.
So I'll take a breath.
Think about what just happened.
We never saw the,
you guys haven't seen it.
I don't even want
to fuck up.
Whoever owns it for sure will get pulled off.
Can we talk about gangs?
Will Watch it off the air,
but whenever anything happens,
it's like a news story.
It's like one of the ways that video's getting pulled off of things.
Hey,
all your,
all your instastories are up powerful damn door.
Instantly.
The five or six when you were saying you had a problem there,
they weren't,
they weren't posting for some reason.
Some of them weren't.
Sounds like they all got posted.
All of them.
Even with complaining about their,
I'll call them up.
Oh,
I definitely do.
At least 10.
Oh,
okay.
I was like,
conspiracy.
My phone's not working as good.
The fucking new phones out.
Okay.
Did you,
uh,
it's all but see,
even though it's like insta stories,
salt,
like we did it on the podcast.
How do we know that's not fake?
Um,
oh shit.
It's all thick.
This could have been fake.
You guys get a Photoshop that out for all I know.
It's like wheat,
wheat as an example of the power of the people and shows the UFC.
That was the power of the motherfucking people underground,
keeping it alive on direct TV.
All those guys.
That was the,
that was,
that's an example that we do have the fucking power,
but we can't use it.
I'm going to tell you wake the fuck up then we could use it.
We can't use it until you wake up.
We did it with the weed and we did it with the UFC and then we got,
it's just,
I know you guys meet proof,
but it's the reality.
The Pentagon just got busted spending half a billion dollars on fake Taliban al
Qaeda videos.
Oh,
what the fuck does that mean to you?
You're going to ignore that shit.
That means you can't,
you know,
it was,
it's all been a fucking reality show and everything's cool.
Everyone's going to sit there and everything.
Everybody's cool.
Oh,
whatever.
We're just going to keep going.
I don't think they're making fake videos.
$500 million sake videos making like it's seed.
Make It.
They gotta.
They gotta have the Arabic writing and make it look like Arabic,
Middle East CNN.
Oh Shit.
And I know you guys don't you need to,
I,
it's so outrageous that I understand that solar ray just said like,
you need absolute proof that you saw it on Russia today.
Today.
It's real.
It's actually real.
But I know you guys need to put,
because it's so crazy.
It's so insane.
Of course it's so insane.
But what the fuck of it?
If it's real,
what the fuck does that mean?
It means everything we see on TV is all programmed,
not like just some of it.
I trust them here and I trust them.
These are strains,
corruption,
straight brainwash,
mine control.
So don't tell him.
Tell me where you are getting your news from before you start talking.
Are you saying what do you,
what are you getting your fund?
Isn't it possible that even the news people are being deceived?
They're being,
they're being told what to do and what to say.
They're not involved.
So who's
the guy you see talking nick?
I don't have enough power.
I was talking about them because there's looking at the way it,
that's a good question.
There's also getting people behind the scene.
Great Court.
It's the same shit that we've gone through already,
but everywhere else,
everywhere else is just as corrupt.
So listen,
everyone's just sitting around and hope and everything's going to be fucking
fine.
But guess what?
We got Hillary and we've got Trump as candidates.
It's because motherfuckers just want to ignore it.
That's what it's about.
Fuckers night.
None of,
I don't give a fuck.
And I'd rather have Trump than Hillary.
I know Trump's full of shit.
If you vote right now,
you know what have I vote right now?
It would be a anybody,
but damn,
I would vote for that libertarian guy.
I don't know shit about him because he's not on TV.
He's not on TV.
He gets no new ship.
He had a moment on TV both for that motherfucker.
Goddamn of both for that dude.
But that dude might be fucking pot and sold that libertarian can move.
We,
it could just be controlled opposition.
That's just basic,
uh,
domination.
One-On-One control your opposition.
You don't think the people at the top are doing that kind of control,
that position,
the Independent.
This is another website.
Hey,
what does that mean?
If it's true,
if it is true,
what does that mean?
All your skeptics independently.
Shit.
That's what that means.
Each shit.
Then
all the guys that,
oh no,
we're in there because we're trying to fucking create freedom.
You motherfuckers.
That's why we're in there.
You're trying to create freedom in the Middle East.
It's a fucking scam.
500 fucking million dollars fake ass terrorist video.
Hey,
fake ass terrorist video out there.
What the fuck does that mean?
What does that mean?
It doesn't mean shit.
We're going to just try and going on how much we drank.
I want to sip.
It doesn't mean shit.
That doesn't mean shit.
They make you guys are one shit.
Listen,
if someone's spent that kind of money,
we could ban God.
Damn.
If there was a way,
I don't want to be part of it.
Do you think you want to die?
I don't want to be part of it and I'm going to shut the focus.
I'm going to shut the door,
but God damn it,
I wasn't a part of the weed movement.
I was just kind of just like off to the side talking shit.
But I don't want to be like the dude like those dudes in the fucking,
uh,
a normal move man and the guys that got all political within the actually win
and to these meetings and just the last chain.
I ain't doing that.
I'm going to know you don't care to Congress meeting.
I took all the shit.
But you don't want to do the work.
I don't,
I just want to have a way to go but let them do it.
I'm too fucking scared.
I'm too lazy.
I don't want to do it.
I can't get away.
You're doing something.
No,
I think in a way anybody talks about us doing something.
Yeah,
because it would change our man.
We could do this.
You just got to wake the fuck up.
People are changing public opinion,
which is what changes like public opinion sort of changes first and then policy
changes.
It just depends on your platform,
but it's also just getting the word out in the view.
Like look at Colin Kaepernick with his,
his Stan about it.
Whether you agree with it or not.
It's brought attention to the situation.
Like we all know it now.
Exactly.
All these little things in a lot of ways they add up.
You know every,
every little thing that happens.
It makes people talk about it.
It adds up.
We got a band together man.
Cause when you band together,
no one can be singled out.
We could take it all back.
We could do anything we fucking want to do.
We made,
we'd legal,
we made,
we'd legal.
That's fucking nuts.
And you know what?
The feds still scheduled one to know.
They fucking fine.
Still scheduled one.
But the people made that shit legal that the people have the fucking power man.
They do.
But they get,
that's the reason why they're making these fake videos.
Why do you think they're making these fake terrorist?
Because,
because they know what the bottom line,
bottom line,
the people have the power.
So we got to make them,
we got to scare them because they have to go cam,
just trying to run.
What is,
um,
what do you like,
what do you think their objective is to get us more scared?
Money.
Is that the button about,
hey,
listen,
when you go into wardrobe,
you know what I do?
I listened to guys that used to be in the CIA.
John Stockwell look him up.
You listen to what they say,
the whistle blows.
There's plenty of them.
The John Stockwell man,
he came out and he just told you exactly the way a fucking was and you know
what?
People at the very top,
there's a lot of great CIA agents,
like all the guys coming up,
they want to stop communism.
It's just a few key guys are corrupt.
Just like in every organization.
Just like in every agency,
just like in every government,
just everywhere.
There's corruption and it isn't just here.
Every,
every goddamn government is the goal to create fear.
The,
that's part of it.
That's part of it of course,
because fears control.
Yes.
That's part of control.
A lot of control.
Food Control,
energy control,
a lot of control,
water control,
control,
all that shit.
Agenda 21 look into agenda 21 it's that a conspiracy theory.
Agenda 21 is what we need to do to take this world.
The world leaders got together and this is like UN shit CFR shit.
They all got together.
Fuck countries and borders,
all the guys with all the money.
So what are we going to do it?
It'd be best if we just fucking control the shit and make it a one world
government and we control everything.
That's what we're in the middle of.
It's increments and people like just like they don't notice it's happening in
increments.
We can stop this shit.
We could stop this shit man.
We could turn this shit around.
We don't have to fucking just,
just sit there and watch it fucking happen.
Talk to watch it happen.
We can stop it.
I think what we talked about earlier that lard culture is kind of like a
battleship and a lot of words and then it's hard or
to make these big giant turns.
It doesn't,
it doesn't turn like a,
like a car getting educated and getting in line.
It takes a long time to like,
everybody has to realize,
oh yeah,
we got to move this way.
Oh this is ridiculous.
I think this is what we're seeing in this election.
It's like one of the last one of these elections where we really interest
completely in a two party system.
I think we're like realizing it's ridiculous.
Especially when you watched the debates.
I've never been so into a presidential race.
I'm in watching like how ridiculous or these debate,
how stupid is that?
I used to shut the whole country
cliche,
polit politicians like,
oh,
I'm going to bring back people cause I care about you and we're going to get
jobs and we're going to have everybody working and women are going to have
rights and we're going to do this and look it up.
Bring it back.
Cheesy,
cheesy right there.
Fuck
you guys realize what's going on.
That's what's going on.
Either you're going to fuck.
Yeah.
Oh,
you're like this.
What the fuck?
This is some bull shit.
I do shit.
Jesus Christ.
And Trump with Hilary.
I wanted Trump to sound good.
Really?
I really,
me too badly.
100% good.
And I had ended up turning the channel cause I'm like,
I was afraid of what?
He was angry.
You know what?
If it's between Trump and Trump,
Trump Trump's full of shit too,
but damn,
I know Hillary is just in the fucking program.
They are the establishment.
Everybody wants Hillary because they know Hillary's president.
Ooh.
Everything goes full sail and demand and fucking business as mother fucking
usually if we get Hillary in there,
no kinks,
it's the same shit.
We been doing 35 gas,
I'm going to go.
But if you've got Trump,
it sounds like he's going to fuck shit up and then he's a man who knows people
are sick of
that.
Could easily be a distraction,
might be in on it.
They're talking about on it.
Luck.
We're dealing with fucking like some Gotham city corruption type mindset and
Trump's base,
he could easily,
he might be part of it.
We need someone.
We need someone that everyone's going to hate.
You.
Just imagine what that imagine and you're partying together,
hanging out.
I don't fucking trust shit cause of the plot of dark side.
That's pain.
Pain,
that movie.
Come on man.
It's good.
It's some fucked up shit because people who want to be Batman and Robin,
you know why?
Because the people that are watching tower seven collapse a free fall speed and
believe the corrupt desk government government is the one that told you this is
fires brought it down.
The corrupt ask government office fires brought it down.
Say
Hey Eddie.
Yeah,
Eddie.
I see a comment.
It says come on and waiting for Eddie to explode.
Oh my God,
that
is causing that.
That is the problem.
Whatever is causing that.
What?
Whether it,
I don't know.
Whatever's causing a man,
a grown ass man to watch a skyscraper collapse at free fall speed,
like the weight controlled demolitions do and have the corrupt das government
tell you that it was office fires,
all his shit you see on on a pop popular mechanics and the discovery channel,
how window.
That's all from the government motherfucker.
Opiate Goddamn eyes.
Dude,
you're being honey dick.
the guy's Dick,
believe Kim down normal office fires when that's the problem.
That's the problem.
If there wasn't that problem,
if we can easily,
we have all the evidence in the goddamn world.
Open your handles five angles of a 47 storey,
skyscraper collapsing at free fall speed.
Okay?
Government didn't say shit for eight years.
Now they didn't even put it in the nine 11 commission report.
They didn't say shit from finally from public pressure.
They go,
what the fuck happened at tower seven that was the camp do you think happened at
tower?
So they said,
guess what?
10 years ago it got hot.
He doesn't even know.
He's says,
most people don't even know I get a great job.
Make It.
If you don't put it on mainstream media,
some people are going to find out,
but they know not everyone's going to find out and you know what?
All the people you take all of them,
they had a five day.
There's going to be more people that don't fucking know.
You know?
Most people do not know.
Three towers collapse talked about this too
much.
Man,
we talk about this too much.
Well,
he's trying to start a revolution.
When we talk about this like so many times,
you don't know what's going on.
What happened here?
How was fun?
We went downtown conspiracy alley and it's just fucking crushed by our seven as
an expressway.
GNOSIS really fucked up my high bro.
Give me a bad spot.
Anxiety.
You know what?
We can go right back to a,
we can go back to,
um,
no man,
we're just talking dude.
I mean,
we're just having you get goes super Pancrase.
He gets super passionate.
You might want to look up that pancreas.
Alan goes,
frank shamrock.
Don't ever forget about that fight.
I'd rather look at Patricia,
grab a rope,
and they got to reset.
So Alan goes,
it was all over.
Frank shamrock had them all sorts of shit.
Frank shamrock grabbed the rope.
He kept separating them.
And then finally at the end,
frank shamrock grabbed a toehold on island goals and fucking breaks his fucking
foot.
You got to watch that fight.
That's Kim.
I get question.
What's the most dangerous thing you've hunted?
Because I don't know shit about hunting.
And I remember you telling me about a guy who hunts,
I freak,
but he,
he'd like 100 buffalo and he would shoot them.
Right.
And then forgot clothes.
He would,
he would have to shoot him again cause they charge.
Oh yeah.
That was a show that I watched.
It was really kind of disturbing.
The guy shot an elephant.
That's right.
Yeah.
And the elephant started running at him and then the guy with the a rifle shot
the elephant in the head and I was like,
what is going on here?
Like this?
It was gnarly on,
on some of those in,
in Africa.
And that dangerous game you don't want,
I mean you can't shoot when they're way out there because your,
your aim isn't going to be that accurate.
So you have to wait actually till they're right there til you know,
and we've got to get on.
They're kind of dangerous game.
We talked to their elephant,
a hippo.
Ooh.
Halos or buffalo.
That Cape Buffalo hunting is very crazy.
That's one of those things where you go,
we have these arbitrary rules as to what you can kill and what you can't kill
him.
It's a very strange,
but we all agree to them like we all agree it's okay to swat mosquitoes.
Nobody gets mad at you when you swap a mosquito.
Nobody gets mad at you when you swat a fly fly.
But he Kilifi nobody gives a shit.
You step on a roach.
Nobody gives a fuck about a roach.
But then you start moving up.
Just can you stop a mouse?
Definitely not.
If you stomp them out,
so you're a piece of shit,
but if you put a mouse in a mouse trap,
hey,
you're not doing the dirty work.
You're farming it out to some fucking mercenary spring set up.
Right.
Okay.
What about rats?
He can't stomp around either.
Okay.
Um,
physical.
What about a beaver?
No,
you can't kick a beaver to death.
Okay.
I can't kick a baby to death.
All right.
Okay.
Well what,
what,
what level?
When do we decide this?
Like,
what weird distinction do we make about what life we can consume?
Societies.
Society's you decided it strange,
right?
Cause it from movies cause we make them so friendly.
You know what I'm saying?
Like a raft.
It tooi Bambi.
You have all these animals for sure that I was,
bears are always friendly and movies.
Whole weeks,
cranes,
Jersey theory or my God,
Eddie.
Let's,
what if we were supposed to eat insects,
but we were brainwashed into thinking they were gross.
Well,
people use it.
We ate insects.
We wouldn't be on the tit.
Well,
I don't think it's a conspiracy theory,
but it's definitely something that people are realizing,
especially with crickets and grasshoppers.
And they'll approach really healthy brought,
I'm scared to death of him.
I'm scared of that because of bugs.
You know,
like,
like what if we're supposed to be like,
I know I do too as Lyme disease.
I was talking to this dude,
that kid that we were hanging out with.
Yeah.
He was uh,
talking about Lyme disease and uh,
he was saying that,
uh,
he got bit by a tick and I know,
I know three,
four people that have gotten Lyme disease from ticks and you get bit by these
fucking ticks and it fucks with your immune system.
That's the only way to get it.
Or you're pretty sure that it is the only
tax because people are scared of the Times because bugs transmit horrible
diseases.
It ruined your life.
Like ticks in particular transmit horrible diseases.
If you thought the black plague was from rats wasn't really from rats,
it was from what the rats were carrying them there,
they were carrying some sort of Mites or bacteria or some,
some bugs or some shit.
Like what was the black plague that it came,
I'm pretty sure this,
that it came off of things that lived on the rats.
It wasn't necessarily the rats itself.
Also insects kill more humans than any other animal in the world does he know
black widows are like Viagara.
Here it is.
The black plague barber caused by bacterium.
Yeah,
pesticides.
This circulates amongst the wild rodents.
So,
so that was a,
it was a bacteria.
It was some sort of a disease that lived off the rodents as a bug.
It's a fucking bug.
Cause a million bugs.
They could just think about,
have you ever tried to just grab a grasshopper?
It's weird.
Tries to jump in.
You want to let it go.
And it's like the guy's scary at generation after generation.
What if we were like fucking really good at insects?
What we used to be,
man,
this,
if you ever talked to anybody who is like a bug catcher or a moth catcher or
somebody collects butterflies,
they say that there's a thrill that people get when you catch up of rare bug and
you cash in your neck.
That goes DNA deep because at one point in time,
humans are,
our answers.
Did you used to be insectivores.
So the,
the people that are like bug catchers,
they want us like them on boards and Shit and study all these different them.
Yeah.
It's,
it's a life form that you're allowed to capture because they only live like a
week anyway.
And so you're allowed to have these,
you're a trophy hunter for butterflies.
You're allowed to be,
but you're like,
you're a person who's an,
you know,
Urus you're studying,
you're studying these animals,
killing you.
But the guy die anyway.
I mean some of them just died,
but the cavemen didn't have drawings on the cave wall of spearing a grasshopper
will,
is this stuff good meeting point.
A line's right there.
You could start
off a conversation with that shit just cause I don't know anything about
hunting.
But when you go to Africa to hunt that dangerous game,
what's the point?
You know what I'm saying?
Like what?
What would be the point of flying to Africa to hunt?
I don't question that shit.
Okay.
No,
it's a,
I mean for me it's a challenge.
It's new countries,
new culture.
It's experiencing new things,
but like you don't eat the hippo meet,
right?
Or do you know,
well,
the hippo meat,
there's tons of hippos over killed the hippo.
No,
I haven't.
I haven't been more post scare.
Oh,
you killed the hippo.
Would you put the meat in the freezer and ship it back?
Apparently now hippo tastes good.
You can leave now.
Supposedly tastes good too.
Here's how it works.
It's crazy right now.
People on the planet,
I could tell you dude,
dude named Corey Knowlton,
he was on the podcast.
He's a famous guy who went over to Africa and paid something like $250,000.
Second time.
Yeah.
He took me to kill a rhino.
He shot this black rhino.
That was,
it was a male rhino that was too old to breed and it was killing other rhinos.
Is this HIPAA threat to this?
Fuck yeah.
No Tanzania.
You gotta you gotta you can't get bit by a hippo.
Hippo step on it.
Definitely.
Yeah.
Right.
So in Tanzania,
here's,
here's how dire it is over there.
All they want is protein.
So whatever you kill people.
The value.
Yeah.
The people that live in Tanzania that the,
uh,
the natives,
that's Australian or African?
No,
no,
no.
Tanzania is Africa.
Africa.
Um,
here's,
here's an example.
We were over there hunting and there was,
there was,
um,
Tanzanians there.
What were you hunting?
I was hunting a lion.
Buffalo monkeys did.
Did you see any of that?
Do you see any lines or,
I never got shot at a lion.
Killed the baboons.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
See the lions,
the line thing is where people get pissed off.
Did you kill him?
He just shot him like he'd be hanging out
and it lands baboons,
baboons,
tear stuff up.
Baboons.
Actually we'll go into,
so they live in grass,
grass huts over there.
They've been known to go in there and like bite on babies' heads,
fossils there things.
There things are this long about Boone is nasty.
So do you shoot it on spot?
I'm with,
yeah.
Oh Wow.
That's so crazy.
So anyway,
the person is like a monkey fucked a dog.
There's poachers over there that will,
you have a baby.
You got to
get to my bathroom before they drown.
There's,
there's uh,
the poachers over there is like,
when you,
when you would see a poach or with a gun,
it was almost like whoever could shoot first.
They wanted to shoot at you.
We had a man who wanted a shooter.
You Poach.
Poach roasters.
You,
yeah.
Anybody you are,
they're getting caught.
Poaching.
Right.
And so it's almost like the wild west.
God Damn.
Yeah.
And all they're trying to get his meat.
Okay.
And say,
okay,
meet,
meet good.
They want protein.
So they would go,
they'd go into land.
They're not supposed to be on.
How do they know you're cool?
What does that process like?
They,
they,
they don't go like this.
Right?
You go like this.
No,
you don't do this.
because they point the gun at you.
They're not supposed to be there.
So Walter Poachers,
is that what happens then?
What's the situation?
The point a gun at them and are
the first experience that we had is,
I saw this,
this guy,
he was crossed,
I don't know,
150 yards away and I,
the guy I was with is who I was hunting with.
His name was Ryan.
And I said,
I see a man.
And he goes,
where?
I said,
there's a man right there,
you know,
it was a black guy.
He had all all brown stuff on racist.
And uh,
I said,
I go,
he's got a gun and he goes,
get behind this tree.
And I said,
are we going to get shot?
And he goes to stay behind the tree.
And so the guy circled around and came,
he was 150 yards away then and he came to 50 yards and you standing there
staring with his gun and uh,
he said he's a poacher.
The guys were said he's a poacher.
This guy never talked.
Finally he melted back into the trees and I was standing there and I said,
I see two more guys up in the rocks.
And they were hiding in the rocks and they took off running.
So I went up to their camp and they had all this,
uh,
you know,
the witch doctor had told him,
if you put powder on your wrist,
you're going to be invisible.
So that guy probably thought he was invisible because the witch doctor of the
village told him you went to their camp,
you didn't go back to your goddamn car and take the fuck off.
No,
just camp to the camp.
And I got hold their stuff.
And the reason why he didn't shoot it 150 yards is because they don't have any
ammo.
So they have a rifle,
but they have to,
they have to make it into a firearm essentially.
So they have to stuff ball bearings down there,
old school firing,
Pin,
the civil war and you're fucking right.
Gum powers,
they have to be safe 40 yards away.
And he was got that close and saw the Guy Ryan who I was with had a high power
rifle with a scope and he's like,
well I'm out gunned here is what he is thinking,
I'm assuming.
And he took off.
Then the guys he's with took off and all,
they had the head of burlap sacks with wire harnesses to put over there like a
backstrap in a burlap sack.
Yeah,
the burlap sack races.
exactly.
And so they would kill an animal.
They'd poach it,
they'd cut the meat off,
they'd hang it on branches or rope and dry it out,
and then they'd take that meat.
They just called protein in a,
put it in the borough,
burlap sack,
take hike all the way back to the village and sell it.
And what do they leave the,
the head and everything?
Yeah,
just bones.
You know what you can't eat.
So anyway,
that's when you talk about killing animals,
they will gladly take the animals you kill.
You know what I mean?
And as far as for hunting goes,
you say,
well why would you want to go?
I mentioned why I would go,
but it also is the only economy they have over there.
You know in Tanzania,
one monkey meetings,
they will need that.
No,
some of them do.
You said this is the only reason you said is the,
is the only economy they have out hunting,
hunting,
hunting trophies.
People.
People would call it trophy,
but it's just,
it's just hunters from abroad going there and,
and putting money in the economy challenge.
Is that why you go with it?
Cause it's the ultimate challenge.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
to kill a Cape Buffalo with a bow and Arrow tato tough.
Those they call them black death.
Why they kill people.
Damn.
Yeah,
they're nasty.
So you are you,
you know hunters that have died?
Um,
I don't know personally any,
I mean I have friends that have died not over there,
but hunting.
They'd died hunting
a fell off a cliff.
That was my buddy right here,
Roy.
She was sheep hunting and um,
she putting,
yeah,
when you're is he was hunting dall sheep up in Alaska.
And uh,
you know,
when I talk about the challenge,
that's why we do it.
We get up in the cliffs are those sheep lives and live and he's with the bone
Arrow and one false step up there.
And that could be your last,
and that's what happened to him a year ago.
Uh,
October 4th.
Damn.
That sucks man.
So,
but that's,
you know,
when we talk about,
you want to hunt black death,
you want to hunt a sheep in the mountains,
there's an inherit risk in doing that.
We understand that.
And that's part of,
that's part of the journey.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
So
it's,
so it's a weird thing
to be a person aware of all the things that you need to consume to stay alive,
you know,
stick with you guys when shit goes down.
Can I have your number and
said,
hey,
I've got skills.
I got Joe Rogan now.
I got you.
I'm not talking,
talking about my family,
you know what I mean?
Are you doing,
you know all I want a job.
You're secret service.
You run your brother.
I told you you're my Dana White.
You need me to choke anybody out ride,
which is build my house.
I make my food for me and anybody.
I'll be your secret service to get to help plan the,
if I had it was head of security,
no motherfucker would get in ever
double cross zone.
Let's,
let's really check into everything he says to Trump government.
The government,
everybody agrees that the criminals let's check into everything,
less everything.
They say,
let's,
let's look into what the fuck they're really saying.
What's wrong with that?
Oh No,
let's just believe what they're saying.
Oh yeah.
One more crush for Camden.
And you guys can talk.
Conspiracies.
No,
no,
no.
Just cause I've never been a hunter.
I've never been around hunting.
You grew up hunting like as a kid?
Um,
no.
You know,
my dad didn't hunt.
He was an
athlete and uh,
so yeah,
so he,
uh,
he didn't hunt.
He aren't and on just wasn't part of it.
So,
um,
my mom and dad got divorced and my Stepdad got me started in hunting or I was 15
years old.
That's when I start.
So,
yeah.
So it's not like you grew up knowing or being around it and that's nuts.
No.
So then my buddy Roy,
who died,
uh,
he,
introduced me to bow hunting when I was 18,
and then that's all I've done since then.
Do you feel the rush,
is that like,
no matter what the fuck goes down,
you're going to be able to eat?
Yeah,
no rush right now.
Hunting,
hunting has given me confidence in all aspects of life because I've overcome so
much out.
You know in the mountains,
you know that you guys can go out and shit went down.
You went out to some stream and Colorado,
you're going to find a fine,
right?
Yeah.
Most likely I trust you.
So is the right by your side in a day.
Here's the reality of a day.
Like today it's 86 degrees.
If there's nothing going on,
if we don't have any refrigeration,
we're kind of fucked because food's not going to last.
So you're going to have to get it on a regular basis.
You're going to have to dry shit out.
You're going to have to have vegetables like the African as in Tanzania or just
slap me down just like the settlers did.
I think I first came here and I tried to,
well they,
you know,
they decimated the animal populations across the country.
I'm reading that Dan Flores book about wolves or coyotes.
Coyotes,
coyotes.
Dude.
It's fucking incredible.
It's incredible.
When you,
you,
you find out like what they did to,
uh,
well,
what they did to all the animals across the United States after the war.
Well,
a bunch of people fucking watch war.
Was it her fashion?
American war?
Which war was it?
It should have been,
yeah,
Spanish American war post that the soldiers came back and they needed a way to
make a living.
And one of the things they did is they did what they called market hunting,
did grow across the country,
just shooting shit for stores and they had a shoot shit all the time for what
stores?
For a store,
for sell,
for to sell them for me,
like with,
people had domesticated some animals,
but there was also a lot of money and just shooting animals and getting to meet
out about where'd you get this information from?
The library to this is all,
this is all from Dan [inaudible] book and also he's a,
he's a professor?
No,
no,
no.
Dan Flores is a professor and he used to be,
Steve Rinella is a professor and he was in some sort of a,
a natural history.
Um,
uh,
class,
I believe it was.
Anyway,
he's like a wildlife historian so he understands like the history of wildlife in
this country and he's like up to the latest information as far as like what
animals evolved here and where they spread out,
where they came back.
It's fascinating shit.
So he was on Rinella,
his podcasts and he was talking about how they just went across the country just
wiping out antelope,
just wiping them out,
just wiping out buffalo,
wiping them out and they just take that and sell it to market
and they just wasn't part of it is because it,
it had to be fresh all the time basically because we could keep it,
you know,
it's no different than a mountain lion killing every three days.
They like to eat fresh meat.
In their defense.
They didn't know they were going to kill all the God damn man was,
I probably thought it was going to last forever.
So they probably didn't have a good accurate account of them.
That's for sure.
There was this got a family,
they're trying to make some phone nowadays there's a conservation mindset.
So we have the ability to look at numbers.
We look at caring capacity for the,
for the land,
and so we can kill.
It's like you will dream date.
What's your dream killed?
Come on.
You know you got one man has got to be something that you want to kill before
you die.
Well,
no,
I mean a human and now I like elk hunting.
If I only could hunt elk or one animal the rest of my life,
it'd be elk.
And that's what we were doing and fish and shit.
Nothing.
None of that stuff.
You don't want to go out into that.
I'm into bone fish.
He's a socialist.
Okay,
so the ultimate is an elk.
What about you?
It's the same no belt grill that the number one on the list.
The grizzly.
You want to be able to eat and you save the head.
Oh yeah.
He put her in the cabin.
Every cabin
on the fucking wall or on the floor.
The first one you got to fucking news everything.
You're like,
I already got a goddamn right.
Hey,
you just saved the head.
Keep it all,
keep it off.
Every long,
Oh wait a minute.
You sell.
We sell now you can actually,
but you're so right
and you kill a bear.
Put her on Instagram.
That's 6,000 that I've done that many times.
We get real bad.
You get a ton of hate on Instagram.
Post Han Jamie show.
Show a show.
Eddie that bear paw my answer.
Now,
what's the biggest barrier?
Killed polar bear.
No,
it's a brown bear.
It's a nine nine foot.
Six inches can kill polar bear.
Put your mind into it and he said,
fuck it.
I'm going to fucking evolve.
We're going to do the snow.
We're going to fucking did.
We'll get a break.
New Ground.
That's fake
photo shot too.
That's not real calm.
Look at that fucking Paul.
Where'd you catch them slipping?
No Way.
Fuck man.
One Boehner.
It killed him.
One shot.
Wait,
where do you hit on that?
Right in the lungs.
Damn.
One shot.
It's an optical illusion.
You know you hold it so close to the camera at appears big butt.
Your head because your head,
because there's looks that looks like it's nine feet tall.
What was it that normal that bear was nine foot six inches.
See,
I didn't,
what was the meat?
Good.
I mean,
it's not very good on those.
Oh my God.
Even really sick.
Well Cook right me.
Right.
You get really strict about tricking.
Gnosis how many times did you have to hit it?
Just one Arrow in the head.
No,
went out right in the heart.
Lungs.
The lungs take out the lungs.
God Damn Long.
It's two minutes.
Three minutes.
No.
Um,
let's see.
That one was dead and about 30 seconds.
What?
You didn't have to go up,
go kneel on the band.
I'm in.
Throw some old d tours down in the belly.
It's hard for people to imagine that you need to control the population of
certain animals.
It's hard for,
that's,
that's a weird one for people.
Yeah.
It's like you're not going to eat it,
but you need to kill it.
Why do you guys need to kill it?
Yeah.
I mentioned that today and too confusing conversations.
He would get upset.
I love bears.
They're beautiful and all that shit,
but hey,
you know what?
I don't mind that.
Hey,
what do you love bears.
I love bear and the cartoons and I got her home washed.
Brainwashed as,
but I don't want to be attacked by no goddamn bear.
So if that fear was eliminated,
1000% maybe more fucking Mexicans would go in the woods.
A strong Mexican would presence is not there.
I thought that's why we stay in the cities.
Well bears are fucking legitimately scary.
I'm sure you saw that video that was going around just a couple of days ago of a
guy who's a,
he's a knifemaker Montana.
He was up in the woods and he got attacked by a mama bear and he got attacked
twice.
He got away White,
sprayed with the bear spray.
She's still got ahold of him.
He got away and then he got away a second time.
Is that the need to get away from it?
Does that beer spray legit cause I was making fun of the guy in like no,
the beer space kind of legit.
I would believe it better than the cartilage it,
but it doesn't work always.
It didn't work in this case.
That's this guy.
No,
no.
This is like last week Eddie,
this guy sees right here is his scalp.
It's shredded.
You see as down to the bone right there.
It's like,
it's got a giant flap up here.
Call now.
He's a hunter.
He was scouting for outlook.
Oh it is arm.
Look at that.
Like how often does that,
once a year.
Yeah,
probably once a year or something like that.
I would say that's a good note.
Do you hear about that boy scout leader where uh,
you know in boy scouts they tell you if you run into a bear that you'll
Yellowstone.
He goes,
if there's a beer,
everyone lays down and they'd stumble upon a fucking black bear and he lays down
and all the other troops are watching the beers.
Like,
look at this fucking idiot and just ate them in front of the troops.
Oh my God.
Was that on Youtube?
It's on all over it.
To me,
there's a real difference.
There's a real difference between the behavior of black bears and brown bears.
And what's really weird is it more black bears attack people as predators versus
more brown
bears attack people out of shock like a brown bear.
Like what happened with this guy is what happens all the time?
You fuck up and you get near a mama with her cubs and she just rips you apart.
That's what happens to most of these guys when they play dead.
There's a different reaction when a black bear gets you.
If a black bear gets you and you played dead,
he might think you're dead and just started eating pass first.
The general,
well,
the first was coyotes.
I think beer too.
What you want to do,
the thought has been wipers are the worst.
The polar bear,
they're the worst.
That's racist.
Polar bears are the worst.
The worst there.
Why not here?
The thing is clear that there's with polar bears is their hair is clear up.
Her skin is,
here's the thing,
why did he say,
how can you say their hair is clear?
I'm going back on one of the year.
How can we say the Harris clear when it's actually white as fuck,
but it's clear.
They say it's clear.
You're not knowing region.
Your white.
Okay.
[inaudible] don't they say that they,
I think they described their hair is being clear.
That's exactly what they say.
I exclaimed white.
It's actually transparency.
It holds no color and appears to be white because it reflects visual light.
I've seen,
I've seen polar bears guide.
That was why was saying that's why I'm confused,
but also polar bears at the zoo.
It's not going off white snow.
It's going off.
There's still,
yeah,
there's still a white,
the first actually transparent and holds no color.
It only appears.
Why?
Because it reflects visible.
Then it would look like a jellyfish.
The ocean come on the case.
That a technicality though because
it doesn't all color reflect visible light in some way.
Right,
Jamie?
That's right.
You're right.
Can we it on her up?
I'm pretty sure like,
uh,
I think like black reflects or absorbs all light.
It's one of those,
right?
Once it jumps in the water,
why is it still white dude?
Lights change color based on how much or rather colors,
whether change their Hughes based on how much light is there.
But they look to us
a color is a,
a frequency on the spectrum of light.
So your Sam,
that frequency,
right?
It's all there.
It's like technically our eyes are only seeing a certain uh,
gauge or level of that frequency.
Like hearing is the same thing.
It's also on a frequency.
All,
all audio is draft frequency.
You can only hear 20 hertz to 20,000 Hertz.
Light is very similar.
It's not the same kind of hurts,
the same kind of waves,
but in a very similar way.
Like once you get to infrared as a way higher frequency than what we can
actually see.
And that's sort of what it's getting into saying here through reflecting light,
they only,
we can see a very fucked up version of it.
Sorry Jamie,
I'm proud of you.
[inaudible] nickname is Jamie Phd.
That's it.
That's young Jamie,
Jamie smart school down some phd type Shit.
So all that,
he certainly did.
Um,
so all this stuff about their,
their white skin,
I'm not sure.
I understand that Mexico,
they have black skin right underneath all that.
I think they're really dark and hoses.
Yeah,
I think they're actually,
they have a dark body underneath all that stuff.
It's a weird animal man.
They just up their jacking.
Shit.
They don't have a single piece of vegetable.
So you can't really kill plants.
Right?
Cause there's not a ton of them.
Now you're not polar bear hunt.
Hey,
I have a polar bear.
Had to fight a grizzly bear and I'm sure they'd been on borders where like every
now and then like bitch,
the snow is mine and was like,
bitch,
this the mountains are mine.
Look at this shit.
Has there ever been a polar bear versus grizzly bear match?
Polar bears is so well insulated by inches of blubber and for that they're heat
signature is nearly invisible through infrared photography to him young Jamie's
on the ball.
Damn the guy.
That's crazy.
Make fucking sounds did.
He's like,
Kanye West is going to make a sound studio off bare blubber dude.
You could barely see them.
Right?
I think this is what you'd be getting into.
It's all good.
He knew.
I told him you mad.
So it's like,
it's like a lot of things in life.
You have to experience it.
Yeah.
Once you experience it,
you know an actual fight.
Companion.
Exactly.
These things go.
They go,
they go down the tracks,
they take turns and goes into the woods.
We've got to cover up.
You're knocking over trees.
They get the,
it was always fine man.
Listen,
these are awesome.
It's harder.
What's beautiful about these?
There's nothing to be sorry for everybody's used to it.
Listen,
it's just what?
What's fun about these things?
Is there chaos?
I was excited to be involved and I learned one thing.
I can't show favoritism.
It's a core.
You can is important.
You gotta look,
you gotta be open minded.
I didn't want veto power or Dan can do whatever you want to talk shit.
And I'm talking about it through my perspective as a commentator.
He can't show.
The problem is you've got to keep the dialogue going.
So if there's really nothing,
the last resort is I'm going to talk show and you just fucking sad cause I ain't
got none now.
Yeah.
So you got to keep the goals.
That's what happens a lot.
You're like fuck,
I'm sorry bro.
It's for the show.
With a sacrifice for the team.
We're going to sacrifice you.
Yeah.
Like as a commentator man,
it's really hard to not have favoritism like every morning.
Twice as much.
You talked too much.
Shut out.
You talked too much bitch.
No,
we supposed to do shut the fuck up.
Get out and said what if it was normal that there was six seconds,
nine seconds of dead air pockets everywhere on the show that was normal.
And this show in any show like that was normal podcast.
If anything,
anything.
You got to keep it going.
You got to keep going on.
And if you're the host,
you're name is on some shit.
Sometimes there's dead air people off.
Yeah,
you're going to cut cause you got to keep it going.
Like bitch,
we'll go back to you.
Shit,
we got four hours,
we'll get back to your shit.
But now that I've got this shit,
let me finish this and then we kill 20 minutes and then we'll get back to your
shit.
I think so.
Some fights.
It's important to give Debbie.
Yeah,
you've got to figure out when to do it though.
And I'm not always right.
I fuck it up a lot.
It's just cause it's your Ad Libbing like pee.
If people complain about like commentaries on one way or another way.
I'm just trying to do my best and sometimes it's a slippery thing.
Like when people are fighting and crazy shit's going on.
Passion,
passionate.
And also you might not recognize everything that's happening.
Things happen.
You're looking for patterns and striking,
but you're also looking for,
you know like someone slowing down is a lot of shit you're looking for.
You know?
It's a weird,
it's a weird gig.
The crazy thing,
that's hard.
We talked about this years,
years ago when you first started commentating for the UFC,
like as a fantasy.
Wouldn't it be cool if somehow the owner of the UFC wanted you to be yourself
and wanted you to say whatever the fuck you want her to say?
Just like this.
It was a fantasy and now what's happening?
You can say whatever you want.
We're going to have to talk about it.
They'll show you.
It's a beautiful thing.
It's what's happening right now.
Shit,
no rules.
True can even bring into journals or dominoes fucking style,
you know?
And here's another thing,
friends who don't always agree on shit but still love each other,
have a great time hanging out and talking shit,
this motherfucker,
because he sounds do we hate each other.
We hate each other,
but you're trying to steal him away from me.
And I'm like,
guys go.
If that happened,
another
fucking men.
But you know what I mean?
My point is if there's an illusion,
it's an illusion that a lot of people suffer under and that illusion is that
someone has to think exactly like you for you to be their friend.
Oh No,
I take that shit is so stupid because there's a lot of people that have some
crazy ideas and I love him to death.
I give him a hug every time I see him.
And I only talked to him about certain shit.
Who wants to hang out with somebody exactly like that.
Yeah,
that'd be a lot of people do.
Man.
A lot of people are scared of being themselves,
you know,
and,
and so because of that,
they want to find like some comfortable frequency where it's like an accent that
everyone in the neighborhood has.
Yeah.
It's a way of thinking and behaving that reinforces the idea that you're on the
same team as everybody else.
It's a natural instinct that we have.
It's a tribal instinct.
No,
I give any ship.
There's a couple of things he sent me links to and we've had long talks with
legit stuff.
Especially when it comes to my kids.
There's a fucking spectrum.
There's a spectrum.
People think it's a beautiful thing that people think all this drama that's
going on.
But me and Brendan were not like tight and going out and having fucking lunch
all the time.
But let me tell you,
I rarely go out to lunch with any friends or anything.
I don't hang out with anybody.
I have no time between all my schools.
It's just all my free time is my wife and my son.
Everything else is my wife
and my son.
Busy.
I don't hang out with anybody.
So I mean,
Brendan,
I fucking love bladder.
How many times I said to you personally off camera.
I said that motherfucker.
You too.
When you guys go off on Emma,
I've told them at least three times.
You guys have amazing chemistry because you guys remember fights.
I don't remember shit.
So when you started talking about this guy knocked out this guy,
if three years ago I just shut the fuck up because my brain don't work like that
no more.
I watched too many conspiracy theories.
You guys are watching fight.
I want to an oil deception man.
When I talked to shop when I took to you,
it elevates my thinking about like past fights because I know you know so much
about past fights so I know I'm talking to a dude.
He's like on the same level as far as like your history of like pride fights and
who not really.
You're to close fucking battling.
Fucking close.
Pretty close.
But it's inspiring.
Like you know so much about it that I have to like remember shit.
What is your system?
How do you stay so sharp?
Because you,
I know you stay sharp and you got your,
you got work ethic when it comes to being on top of the UFC and what's going on.
And I know you got work ethic.
I know you said before you go to bed you have to watch some fights right before
you go to bed.
It's just cause you guys like it.
So I stay up on that.
When do you watch the fights?
When they're live and I'll record them and if it's,
if it's like a big one or if we're doing a fight competitor or doing something,
I'll watch it again.
You don't have to do it a lot,
man.
I've been watching a lot of more time,
A lot of Moyie Thai food
boxing obsessed with boxing,
but you know me,
I barely can keep up with them in Maine you have said so I don't have time for
kickboxing and boxing,
but in big bear,
triple g I got a taste of that motherfucker.
I like Kim.
All of a sudden I got,
I got a little foot in the door in boxing,
but I also,
while I was up in big bear,
we're fucking just,
just chillin,
making sure our seizures don't act up like all night.
And we put on the best of glory,
the best of glory.
Holy Shit.
Get on UFC fight pass and watch the,
they'll go through,
there's a documentary them,
man,
they hit fucking hard.
Holy Shit.
All of a sudden you guys are watching that.
Listen man.
I'm like,
good.
I'm so glad you brought that up.
Cause I was actually gonna ask you guys if you want to do this.
That's guys fight companion for glory when there's glory,
glory,
Denver.
And it's on October 21st and it's in Denver.
Is that a Saturday?
And it's a niche.
I think I'm going to be Nikki Holtzclaw's rematching Marketo grown hall.
Is that,
is that,
who was in October?
Why?
Oh,
I'll tell you again,
but I was thinking it'd be fun to do that.
Um,
the 21st of October 21st he's sober,
he's fighting growing heart and he's a bad motherfucker.
They had a really close fight the first time really close.
Um,
Varga,
rue,
small and
very small.
And so this 24th of October 21st 21st and uh,
but Nicky holds skin is a bad mother fucker.
Dude.
21st of October I'm going to be in Springfield.
Dammit.
Oregon grown on,
it's a bad motherfucker to planets.
Springfield in the house.
You know who we need to get in if he can,
we need to get Joe Schilling in for that one,
right?
Yeah.
Right.
Because Joe was fighting to glory for launch and they showed that fight that we
saw at the forum would be where they live,
where they went into overtime and they did the extra rounds and fucking knocked
out back.
It was amazing.
Last man standing,
hey dude to do some more mountain running on October 23rd listen,
listen in Springfield
had a disc replaced in his back,
like pretty significant back.
Ivan's roll Jujitsu and over four months now I just had major back surgery so I
think I might take off the rest of the year just to be sure to safe smartly.
Sure.
Cause when the doctor tells me,
you know,
I was on,
you can either get fusion on your desk,
which is last resort.
We just got to fucking screw everything together.
Or we could put a disk in,
right?
There's people that are qualified for the desk and if you don't qualify for that
desk,
they're like,
you know what,
your shit so fucked up.
You got to fucking lock all that shit up with screws.
So I was on the fence.
So the doctor would sit me down and say,
what does this Jujitsu people picking you up and slamming you?
I'm like,
no,
I'm not gonna really get,
are you?
Are you,
are they picking you up?
Is there impact?
And the fact that it was asking this question,
I was like no,
no,
no.
It's like dude,
I'm fucking pillow quarter guard.
And just clinch on mother fuckers aren't impact in my roles ever did.
Do you have any back issues?
Came all that running and hiking shit.
Cause that's the only thing that tightens me up is when I run,
I love running.
But that's what tightens my back.
Yeah,
you're pretty big.
You know that makes a difference on running for the pounding.
So it's tougher on your body.
But with all the hunter and anything,
you haven't had any injuries or knee problems?
Nothing.
But what's a,
what's a really big guy for a hundred a hundred mile?
Anybody who's been the biggest guys?
I mean nobody's ever over
one 80 so I can't do it.
You can't do it.
It's just to do it.
Talk about really what we're talking with Stephan struve.
I was thinking there's only like a certain amount of blood the that guy can get
to his body.
Right?
He's got so much body to deal with.
Like he's,
he's got his cardio can't be as good as the mighty mouse is just so big.
There's just so much blood has to keep pumping fuel from.
I run 40 year and laughed.
I run 14 miles a week for a bigger guy.
Loved his size.
Might not be like I have anything to do with the UFC fight though.
Maybe if he was headed like survive the apocalypse,
he would see the difference.
But I don't think you'd see the difference.
Like could just cause he's seven foot that he's going to have shitty cardio.
No,
I'm just saying that you're,
when you're to
65 I think there's a magic number and I think there's a lot of guys agree with
this and it's around where steeply Mijo chick is.
It's around where Cain Velasquez is set to 40 number.
It seems like two forties as heavy as you want to get cause you can handle a guy
that's two 65 because at 25 pound differential,
although it seems like a big deal,
like if if the skills better it,
it plays itself out because it's 25 pound differential.
That guy,
that 265 pound guy or bigger and cutting down to it,
it has such a giant reservoir that he needs to fill also slower,
slower speed but cardio,
but if you're a two 40 and you got Brock Lesnar,
that's not good.
That's not true because that's what Cain Velasquez did to him.
He worked him.
Brock took him down,
he got right back up and Brock got tired and Cain did not.
And Kane started beating on him with perfect striking because we've heard pop
pop,
pop and and Brock was like,
Oh shit,
I'm in deep fucking trouble.
And he took him down and beat him up.
It was a brutal fight and an excellent example of how a 240 pound fighter,
it might be a better deal.
That's why I could do that.
Kingsville,
but that's a fighter.
That's,
I mean that could be a fighting style man versus man til it's also,
you have to put it up,
you have to put it up at Cain.
Velasquez has extraordinary cardio for heavyweight.
Cardio is one of the biggest weapons he has and if not the absolutely,
absolutely skill.
Great technique with striking and with wrestling,
but almost more importantly championship mindset,
like a hundred percent confidence in himself and cardio.
That's just like superhuman is a championship mindset.
He has the heart like no one else and then he has cardio is how fucking hard MMA
is.
Even that guy lost.
Yeah.
Isn't that crazy?
Come on,
man.
Even that guy can have a day where he just like when he fought over doom.
That's right.
Yup.
That's what I found is best guys have 10 losses.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Look man,
in my opinion,
I mean bef Kane is not done like his career is not done,
but when it all goes down,
you have to look at him in his prime and go that.
That is one of the very best examples of a heavyweight fighter we've ever seen.
I think he's top two.
If Tom,
I'm 100% with you,
I think on a personal one,
but it might because a door see,
well you could toss for doom in there without a good toss for doom in there,
but you could toss for doom and they're just so,
it was true on accomplishments on paper.
You have to look at if you're doing,
I think,
I think Kane most likely the obviously just my educated opinion,
I think he's the best matchup for four to beat Steve Bay with skill sets because
does doom and then he gets steep a,
it's a tough matchup for steep.
If you look down on paper,
if they fight the way he fought,
if,
I mean,
here's the thing,
they cane has been through some wars with junior wars.
Dbas been through war and steep,
it went through a war with junior.
But the difference between his teeth pays war with Jr.
And I know MMA,
math doesn't really work this way.
Like you can't like look at one guy and go just cause it's one guy beat one guy,
he's going to beat the other guy.
It doesn't work like that.
But if they fight in the same way that Steve Bay fought junior dos Santos,
you've got to think that cane can keep a pace that's ahead of where jds was
correct and take Steve Bay and him,
it was a very close fight between him and jds and it was like super close him
hitting that high level upper echelon of the heavyweight division for the first
time as well,
other than the strew fight.
So I think,
I don't know man.
I think that,
I think that Cain is a nightmare for anybody if he's healthy.
I just think if cane comes back and becomes champion and beat Steve Bay,
he's the best heavyweight of all time and there's a good probability he's going
to do that.
We're steep,
steep.
It's a nightmare.
But his,
that's box boxing but how,
how but what if he did MMA?
Oh boy.
He would get taken down smushed.
You'd get fucked up.
He get taken down and smashed through two.
Don't have know how to wrestle.
You can't start at 35 and compete at that level.
You just,
you're not,
if you don't actually know something.
If a guy knows something and Anthony Boxes Klitschko Andrew Johns,
Joshua [inaudible] not the tall,
those guys would would get destroyed and if not,
they started in them and man fucked up by a lot of high level right now.
They decided to do it.
Do they get fucked up by Rico Verhoeven?
This,
forget about MMA.
Just kickboxers a like Rico.
Verhoeven will fuck up a lot of boxes and touch him.
He wouldn't give me away way on the outside.
More prepared for MMA than boxers know.
What I'm saying is that boxers right now,
like them getting into MMA is they can't even get through the top kickboxers is
what I'm saying.
So kickboxing is kick the top kickboxers are more prepared to go into MMA and
not necessarily guys get taken down.
Yeah.
Everybody gets taken down.
So when they get taken down,
you know as well as anybody does when they're fucked,
they're all fun.
The difference between the boxing,
like the best boxers,
they're hands are without a doubt.
Better than the best kick boxers.
Yeah.
But they don't have to be that good with their hands because they got all these
other tools.
So they might have one skill that's like maybe I would say like the Max of the
best kick boxers,
like 70% of the hands of a world championship boxer.
Right.
If you want to look at it like a flow,
like a Roberto Duran and is proud where the fuck punches like that in MMA,
right?
No one wait.
Yeah.
Kickboxing.
Okay.
Say this again you guys.
No,
no,
not,
not.
Maybe the guys maybe.
I don't think you can get there.
I think to maybe you got a sugar ray Leonard as good as rot.
Roberta dress,
he gets to do knees,
elbows,
takedowns.
I mean,
look,
Robbie Lawler was a fucking savage and I would never compare him unfavorably to
anybody because he's like one of my all time.
Great.
Yours just as good as fucking focused on boxing solely.
If he focused on boxing solely or plot right now,
fuck in his prime sugar ray Leonard and boxing.
Oh my God,
my brother who would inboxing God inboxing to come on.
Do you have any idea what that would look very similar to you having a fight
with sugar ray Leonard.
What about kickbox?
What about
in kickbox?
If they fought kickbox kind of list kind of a fuck him up.
I mean you don't box it.
I did boy scouts for two years.
I did karate for one year.
I did Cass Magda,
which is again [inaudible] system fucking years.
Did you hear what I just said?
Obviously Connor has got really good hands.
He's obviously got a lethal power in its punches and Mary that he'll carry that
somewhat in boxing,
but sugar ray Leonard,
if you watch his fights,
like when he was in his prime,
he was,
when he knocked out Tommy Hearns that 13th round after Angelo Dundee came back
and said,
you're blowing a kid.
And he went out there and put it to Tommy Hearns.
Dude,
I'm,
I'm looking at you,
I'm not going to mention names,
but I've seen some world champion high level UFC guys fight mediocre boxers and
just sparring,
sparring and they get this math.
Tell about when he lit up.
Floyd Mayweather,
his dad times of different Floyd Mayweather,
the senior from sugar ray Leonard Floyd Mayweather senior was a world class box.
Amazing buzz uncles too.
Yeah,
Roger May with it.
Both the Black Mamba,
bad motherfucker.
Bad motherfucker come out in the Mexican gear.
He's a bad motherfucker.
But his dad fought sugar ray Leonard in his prime and he hung,
hung in with him for a little while,
but eventually sugary got him.
It was sugar ray like at his very best.
Tommy Hearns versus Marvin Hagler.
That's,
that's the shit that's going on right now all around us and we won't realize
that for 30 years.
Yeah,
you're right.
You're a hundred percent sure
Thomas were.
We're living in it,
but it's so new to us.
We didn't know what the difference is like music,
but there's like 10 Marvin hagglers now and there's 10 Tommy Hearns.
It's like in MMA.
Look him up.
Anyway,
in MMA there's so many good fights and then we have the boxing fights to the
boxing fights are exciting to
be the best of all time commercials.
Young kids are not into boxing.
I don't gigs or no,
no,
no.
That's not true.
A lot of kids are into boxing match,
Hbo,
Boxing PDS.
Who's getting a minnow?
Alvarez is a hero.
People love Kale or I don't you Mexicans.
Compatriot.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Know what?
He punches hard.
Who's a bad mother?
Bucker Canelo use the under Armour guy.
Tammy hits hard.
So you're an under Armour guy showed you the shoes.
It says keep hammering.
That's right.
Remember Jesus Christ?
No,
I remember,
but I didn't know none of that deal over them.
It's like the rock you and fucking Canela I they take is just one pit Cesar for
the race they made to find that guy.
I can't hold that.
We can't have two conversations at the same time.
Jamie,
let's find the baddest motherfucker oil wrestling and listen,
I'll load them up.
Let's give him clucking Presto when,
so when I show the wolf one Instagram that you were coming on the show,
my boy Cody dom,
he goes,
that guy's my hair out.
I was like,
really?
He's like,
yeah,
I guess hunting.
It's fucking,
you're the Mickey Mail.
Do you live in southern California?
And y'all
don't do that.
Oh,
that's right.
I'm going to see you.
And you're just a regular house,
but your house,
just a regular house like in a regular shirt cabin.
Do you have like a mother fucker eat dead deer?
Yeah.
There's dead deer in there.
In the shed?
No.
In the house with pro con
special thing.
You keep the
keep lies.
What do you do with the flies?
There's no flies.
Fly Paper.
No flies,
dude.
In the wintertime.
Most of the time when you're hunting,
you're hunting in the fall to about the bees and the flies kind of go away for
the most part,
unless you're in a warm climate.
We saw a bunch of flies around this week.
We saw some flaws,
but if he was in Utah,
who wouldn't see any flies?
Now all debt he should try hunting is not weird.
Gay fucking the jungle like in Costa Rica.
See what's up with that.
That's extreme.
You gotta deal with the bugs.
There's a war with the bugs and you're trying to get your fucking mammo.
You're trying to get your Jaguar or a monkey or whatever,
but you got an a different battle with the insects.
Joe,
check this out.
I had this guy when I was doing in that area right there when I was doing that
Scifi show.
Um,
I,
um,
I had this guy on the show call.
His name is Peter Cortez.
He's a professor,
I think at the university.
Houston.
Really,
really smart dude.
But his,
his specialty is infectious diseases in tropical climates.
Like parasites go on your deck.
No.
All,
all,
all form of different parasites.
But this was what was really crazy.
He was saying that somewhere in like the high 90% of all people in these
tropical climates,
I hope I'm not misquoting him.
They have some sort of infections.
They have some sort of parasites living in them.
My jungle.
Yeah,
that seems totally straight.
They go on those lagoons there covering the,
not even that Dick,
if that's a the food you're eating,
owning your,
but it's in like we're talking about Lyme disease.
That's kind of a disease.
I mean it's like it kind of a of a virus or a bacteria.
I don't know how you would describe viruses from all the traveling.
No ticks.
Ticks.
Yeah.
What do you do with that?
How do you deal with that?
I've been bitten by a few ticks and they bury in.
So I would take like a trying to think what either knee,
I think I heat it up and needle and stuck a tick and when they burn they back
out.
What?
Holy Shit.
I've been once then,
right?
No,
a few times.
But yeah,
the ticks because I dunno what happens,
but you can't feel them going in.
All of a sudden you kind of the saliva.
That's a numbing,
right,
so it must be something you think you'd feel them bearing in your skin,
but you don't feel them till their end and then you double check that.
Jamie,
has anybody ever had one of those ticks bury themselves in the rectum?
Oh,
deepen the bottle there.
They go towards the dark out when you stop,
like you know what is that when you go vegan?
I don't know.
It's it crawls inside your butthole.
I just flush out APP.
It just keeps you out of it.
How many times does that have to happen before you just say,
I want to go to boulder.
I haven't had,
I haven't had the belly,
but it's actually the softball size.
Tick their lives in gas now.
Ticks or cast.
It feels good.
You never know.
So I can,
when you're burning all these calories,
when you eat,
just whatever you want.
Fast food,
whatever.
No,
not fast
skin.
Oh my God.
What does this mean?
Hey,
listen,
this is pubic hair.
This.
We have children.
Listen,
I don't even want to know what this is.
It's a tick bite on your genitals.
Is that what was talking about?
Just put ticks on their skin to start looking at,
oh my gosh.
They go look at that.
Smelled what do you do?
Have a tick.
I'm strong.
My sugar's too.
They get a tick too.
That's the thing about the world.
Tick a knows your ass and make different bugs or just jacking each other.
What do you mean?
Oh,
killing each other.
The problem is attracted to the smell of shit that it's,
if you don't wipe her ass right,
boom,
you're,
you're susceptible.
Probably
Browse.
Right dude.
Expect it.
Don't be surprised.
Well,
think about it.
Is that a wives tale that bear are attracted to ministration?
I don't know cause I've heard that.
I believe I've heard that 100% assumed that,
but I would think that people would be afraid to say it because they don't want
to accuse women of being like in any way,
like bringing on the bears or,
and they don't want to address.
I find out that's true.
Bears not attracted,
says,
oh,
you fuck or not accept,
smell it.
We're not attracted polar bear guards,
but polar Stockholm.
I believe it though.
But it says polar bears may be interested in the smell of menstrual blood.
They've eaten about a hundred researchers with China's meanwhile.
Got me.
Well,
it's like a fucking,
this is the cover up.
They bought the song.
Meanwhile,
there's a fucking epidemic,
a bears eating female,
uh,
menstrual terse researchers that Jane Goodall of the bears and like damn they
print.
They didn't tell him about the menstruation.
That's some strong shit.
That's what's really scary about the way some animals kill other animals as
they,
they go asshole first.
Look at that they're stuck asshole for,
but sometimes they do file.
It's junk.
Calm,
menstruating women.
Should you camp there's not attracted.
Well how bout,
how bout how crocodiles dude,
that wouldn't trust those don't bear man.
I wouldn't trust
my listening and the study designed to test the hypothesis that bears are
attracted.
The odors of menstruation,
uh,
Cushing reported that when presented with a series of different odors including
seals,
sense and other,
sends non menstrual human blood and use tampons for Captain Jamie.
Thank you.
That was how dare you.
That was the end of why
he had to,
when I was,
uh,
I didn't finish it,
that I finished.
Four captains elicited a PR.
That party didn't get elicited.
The what?
This is good news.
Now what does it say?
You're going to go on for bears and then you could show it.
You could tell your wife said that these links and say,
look,
they go after periods.
We have to stop that.
I can't bring you.
I do want to bring you on this bear
desires.
I'm concerned for your safety.
Don't you start your rag mix.
I mean,
think about that.
Look at ways website.
Hold on a second.
Your links.
I can't see it.
Jamie.
That camera.
You got the camera set up there.
Okay,
that's good.
A strong behavioral response only to seal sense and menstrual odors.
Use tampons.
Okay,
so it did.
So that's not true.
Those for polar bears.
For polar bears,
it's an attractive,
yeah,
I got to think that is where it's going to smell it to any of that
other stuff.
There's probably other stuff they prefer.
All you got to say,
no.
Just came,
go.
When's the next Hunt Cam?
What and what?
Are you hunting a deer back home?
You bring in your wife?
No,
she has.
Perfect,
dear.
Cool,
Yeah,
Dude.
We sought mountain lions.
Really?
Yeah.
Was telling Mama and how many cubs should have two or three bobcats.
Bobcats.
Did you attempt to cross paths?
Right?
We saw a a,
yeah,
a female.
Two kittens.
If you saw a female,
might be worried at all the other smaller Catholics.
I think that one of them was,
I thought,
why don't I think it was through a little cougar now too.
Why was I needed in my mind?
I saw it so quick.
This is a shitty memory is or you're higher in my mind.
No,
no.
He smoke weed.
Fuck yeah.
You saw me.
You brought no,
no,
not too long.
He thought it was a mountain lion.
No dog.
No,
I didn't bring anything.
no,
no.
You were in the woods.
Heady.
Hold on a second.
I thought those things were,
I thought those things were a cougars.
Now the big Bobcat,
how you can tell like quickly as the tail,
they were really small.
Yeah,
they're small.
But a mountain lion.
You're always going to notice a tail long tail man.
That's interesting cause it was such a brief thing.
You guys said it first and then I turned and saw him for such a maybe half a
second wait a second before they bolted.
And I'm thinking that sometimes when you expect to see something like,
so I think maybe Brian had said cat and maybe I thought Cougar.
Yeah,
so maybe it was just a flash in my mind.
Filled in the blanks.
Yeah.
Which is shocking.
That happens with shots.
Most dangerous cat and this part of the world.
Mal mine more than a bobcat.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Amount amount.
Mine can be 170 pounds and stock you yeah.
Has been stopped.
Once you realize you're being stocked,
is there a point you want to watch a video?
Usually you don't realize it.
They realize you're being stocked at that point.
Is that mission number one to watch this video,
we're going to watch this video,
right?
Video stock.
Put It on Youtube,
but we can watch it on youtube so nobody else sees it.
But uh,
that a guy who got stocked who was on a mountain bike and he got stocked by this
mountain mine who got within inside of 20 yards.
Do we get them?
Is walking slowly at them like this,
like out in the open.
Let me see that out in the open.
Staring at him.
It is fucking horrific dude.
It scares the shit out of me.
Who?
This cat,
this dude is just hanging out in his fucking cat.
Keeps coming close to him.
What is it?
So we can give the dude,
uh,
some props and he can get some views on it.
It says mountain lion standoff with hiker.
So this,
this gentleman,
whoever he was,
it was the hiker.
He was yelling here and the cat just keeps getting closer and closer to him and
he got fucking super sure to take off.
Do they got super sketchy?
That cat was for sure.
Thinking about eating him.
Did he have a gun?
I don't think he did.
He just got loud.
Was it the time?
Yeah.
Um,
Tennessee at Jamie
shitty glacier national park.
Where's that at?
Cam?
Where's glacier national park and he said,
hey bud.
He called them Alaska.
Is it called?
And we said,
hey buy,
I don't think they have a lot of mountain lions in Alaska.
Do they?
Cam Glacier.
That's a big little fucker.
That mother Fucker,
that's how fucking tiger right there.
Dude.
That is so scary.
That cat that no rules have in motherfucker is closing in just an optical
illusion.
Terrible way to die on an optical illusion.
Look,
a hundred pound cat.
Like if you see a German shepherd,
German shepherd wants to fuck you up.
You're scared.
Right?
German shepard might weigh 70 pounds.
Okay.
That's not a big animal at all,
but yet they will most likely fuck you up.
Yeah,
he all those belts and Malcolm was that they use for the police academy.
Think that those are actually like more likely to be in the 60s and 70 lbs.
German shepherds can get a little bit bigger.
No,
no,
he's not.
He just doesn't know what to do.
So he's making this video,
this guy shit in his pants.
Yeah,
that was awesome.
That was awesome.
There's a gang of those videos and occasionally,
occasionally people go missing.
They just grabbed her women and children though.
Not that guy.
That guy was a man and that might've kept him from being killed.
Maybe if that was a child,
the cat wouldn't have hesitated.
Yeah.
Okay.
What did,
he just killed them and it's happened.
I mean,
there was a guy in Cupertino who watched his kid get attacked by a mountain lion
just a year and a half ago and killed Tina was,
they chased it off
and I think then the animal skinny.
Oh,
look at their thing.
That star.
Look at that right arm.
She's checked.
Oh,
so you'd have the most ridiculous reco Roman skills.
You're going to go take a walk in the woods during your mother fucking rive.
How skinny.
Starving.
So then he's dangerous.
Look at it,
dude.
Oh my God.
They're straight up killers.
Ooh,
look at that.
That is so dangerous and it's just,
it's just not sure whether or not you got to bang stick.
I mean,
you think about how the banks that gun think about trying to hold down a house
house cat.
If it doesn't have to be held down 1510 pounds,
150 killed the cat.
Jesus Christ.
Those things are scary.
What's really weird is that we love them and we want them around us,
but not so close.
Look at that one that went,
ran after the,
no check any sprayed it in the trace on the far right.
Greatest Tiger attacks ever caught on camera rounds necessarily thinking,
I want to look at that 7 million views.
As long as it doesn't get us kicked off of Youtube,
Jamie,
because we get so no one else could see it.
It's crazy.
This was the one when the dudes on the top of an elephant and the tiger decides
to row,
look at this whole running out.
I mean,
look at this thing.
Flies through the air.
Oh yeah.
He threw a machete at,
oh my God.
Damn.
Tours are apart.
He shouldn't have time.
That machete a lot better than that.
You're like,
oh shit,
you can't pull it back.
A little dog.
Oh my God.
Oh Shit.
Oh God.
That was quick.
C.
Dot.
Oh my God.
Kill Tigers.
Kills 14 foot crocodile dude.
There's a video that I just watched the other day of a tiger making a run at a
guy and then at the last minute it turns.
But as it's angry and it's in full fury and it's making a runner,
it moves so much quicker than I thought they could.
So much quicker.
It was like a fucking regular cat,
but like 600 pounds,
tiger kills.
What slot there?
Oh my God.
Oh,
these guys are dead.
Everybody's dead.
They killed crocodiles,
dude.
Have you seen those ones and Jaguars in Brazil?
The jumping it right.
My God.
The goal thing across it's warm enough.
I was talking about leopard,
so I think,
or Jaguars rather,
which are even smaller than tigers and they kill those Caymans in Brazil.
There's a bunch of those videos that come behind them.
They treat them like their food man.
They just jack them.
Dude.
How fucking scares a tiger though,
thinks she's huge,
man.
I get this thing is chasing after these fees about like those African lions look
thing.
But imagine you're in this fucking,
because tigers are little truck,
much larger,
700 pounds.
I buy off on the choice.
You want to live around tigers that he wanted to live around.
Criminals have guns on the street,
criminals at the same shit.
Criminals.
They probably think we're fucking crazy that there's humans with guns shooting
people and all they got to do is deal with tight.
Looking at this video,
this tiger is just slowly stocking these fucking people.
There's a truck behind him and there's a truck in front of them and this tiger
is just Strutton.
Dude,
this is scary and that tiger is just trying to figure out what it's going to do.
And this is a video called tiger attacks.
What's scary?
I'm shitting my pants right now.
Motherfucker.
I don't know tiger like that or a government official that wants you suicide.
Tiger.
Eddie.
Okay.
Moment moment.
I just feel like the government officials,
I don't know.
Maybe you're right.
Coax into enlightenment.
You're right.
Yeah.
There's no talking to this tiger.
This tiger doesn't give a fuck if the trade off
Jesus Christ here comes.
Oh God.
Oh,
she's like the Blair witch camera work.
Oh my God.
They're running away from this tiger.
I hit.
Man's not going to scrape the skin off the,
that's the trade off.
I'm so scared of those goddamn things.
Yeah,
I tell you that video.
No Tigris.
Paul.
I think that that video in Beijing or that chick gets in an argument with
someone and she gets out of the car
right here.
Yeah.
She's like,
fuck this bitch.
Watch three cars.
Car.
What is the genuine car?
Beijing.
Yeah.
Watch regular.
Stay there.
She's all Stretton do shit.
Go home.
Look at this.
You ain't doing shit.
That tiger white washed out of the car just sitting there.
Why is that red car just sitting here?
They're all,
they're all on a sofar.
We'd drive down the road in your car and need to see these animals.
She thinks she didn't die.
The guy right after it.
No,
the mark.
I get it.
It's a point.
I do not want to see that guy's arm bar ripped off like that God damn car.
You're in fucking lying countries.
Safari.
San Diego.
Oh,
he,
this guy was trying to convince these lions.
Christianity was the way to do it.
I think they believe him.
I don't know why,
but oh my God.
That guy got fucked up.
He is in a bad spot.
I believe him.
He jumped into the exhibit.
Yeah,
man.
God is stronger than any of us can imagine.
Brian fucked up.
Look at it.
What they're doing,
they have to spray these lot of stamp.
The cats really hate water.
Well,
they just don't like being changed.
Oh my God.
There's the leper that came out of the roof and fuck these guys.
They need a baseball bat.
A little baby one like those,
uh,
those little one.
So he busted God right that boom.
Right in the season.
Yeah.
He's scared.
Look at fuck those cats because cats are terrifying dude.
Oh,
that's that real flat.
The living room.
Oh my God.
That's real
thing.
We get the biggest cat in Indonesia.
There were on a TV show in Indonesia.
Oh my God.
These silly bitches are in the cage with them.
It's trying to fuck him.
Yeah,
it's try the phone.
I was gone for that Dick.
You know what?
God hurts.
Oh,
my face.
Oh No.
For his face.
We going to get hit him on the head.
It looks like folks,
that's not a full size tiger either.
That's like a baby.
It's feeling as,
oh,
that's the female.
Imagine those laws digging into that asset.
A lion has claws.
Lioness.
I'm too drunk.
Imagine I forgot my species deep.
Those clouds are right up his ass,
but she's young,
right?
You think she's a young one?
I Dunno.
Lionesses smaller team,
but it seems
silly,
but it seemed like she wasn't that big.
Oh my God.
Oh Shit.
There's the female son,
Vegas.
It's a male Brendan.
Mgm Back at a hold that that bag.
You might as well just,
this is so crazy,
so crazy.
What are they thinking?
You think they got cocky?
They thought they could hang out with their friends.
Lions.
Oh,
this guy's about to get yet.
you got.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Don't show me this jam.
Eat that aren't so I don't want to see this.
I do.
I want to see this guy getting torn up.
It's just the,
just a tee shirt.
It's just like,
God,
no,
this is not good.
That's fake.
Oh my God.
Circus.
The leaving this shit.
Oh my stride.
I see.
I like the real ones.
I don't like to exhibit once.
The here's the real shit.
Is that an ostrich?
Oh God.
What is that?
It tackled it dude.
And they shot it.
At least he ran.
Oh my God.
Oh yeah,
red carpet.
That makes sense.
You dumb ass.
Oh Jesus Christ.
That's not America.
There's no way.
Oh my God,
it's got his fucking leg,
dude.
Fuck these things.
Like what is wrong?
Why you won't go down a red carpet in a Tuxedo like an asshole with all lie in a
lie.
And who's your date tonight line?
I'm going to let everyone know I'm so connected to the wall.
A real life story.
Not this,
but when we were hunting over there in Tanzania,
this lioness had cubs and we had to keep driving by in the jeep.
We know when we were hunting the lioness,
but she was getting mad like every time we drive by.
So one time we drove by,
we got video of it somewhere on my Instagram,
but she takes off after the jeep and we're like go,
go,
go and we're going,
dust is coming up and here she comes out of the dust and catching up with us to
Linus.
Yeah.
Will you in an open cheap?
Oh No,
we gotta fucking never buddy.
We were kind of laughing like ha ha ha.
And then she comes out of the dope.
She's like catching,
but you guys aren't,
y'all had your guns out.
Like come on.
But what if you had like one bad spark plug,
like won miss fire engines just hiccup and once shitty old carburetor they
haven't cleared the dust out of
and it just,
the fuel injectors get fucking clogged.
Jesus Christ and a giant cat is eating your asshole
just in case you have a backup gun.
No,
you need to get that shit in order.
Okay.
You've got to have that backup gun hanging out with polar bears and shit.
Yeah.
Don't,
don't hang out with polar bears.
That does not seem like a wise maneuver.
Those fucking things don't do anything but Jack Things.
He would see that video that I posted.
Um,
I forgot where I got it from on the come and national geographic snow.
A seal seal's Chelan and doesn't know that a polar bears in the neighborhood and
the pope or jumps up on the ice shelf and the CLCs it was,
and it goes,
it starts this mad sprint for the water and gets to the water.
As he's getting in the water,
the polar bears coming out of the water onto the ice shelf and he's running
towards him and he dives into the water.
Watch this shit.
Yeah,
look,
but seal is just like,
you know,
you know how we do killer whale one?
They watch this.
Yeah,
but hold on.
Say it.
Oh look at the polar bear appears up.
It realizes it's,
there it goes.
Oh motherfucker.
Oh,
this is just the Gif.
it's a different one.
Oh,
the the Gif on the video.
It's a gift to those classic gift to imagine that mean.
Just see if we can find that.
Or wait.
Joe D is called [inaudible].
This is it.
There's a,
there's a seal.
He's like,
fuck,
fuck.
And the polar bears.
Oh God.
See we dived right the fucking,
well Jamie,
find the one one posted.
Go on.
My Instagram got shit for water break somewhere.
My Instagram,
like,
it was a while ago though.
There's,
there's one similar with,
with killer whales.
There's like three of them and they're like,
fuck it right in there.
Teaching them how to make it,
they're making waves on a fucking seal this and then they,
they rock it off and it's done.
Yeah.
They put their weight on it and they tilt it and then make them slide right to
them.
These poor fuckers,
the oldest trick in the book,
we got on a site shelf.
Everything should be cool now.
I was like,
bitch,
shit on it.
Slippery to get away from it.
Oh yeah.
That's the seal that runs away from the sharks.
Yeah,
sure.
Smart Little fuckers.
Yeah.
The sharks were trying to eat the seals and so,
oh shit,
was it?
Sharks are killer.
Whales trainee says whale.
Oh,
so what's killer whale?
Yeah,
it's a killer whale.
A seal didn't care what it got up on.
It just so happened he will fuck with.
They will fuck with seals.
They'll play with them before they kill him.
They're so smart.
It's like there's a shark down there too.
And you know they're a dolphin.
What is killer whale or Dolphin cove?
It's a cousin of a dolphin.
A whale killer whale is a cousin of Orca.
All the cousin of a dolphin,
right?
Well,
whales and dolphins are similar in that the marine mammals,
but like as far as like this species goes,
killer orcas apparently are closer to dolphin.
I didn't know that.
They're super close to doff.
That's why they're both smart as shit.
Smart Shit.
But they kill each other.
Mostly orchids kill dolphins,
but orchids,
I think so.
Killer whales and it can't,
it can't.
They kill great whites too,
like they fucking punks at a great,
well,
they've killed great whites.
There's so much smarter and bigger.
Where do you see that on Youtube?
He has a video of a mama and protecting her house.
What does time that Youtube works?
Okay,
what is a a a baby?
What do you call a baby?
A baby or calf.
Was it a calf calf?
Barb Guy.
Isn't that weird?
Why can't we just call it a baby?
Why can't admit their smartest shit is weird.
But they kill whales.
Do they bite their faces?
So it's rough.
There's one video.
It really,
I'd love to see it.
It's a killer whale killing a whale and he bites his face.
Just chewing this whales face off.
Duct here.
Wisdom apart motherfucker.
The Yang is shit.
I mean Shit,
because the sham move,
we grew up thinking they're all cool and friendly to us.
A Pencil,
Tony Montana,
seaworld.
But in reality I Pablo Escobar,
I had read something that wasn't true.
I read something that wasn't true.
But as one of those things that you read and it sounds so awesome,
you don't want it to not be true.
But what I read was that killer whales used to kill people until World War Two
when they started using planes and they used,
do you use killer whales for Tiger target practice?
That's some bullshit.
It's totally bullshit,
but I heard it and I got so excited.
Yeah.
How do you know what the bullshit you're measuring that Joe.
Maybe it's real.
How do you know it's bullshit?
Well,
because is because they sent it on CNN because I'm educated MSN.
Just cause I'm educated that there's no way that was.
No,
there's no evidence that they ever killed anybody other than in captivity.
I'm just saying what they know as far as evidence of killer whales attacking
human beings,
there's almost no record of anything ever happening in the wild.
What if they covered that shit up?
Why would they do that?
The too busy.
Because the foundation and sea world,
they don't have time.
Is this?
Yeah.
See,
this killer whale is biting his fucking wheels face off or shark.
Here.
There's a tiger shark.
Tiger Shark.
It's,
I think it's a humpback whale.
They've never killed humans.
I don't know,
man.
It was a movie called Orca.
Maybe they don't need us.
Maybe they know that we're not competing based.
All right now
what?
Anything include hungry.
I'm starving.
There's bars.
Do you know Josh?
Me At the same though.
I tried to have one,
but I got in trouble with great whites.
There was a movie called Orca.
I thought you said,
you know how Josh fucked fucked everybody else.
I don't want to Josh,
Josh,
Josh Barnett fucked everything is in flux.
I know jaws
for sure.
Go in to guide their emotion because of jobs.
I know it's a brainwash,
but it worked and I'm a subject of it and I am not going in the goddamn ocean.
Do you think they're trying to keep us from the oceans knowledge?
I don't know why they're trying to keep us jobs that worked on,
there's the new jaws caucus.
The shallows.
Lively Orca.
Just like jobs,
but it was actually,
it was a killer whale.
Yeah,
it was a toe.
Whether Jack people trying to see that boy shit,
that friend,
somebody not want to go.
I think you're right.
I think 79 sounds right.
Was that the worst movie of all time?
[inaudible] 77 nice.
74 jaws.
Think about that shit.
Jobs ripped this,
this was
what year was two jobs was older than 70 17% on rotten tomatoes.
What year was jaws?
Okay,
I'm going to say jaws is older than I am.
Say Jol 70 to 75 this what year?
75 so it's old.
It's okay.
So this was jaws off?
Yeah,
I've got a baby whale.
We all knew that.
We just forgot because Peter Benchley wrote jaws.
Jaws was a hit novel,
right?
Wasn't it came from a true story,
right,
but wasn't a novel before.
It was okay.
Got suppressed.
I read the book.
I know I read the book was,
it was one of those times they used to make books and they would sell them and
it was the plot of the movie.
Peter Benchley.
They still do that,
but this wasn't that.
It was a novel.
Okay.
1974 novel and then they turned it into moving 70 shark.
Right.
That's the most
it with that movie,
shallow with Blake lively and it's legit.
See that picture posted.
The picture picture I posted on my Instagram.
That wasn't a real shark.
It was a three d rendering,
like a computer renders.
But did you want a shirt?
It looks like.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's,
I repost it.
It was from somewhere else,
but it's fucking crazy.
Here's the thing,
man.
Yeah,
it's a three d rendering.
But that's what a shark looks like.
And the sharks can do that.
Yes.
They can see the south,
that water.
That's all real.
I mean,
that's totally,
keep it up.
You're fired.
How dare you.
You just went crazy.
He's lost it.
How dare you look at that thing,
man.
I mean,
if that wasn't a real animal,
if that,
if there was no such thing as a shark,
that's your,
uh,
yeah,
you're right.
Five likes.
You're right.
That's the most likes ever.
We try to figure out which one it was.
[inaudible] 75 no,
that's not much in the rock
gets that shit.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
But look at the fucking body on that thing.
That's a real,
but that's the really what they're built.
Like they're a giant mouth with a body that had just fill up with member of
jaws.
They were like pulling license plates out and boots and shit.
I love sharks.
Sharks.
I wanted a shark tooth.
I had shark tooth necklace,
too many have that.
I did too,
man.
How about another mother fuckers?
Crazy bull sharks.
Tiger sharks.
She said there's great whites all all in hit down here from fucking San Diego up
to do you know the jaws was based on a,
an attack that took place in fresh water?
Yes.
Yeah.
All the New Jersey coast.
It was a true story.
Sort of.
Nobody wants to admit that the sharks were killing people,
but it wasn't a great white.
It was bull sharks.
They were bull sharks.
Dude.
Bull sharks are so crazy.
They can get all the way up the Mississippi River towards Illinois.
They can go that high up fresh water because there's a bunch of bull sharks and
tiger sharks.
Those are the super,
super aggressive.
When you hear about people getting bit and those are jackhammers making videos
with got a swimming with you.
Those guys are crazy.
What about that was swimming with sharks.
We get that one garages,
he breaches the watch.
Do you see that?
Did you see that surfer in the competition?
You see the surface of the competition,
there's a bit of white and you had to fight him off.
Yeah,
it bumps him.
Fuck all that.
We get bit like the next year to,
Oh my God.
Is it delicious man?
I mean that things flying through the air.
Yep.
Don't say it.
I was to say
and in living color on it was a female.
They every year,
you know every year someone,
someone in the California coast,
it's not a lot,
but almost every year someone gets bitten in half and there's a,
I shouldn't say almost every year like gangster three times that I have known of
over the past like 10 years,
guys have been bitten in half and the scariest one for me was this dude who was
compete.
He was training for a triathlon and so they had hopped in the ocean off the
coast to San Diego,
just about a hundred miles,
a hundred yards off shore and they were doing these labs and there was a bunch
of them.
There's a bunch of people in the water and it's great.
White came along and cut one of them in half in front of everybody could chew
Iem Chair.
She would get
you starting to think like,
why the fuck exactly am I doing this in front of you?
The guy in front of you see in Gulf by an airstream trailer with teeth and it
just cuts him in half and his legs go one way and it's upper body becomes this
meat stew just fucking trailing off and the frothy waters in front of you got to
swim through that shit to get to the shore and not even that.
Have you been in the water and just something to hit your leg?
Even seaweed.
I'm like,
yes.
Oh my God,
folks,
wagon door,
just closing on your part of the game.
Fuck all those guys that go out there,
they know that it's real and they'll tell you it's part of the Goddamn game.
It's all the chances are for sure.
Don't play that can Pacific Ocean,
California coast.
That's great.
White City.
It's not like South Africa tech though because it's basically that whole like
South Africa Ocean does is uh,
a Jacuzzi for great white.
You can't go into water there,
but on the,
on the California coast,
that's great white city,
but no one's going to attack the
Florida.
Florida's where there's like the sharks,
tiger sharks,
the black tips.
That's where everyone's going to tie in great whites.
Why do you think great whites aren't attacking people around here,
but they're tracking people at crazy in like South Africa?
Well,
they attack people in and the co two,
but it's not that often.
Not really.
It's not that often.
There hasn't been a death in one of the things they'd been finding out when
they've been doing all these studies,
especially they fly over them with cameras and they look down,
they're finding great whites,
a hundred yards off shore.
Finding babies.
Yeah.
They're finding the young ones here.
Let's go.
Right.
They breed in San Francisco,
they'll have a pop popular beats where all these mother fucking tours that in
the beach and like maybe a mile off the coast that they're monitoring all these
great whites.
I just looking at them,
they're in helicopters that are in plants and the adolescents are kind of close.
But they know that those,
those little teenagers don't attack humans.
I know that their people are in the water.
While there is some task force,
some great white shark task force monitoring the great whites to make sure they
don't get that close.
That's every day in South Africa.
They're there and they could spot them.
They could see him cause the water's clear.
What do they do?
And if they get too close,
they're like,
ah,
get the fuck mouth.
Why don't they put up like a net that anything would kill all the animals?
Oh,
anything smaller than like a fucking tuna can get through to them.
The dolphins and stuff get caught in those measures here.
Right.
I'm an asshole.
But I was thinking there's gotta be a way to like put up something.
They can walk on the discovery channel they had,
they had this guy put up like these,
these poles at the bottom.
The CLCs can be a beast to do have these poles and it would send off like just
fucking pussy that CNN,
Fox News,
Bro.
Yeah,
exactly.
Fuck.
Do you know Fox News is pro shark and you know,
I think it's cheaper if they
like,
okay.
We on the bill and Goddamn fucking fences.
I don't think that it's not an issue to keep an eye on that.
No,
they don't give a fuck.
They want the seals.
They're like one person.
Obama,
Obama.
Donald Trump to,
you know what?
I blame uh,
pharmacy companies random on power seven.
I know.
I blame Castro.
Hey,
what are you feelings on aliens,
man.
I don't even think about aliens no more,
Dude.
Aliens are like,
I look at aliens sounds though.
You don't believe in aliens.
I believe that all that Shit is government distraction.
Aliens.
I believe try.
I've been tricked when I was into aliens and all that Shit.
I believed I was hoodwinked.
I believe that was foolish.
I believe that all the alien shit is all bullshit to trick people and they
tricked me and they trick me no more.
Do you think like 10 or going the reo Speedwagon song 10 years down the road,
you're going to think our,
the tower seven thing,
it was a trick.
And then Trican means get out of here.
You know what I think for sure.
We're gonna wrap this up soon,
but,
uh,
I think there's
so really needs,
bro.
There's so little evidence
that anybody's ever visited us.
It's in [inaudible].
This is a crazy thought,
but think about it.
If there has to be a point,
if they're,
if the earth was at one time this thing that had no life and it evolved to be
the thing that's like,
today we're,
we're on the Internet and we're driving,
cars were flying,
planes were sending video through this guy.
It's entirely possible that were the first things to do this.
Even though we'd like to thank the university around for so long that for sure
there's ever other civilizations out there in this infinite universe.
Maybe
Brunette fucking mix slap,
maybe.
No,
he doesn't.
He doesn't
necessarily know whether or not there's alien life in other planets and there
might be.
But here's the thing about infinity.
The reality is if we are the first ever intelligent life and we're the first
things to ever hit this point,
would they be,
if we don't know,
we don't.
We never experienced anything smarter than us.
Not to say that we're so awesome,
but we haven't run into any other intelligent life anywhere in the universe.
Right?
It's possible they say that not only is this the first time that this has ever
happened,
but this is happening simultaneously in infinite worlds that behave exactly the
same way as this world,
an infinite universes that every fucking thing that's ever happened,
including our El Con,
including this crazy tower seven talk,
including is fucking incredible,
incredible fight between Bisbing and Henderson is happening to the exact same
nanosecond in an infinite number of worlds,
in an infinite number of times zone.
But,
but there's no evidence that we're here other than the fact that we know we're
here.
How do we not,
how do we,
not that this is
probably not just common,
but constant all throughout the sky.
How about how about one thing,
here's an,
here's a new thing that I never thought about.
What the whole moon hoax,
very,
there is no video of a video.
There's all this video of dudes on the moon with a fucking moon buggy that
listen up,
listen on,
but there's no video footage of,
you know,
video footage of boom,
here's an astronaut,
here's the earth and here's an Astra,
here's earth.
They went up how many times and there's not one swooping shot of the earth and
the astronauts and the earth and the shitty cameramen
to take pictures of anything back then was pretty crude.
All they needed was then they really think they released those pictures on the
NASA website,
proven fake Russian birth from moon that she was proven fake.
There's like two different ones they released.
That's bullshit,
but it's all perfect.
The picture of the earth is all perfect from the moon,
but then you couldn't get no goddamn video.
All those hours of video on the moon.
You couldn't swoop up to the Goddamn Earth.
You couldn't get any go camera,
no video of the earth from moon.
And we went,
how many mother fucking times.
How many motherfucker done?
Six Times successful?
There's no video.
They've got pictures that were proven fake.
Why are they faking picture?
Why they taking pictures?
China,
Jamie's already looking into it and he knows.
He knows that's real.
There's no video.
Here's one thing from the moon.
One thing they absolutely did fake is Michael Collins.
Somebody did it.
We don't know who.
Here's the problem.
You know,
it could have been an overzealous PR representative,
but Michael Collins from uh,
one of the Gemini missions,
there's a photo of him where they blacked out the background and pretended that
it was a photo that was taken in space,
but it's an identical photo.
Just reversed of how about that with him in a training?
Uh,
he was in a training program,
so he's hooked up a harness and the whole deal and wires in the background,
it's all over her.
Look,
you could see it.
I mean this is,
but here's the thing,
and this is just me trying to be fair.
Who the fuck knows who did that?
It could have been some idiot who thought he was smarter than everybody and he
worked for the Pr Department of NASA and they didn't have any good photos.
And look,
here's the thing,
man.
It ain't easy to fucking take photos while you're in a space walk.
You know?
And if a dude is really out there doing a space walk,
I think it's entirely possible that they could lie and fake photos and twist
stuff around.
I mean,
this is the 1960s taking kind of do whatever the fuck they want it to,
but you'd never seen this before.
I want you to see this.
I want to see it.
Cheesy habit.
Show it to Michael Collins.
Um,
spacewalk Gemini fake.
Yeah,
it's,
it's weird.
It's weird.
But see,
the thing is I try to be open minded.
I don't know who did that.
I don't know when they did that.
I don't know why they did that.
I don't know if it'll put them in one goofy fuck who worked at NASA.
He thought he was really smart and he was in charge of the prs it all.
We've got some great photos,
Mr President,
and here's one of them.
That's no Michael Collins,
Gemini,
spacewalk fake photo Jim and I 15 right,
so fake.
And then putting that on NASA's website.
They're putting theories there is just had a good look at this pictures and
that's it.
They can't get one in Mohegan showed the contrast.
Okay,
here it goes.
So go see the one on the left is him in a simulation.
The one on the right is just the reverse of that image.
Exactly.
And it's him in space.
Of course.
Yeah.
So what they did was,
was like,
oh,
that's like show that every picture is showing me some lobster gangsters
murdered people with a stripper.
And someone's saying,
look,
he's fucking that stripper.
That's all I need.
A motherfucking scene.
You know what I mean?
He's,
hey man,
best pictures
yet
all I need.
Example anther.
Okay,
that's real shit.
Let's bring this thing called gangster in a picture with a stripper.
And I'm supposed to,
and you're trying to do,
but she has,
she's a stripper,
but deck,
there's no proof.
There's no proof that they had sex.
Okay.
He's with the kids,
but there's no picture.
Kiva fire the kid [inaudible] k a Pq BGT.
Hey,
hope for real hard on Thursday this coming Thursday when oxide Braya then we're
up in New York for the comedy festival.
[inaudible] k.com as you,
I Ebi,
uh,
Haley,
I'm going to ask you one question before we go.
I saw something that yeah,
John Danaher was writing about palm strikes.
You're going to implement that.
I think about it.
It's for the first show of 2017 is going to be the one 70 Ebi tournament.
So it's going to be regular Ebi rules for the 16 Guy Tournament.
Regular Ebi 16 first show of 2017 but we usually have three a special matches
and they used to be,
um,
teenagers and stuff,
but we can't use minors anymore and stuff.
So,
so what we're going to use those three,
we would do a round of the 16 man tournament,
then throw a special match,
let everyone ref,
then do another round and then a special master to everyone rest.
And then that final semifinal round.
So before the finals,
there's one more.
So there's three special matches.
Now when we're going to do is us three special matches are going to be a four
man combat Jujitsu tournament where it's,
I had this clear through the commission years ago,
but it kind of got stalled with some of the rules.
They wouldn't let me,
um,
they didn't want to do it outside of cage and they didn't want to give me more
than three,
three rounds.
So Ebi was always about having combat Jujitsu,
Jujitsu with some palm strikes,
just to keep him honest,
just to keep her Jujitsu a little more real.
Because when you don't have zero strikes,
I mean,
MMA,
MMA is the ultimate,
you know,
UFC all,
you got punches,
you've got elbows,
he got kicks.
But I want her to make w Jujitsu just a little more realistic.
It's always been the plan.
That was before Ebi.
I was trying to push combat Jiu Jitsu through.
We have two matches to go onto youtube punch in combat Jujitsu,
we did two matches.
Compelling did a match.
Nate Harris from 10th Planet Santa Fe did a match.
We did two combat Jiu Jitsu matches and this style of Jujitsu,
no,
it's striking.
No Muay Thai,
no boxing,
none of that yet.
It's just par.
Just strikes when you're on the ground.
So it's,
it's,
it's generally for three different types of athletes.
I know
Brad cause them all times.
Can I ask you a question?
How do you define when someone's on the ground?
Let's say if someone is defending a takedown and they have one foot,
one knee on the ground,
can you smack him in the face?
Listen,
first of all,
if you're getting bored,
Brendan,
I'm good.
No good man.
Man's not hers.
It was a long explanation.
No,
I thought we were done.
Explain Shit.
Do it man.
Dude,
that's a long explanation.
No,
no.
This is my shit.
Shit.
I do it man.
We rapping shit up.
He was,
but I was my fault because I forgot this is something I wanted to bring up cause
I saw John Danaher posted about it and uh,
I forgot to ask it so it's not him.
It was me.
I just so fucked up.
Question you asked is real.
I mean you fucked up.
You told me you were,
we are ending.
Hey if you want to leave you could leave.
No good brother.
I'm done.
We're shutting down your feelings.
My feelings are not hurt.
You're the one that's saying,
Oh shit this supposed to be,
I'm trying to explain this shit.
No,
no,
no.
I interrupted.
You were just going to say Ebia and then I brought in because I realized this
was something I wanted to cover so we technically correct.
I think we were both way cause he likes does wrap this kitchen.
I plugged my days go,
you're like fuck damn.
You're ready?
Okay,
I get it.
You're in trouble.
You have to be
five minutes ago.
We're getting off track because I want to hear this,
this idea cause so you can smack to the head into the body with an open palm.
Before
Abi,
I was trying to get combat Jujitsu through the most,
the,
the Jujitsu style that would most,
uh,
best,
prepare you for a career in MMA.
Right?
So that's what I was trying to do.
I had a couple fights.
We did it at university,
Lma w got it clear through the commission,
but I knew that we couldn't have it done in a cage and three,
three minute rounds can I,
that wasn't going to,
that wasn't going to cut it.
So I decided that's when I decided,
fuck it,
I'm not getting the rules I want.
Let me just do Ebi submission only.
No strikes,
submission,
only.
Get that going and see what happens.
And then later I'm going to come back and bring back combat.
You get to,
and that's what I'm doing now.
I'm not eliminating Ebi.
Who knows what's gonna happen in the future.
I don't know what it's going to be like.
But the first show in 2017 is going to be a 16 man tournament.
Just like it's always been submission only.
Same rules,
same overtime,
but in between every round we're going to have a four man combat Jiu Jitsu match
where there's palm strikes allowed.
It's not an MMA,
it's not the most gangster.
It just makes you just so a little more honest.
You want to do this style.
How about I slap you in the face?
Let's,
let's,
let's get a little more real.
Can I knock them out or now you could knock.
It's called finish only Jujitsu because you can fucking Tko a guy.
You could knock.
A guy asked you this or you can finish him.
Can I ask you this?
What do I show him?
What about submission only?
What about karate chops?
You allow in chronic chest pump strikes.
You can kind of,
you can kind of bring it like it's a palm strike while you're hitting with the
blade of the hand.
And if you do that tough,
you could,
you could knock fucking people out for sure.
I mean you,
you,
you really,
you'd be well served to just ground and pound and drop these karate chops to
look like bitch slaps.
Yeah,
because if you're just talking about just,
or one of the things that boss Rutan showed is that if you can get your hand
flexibility,
good boss route and figured out how to pose hands way man.
And he was fucking guys up by punching like a real punch.
Like they dropped those palms down on you home strike.
It doesn't hurt.
See that's the thing is you can hit shit super hard.
We don't prompt you break shit with your knuckles.
It's really almost a better way to strike.
That could be a problem with a rich hand.
But we're going to learn as we go and there's going to be some tweaks.
Big John is very instrumental in all this.
The commission Cammo it's all legit.
It's not some Indian reservation shit.
We're doing it all legit.
Right.
And we're going to bring it in slowly right now.
So we have a 60 man tournament,
but in between every round we have room for three fights to have a four man
tournament,
we need three.
If there's hitting,
you have to have commission now because Jiu Jitsu,
there's no commission.
Right,
but do you worry about the commission there to worry about people getting hurt?
People are going to get hurt.
Fuck yeah.
Fuck yeah,
but you have to have like different kinds of services on hand.
We have the com now since we're doing this along with the 16 man tournament,
that regular Ebi rules,
we're going to have a four man combat Jujitsu.
We're going to have the commission there.
There's going to be all the stamp,
everything that that the commission wants we're doing and we're going to bring
it in.
Who knows?
It could go two ways.
It could be a complete disaster or it could be fucking something that that
they're just takes off and,
and we can't even go back to regular Ebi roles.
I don't fucking know we're going to go through labor.
I Dunno.
I think that it's a good idea.
So really good idea.
But I think that to achieve the highest levels of Jiu Jitsu in like the tactical
sense,
and I'm thinking you could have too much striking.
I think as soon as you start throwing wax and slaps in there,
like a change is shit.
Because once a guy gets that off,
you're like all your job is now just to defend against that and maybe you would
be offensive.
Jujitsu.
Why's it important that it's both?
I think both of us combat you get to is of the focus isn't trying to hurt to
hurt anybody.
There will be people that,
that uh,
take advantage of the rules and really focus on fucking Baas Rutan Palm Strike.
There's going to be Tkos.
It's,
it's finish also going to be guys that elbow you slap.
Those are legal and many,
even if it's illegal,
if you're going like this,
they coming down with slaps.
They might live,
add that to it and there's not a whole lot you can do to stop that.
That's going to be considered like a knee on the ground at a toner.
We're going to treat it this exact same way.
There might be,
um,
seems more qualifications.
Hey,
it might be a disaster.
No,
no,
no.
I'm just stay in the elbow.
Crush day one.
The plan for 10th Planet from day one was to try to make Jujitsu more effective
for when their strikes.
That's always been the plan from day one,
always.
And now there's an opportunity to make that just that a reality.
And who knows?
Maybe it's a disaster.
Maybe it takes off.
I don't know about we're going to do both.
And uh,
you know,
uh,
I just would,
me personally,
I think if you add some palm strikes,
it's gonna make your Jujitsu more real,
more honest.
And Not Anna May not,
you know,
there's,
we're not dealing with striking standing,
standing combat.
You have to strike a standing.
Is this wrestling?
No.
Striking at all.
So this is going to attract three different types of people.
It's going to attract grapplers,
Jujitsu and wrestlers that want to eventually transition to the MMA.
This sport is going to be a great way to get their feet wet.
Also it's going to take people that have had 18 and a knife fights and they
realize this is just too fucking intense,
but I'll do this combat [inaudible] shit.
This is Tamesha.
They look at it,
it's tame lightweight shoe.
It depends where you're coming from.
And then there's also going to be,
there's going to be three,
there's going to be your third type of person.
It's just a Jujitsu guy that doesn't want to go and in May at all.
No dreams,
never done it,
no dreams,
just,
but would love to take it to the next level because it's obvious if you add
Jujitsu with some fucking palm strikes,
it keeps it a little more honest you,
because when there's no strikes and it's just pure Jujitsu,
I love that.
But at the same time you're,
you're watching shit happen.
You're like,
man,
that,
that wouldn't happen in a real goddamn fight here.
And that would happen in a real God damn fight here.
So as a fan of the sport,
as a fan who came in through the UFC to MMA,
that's what got me into Jujitsu is the fighting.
So,
uh,
to me,
it's important that we develop a Jujitsu system or,
and the sport that goes along with it that prepares you for,
it's a Jujitsu style combat Jujitsu that will prepare you more for either MMA or
real,
like a little more.
We know,
and I can look,
one way you could look at it is like we have boxing than we have kickboxing.
Yeah.
Then we have more time.
You have to Jitsu and you have calm attitude to them rather than another level.
[inaudible] sees the Beth Beth tie over boxing.
Okay.
Let's boxing.
What about kicks?
What do I lend kicks?
We'll throw that in there.
I like it.
Yeah.
So it's Jujitsu.
What some sweats and will because it's going to go down.
And the of November 6th,
November six,
is that the light heavyweights?
No Combat Jujitsu.
Uh,
December 2nd in Mexico City is the Bantam Lloyd's Geo Martinez defending his
title.
That's just the same.
We have two shows coming up that that's not being changed,
but the first show in 2017 we don't have a date yet.
It's going to be one the one seven to welterweight championship.
Gary [inaudible] is the one 70 championed the welterweight champion.
He's going to come back.
That's going to be regular Ebi roles,
but we're also gonna have a four man tournament,
uh,
combat Jujitsu on the side simultaneously going along with it.
Who knows how it's going to turn out.
I don't even know how the fuck it's going to turn out,
but we got the,
um,
the support of the camel athletic commission and we're going to do it and we're
going to w w w it's going to be a,
we're going to learn from it.
We're going to,
cause we've,
there's,
there,
there isn't a sport like that.
We don't know how it's going to look and where people are going to exploit
little holes and we're going to have to tweak shit.
We don't know.
But the rules are,
the basic rules are if one guy is on the ground,
like if you pull guard and you're on their back and I'm standing horse stance
style,
I could fucking palm strike you right?
If I got neon,
the belly on you,
I get palm strike you.
So as soon as it got to be on top,
you have to be on top on the ground.
As soon as the guy is grounded.
Which means if a guy pulls guard,
he's grounded.
As soon as one guy has grounded palm strikes.
Can commend.
What about when you come,
you're coming up like say if you go to dogfight and then you get to one knee and
you pop back up and you both standing up.
When can you stop striking you when you get to dog fight?
That's a good question because sometimes you're in dog fight on your knees and
if someone could just upper cut you boss and style on the face and knock you the
fuck out.
Yeah we're going to have you,
that's a very good question right there in dog.
Fuck.
Cause there's dog fight when both competitors are on their knees and there's dog
fight when they're both standing.
So just like how Moitai not allowed to kick guy in the head when they're down.
You know you can,
you can trip them.
I can take them down.
You can't kick him in the head if you're in dog fight at both guys are standing
up.
No striking.
If you had a dog fight and both guys are on their knees or one guy's on his
knees,
you can strike.
It's going to be something like that.
But really it's all designed.
It's all designed to make Jujitsu more effective as a martial art because it,
if it,
if it works and it takes off and people like it and we do it for 10 years.
When people are and combat do you get to becomes a sport.
I guarantee you the champions of combat Jujitsu will translate to MMA a lot
easier than a champions of other grappling genres.
In my opinion.
I could be wrong,
but it's just like,
seems like a good idea.
Yeah,
I like it.
I like it as a new step from Jujitsu to MMA and die.
Um,
and Ebi,
November 6th is the next one.
Number six.
You can watch it on UFC fight pass.
It's a Sunday.
It starts at 6:00 PM.
Gordon Ryan is trying to take that light heavyweight championship.
Vinnie Maga classes in it.
Gibson saw that we got some bad motherfuckers in this one 2000 this is the first
time we've done light heavyweight,
two oh five and there's no champion and you know of any mega last wants it.
Gordon Ryan,
he's the one 85 champion and the absolute champion.
He's trying to take that two oh five that Danaher her death squad.
They're trying to take all the god damn belts.
Eddie coming.
This is going down to one 35 to take that bad boy.
He's trying to and and that's December 2nd in Mexico City.
Geo Martinez,
10 plan of black belt.
He's the champion come the Denner.
That's why they want all the goddamned belts.
So it's a beautiful thing man.
There's,
there's a serious war going on.
It's a friend of the rider friendly rivalry and everyone's improving from it,
man.
Every,
you know,
we're looking at what the with John Danaher's don't with them leg locks and man,
everyone's jumping on that and trying to catch up and word.
We're knee deep in that leg lock game because of what DDS has done.
And so you know when you draw DDS DDS,
they got that,
they got that leg lock system down like no motherfuckers on the planet.
You think you know leg lock.
Oh I think I could defend on Gluck's roll with one of them motherfuckers and see
if you could defend leg locks up every week.
So what that's done with what's transpired in Ebi with with the domination of
the DDS squad,
it made me realize that damn,
we haven't been paying enough attention to leg locks.
So for the last few years who spend a lot of attention,
I'm like left.
So all the shit that's going down,
just making us better and we love the rivalry.
And you know,
there's a,
there's all these little sex,
there's like the Ibj jam guys trying to prove themselves in sub only.
And then there's the DDS guys are dominating everybody that fucking up the 10th
planet guys,
Gio fucking,
he's battling like a God damn barbarian.
And then you've got all the random,
the random that has like Joe Soto from the UFC.
Fucking get into the finals against Joe,
uh,
against Eddie Cummings and just go on leg lock,
leg lock from way in the finals.
Joe Soto,
you have c one,
a 35 contender.
He's in there battling with Eddie comes leg lock for luck.
Luck.
Turns out fucking Dave to rouse a leg lock maniac who has,
eh,
it wasn't a big deal for Joe said he did,
ended up getting caught or leg lock.
But you're seeing those random guys like another random guy,
the Russian bear fucking Rustam Chizzy of Holy Shit.
So it,
it's,
it's a beautiful thing that's going on.
We're all trying to win.
We're all trying to get better where,
but it's a friendly rivalry and we all love each other.
And um,
you know,
we're just,
we're in,
we're enjoying the ride.
Beautiful.
Ebi Six.
What does it Abi,
nine
or six,
you got to try and pass and also you could,
you could get it on a ufc.tv or EBI official.com.
Beautiful.
And Cameron Hanes.
Cameron our hands on Instagram.
Who the fuck is Cameron hands on Instagram.
Instagram.
Not Change that shit over.
I Dunno.
They need to get on the ball.
You searched Cameron Hanes.
I'll come 500 visitors.
I know.
It's crazy.
But if it was another dude named Cameron Hanes,
why doesn't he let go?
Look,
man,
just take the shit.
I'm gonna call myself booboo.
My,
I got my own head ma'am.
But Cameron or Cameron?
Our hands on Instagram.
Cameron Hanes on Facebook.
No Sir.
Uh,
you don't use Twitter,
Huh?
Not really.
I do.
You do now?
No.
It was automatically there.
Automatically get on Twitter.
So don't be scared of Twitter.
Briand and motherfucking Shab.
We did it already where he said,
well,
you do,
so we'll end this and life.
God Damn Marathon.
He went five and a half hour.
Yeah,
we barely covered UFO.
Thanks guys.
Thank you.
Cameron Brennan Shop.
Eddie Bravo.
Thank you world.
We'll see Samara Cameron fucks.
Oh
yeah.